well the issue is just hearing people um
i don't
and whoever out there in the ether may
or may not hear me will
just restrain ourselves as to our
conversation
but
where did i put this one
where did i put this
i am opening the subcommittee meeting on
house bill 1439
relative to hospital visitation policies
and i note as a preliminary matter
that
there were
several sort of technical issues that i
think we could address fairly simply and
then
simply start in on on the rest of it
and this
as far as i'm concerned this is a very
open discussion feel free to chime in
when we get to things you need to chime
in on
the the ones that i
noticed was
first of all on line 10
and line six
the licensed person went to rsa 151
colon two
we were told that that was a really an
exact reference because
it includes things like renal dialysis
and adult day care centers and uh
perhaps doesn't include nursing homes
but this is intended to apply to nursing
homes so i think we might
so i had
i had a discussion with david ross and
right now they are required by by
federal law to allow
visitors
i don't want to do anything to
jeopardize their funding should the
federal government say you can't because
then that leaves us in more precarious
situations so i'm okay with not
including the nursing homes because like
i said
i spoke to him and right now
you know the federal government said you
have to let someone in i think that's
something that should be addressed at
the federal level because we don't want
them to lose their funding
because if they do that we cause more
harm than good
okay in my humble opinion
okay so my my question also is
would that same provision cover the
hospitals
that same issue
go ahead paul
well no uh what i'm i'm referring to
what representative rice just said about
the concern for nursing homes is they
are already required by the federal
government to allow
people accompanying right and
what they did but i mean listen if it
comes down
if it comes down to it that you know
this is going to affect hospitals too
i'm not bending on that
i'm not
because and i'm sorry that i get angry
but nobody should be alone and facetime
that is not it you know what i mean i'm
not going to be i i get that i'm just
i'm just seeking information here
right
the state okay or
joint commission or dmv
then you need to follow
what
because the cms is ever changing um cms
is reviewing those policies as well so
um
well we'll bear it in mind but there
isn't a similar requirement that people
have somebody with them at the end of
life that they do have in the nursing
homes is what i was asking
i'm asking about federal law
okay so
right
right obviously then everybody has to
take that into account but i i just
wanted to find out whether this might
all be moot not so we need to address
hospital issues
and
i i think that representative rice
brings up a really important point that
in the testimony that we heard
the issues that people were the most
concerned about
were beginning of life issues and end of
life issues that's not to say that
somebody who is sick wouldn't benefit by
appropriate contact with the people they
care about but
i think we want to be particularly
careful with
beginning of life issues i mean
separating a a parent from a newborn and
and
making sure that somebody who is dying
has
somebody there with them
um
so um i'm just gonna make a note that i
will find a different way of saying this
so
are we
comfortable as a committee
saying this applies to hospitals
and leaving out the nursing homes
just as an inch yeah go ahead
either one thanks um
i i would prefer
that it applies to nursing homes also
just because i've seen so much decline
in the
mental well-being of the people in the
nursing homes since the pandemic started
and they closed every everybody off
that being said i think either way you
can you can phrase
the language so that if there is a
conflict with cms
that
i think we could do something on the
order of to the extent permitted
by cms regulations
okay
yep
just as a side note so um when my
grandma was dying um and and she died of
covid they had to once
they realized that she was at the end of
her life they had to transfer her
actually out of the hospital into a
rehabilitation facility and at that
moment that was the only way we could
see her
so and that was extremely hard on her
because she was within
i mean she was within 48 hours of death
at that time so i don't know if
if we
if we say that it doesn't apply to
hospitals and nursing homes does that
overburden
these rehabilitation places to then re
have to receive
the patients
well what the bill does if we pass the
bill
is require
all the facilities that the bill covers
to allow visitation subject
to
the provisions whatever the provisions
are that we finally put in the bill
there was one other thing that i noted
just from the beginning on page two
the department was concerned about
the language on line four about each
healthcare facility licensed person went
to
rsa 151.2 whatever language we use for
that she'll post on its website
informational materials
and they don't want to do the developing
of the materials they want to require
each facility to develop its own
materials and i'm assuming that the
facilities would prefer to develop their
own
message so um
so we could just line out developed by
the department of health and human
services on line five
and the last sentence of that section so
it would read each healthcare facility
licensed pursuant whatever language we
use
she'll post on its website informational
materials explaining the rights
specified in this section
okay
and let me just have one more technical
correction here
on
lines eight and nine of that page
section eight unless expressly required
by federal law or regulation which i
think probably takes care of the cms
stuff but i'll i would take that under
advisement
the department or any state agency shall
not take action against any health care
facility and it was proposed to add in
their
action arising out of this statute
because if there was something
other
we don't want to
okay
i have a question yep
so are you saying to um eliminate a b c
and d and just no no no no i i i'm just
they're all they all stay there
uh i just want to be sure that
um
we don't want to
we don't want to limit liability unless
it's related
we want to limit liability related to
these this statute but if there was some
other situation
in which there was an issue we don't
want to limit liability there
um and
uh the last issue that i note is a
technical issue
on lines 14 and 15
um
and i think it's actually a conflict
anyway
uh on lines 14 15.
what we're what line 8-9 says is
the state shall not take any action
but up above it says unless expressly
required by federal law
and then it says failing to follow the
guidelines of
centers for disease control and
prevention so
um
i
we
what we really want to do is
to
ha to take that out because
they should be following those
guidelines
is the sense that we had
my question there is that
there's a difference between federal
laws and federal regulations and
guidelines from federal agencies
and
that that has a distinguishing factor
between when it's law or regulations and
when it's guidelines because there's a
different
there's there's a different process that
goes into developing guidelines we've
heard that they change
and i was curious if we'd be able to get
a copy of them or find out because if
all of this is subject to the cms
guidelines that should be available not
just to our committee but to anybody who
has loved ones in the hospital
anybody know how we can find that easily
or
if not easily at least find that
okay
thank you
so that's all the notes that i have so
jump in yeah okay so um one other thing
that i i want to make sure that this
covers and and you know keep in mind hhs
is not my area of expertise
but i did receive calls from people who
have
loved ones in rehabilitation facilities
who are unable to visit them as of right
now
and
she she was like one of the women was
like
i know his baseline they don't know
him why am i not there
to you know make them aware of changes
they don't know what changed to him they
don't know him right so she had asked
that we include rehabilitation centers
in this
and as you can imagine
so i had no idea kevin langdon was going
to do a story on this but can i just
tell you the amount of emails and people
calling me and the support this has had
has been overwhelming well
i
i don't think any of us sitting here
need to be convinced of that i mean i am
i am well aware of the concerns that i
heard when our county nursing home shut
down
and there were concerns on both sides of
how do we keep people safe and how do we
keep them in touch with their loved ones
and all of the issues of facetime is not
adequate for somebody who has dementia
they you know they may not know who they
are but
you can hold their hand but people
couldn't and even
when visitation started it was six feet
apart in in the parking lot so
um
i think i think the thing is how do we
balance out
making sure that people have the contact
that they need and that you know that's
across all kinds of facilities so we
need to figure out
exactly what we're going to aim at
because one of my things is
all the kids we have in in
residential group homes didn't see
anybody for months and
they too are people who
are particularly vulnerable and
particularly needing of reintegration
into
the broader society so
uh we've got
the the there's a lot to do but we need
to figure out what we're going to do in
this bill and what is the subject of
other
other bills
so i will look up 151
colon 2 and figure out about
the regulations and what might be a
better way of phrasing what we're
covering
other
thoughts concerns and i'm i am going to
give anybody in the audience if you want
to jump in with things that you're
particularly concerned about that are
still in there
now's the time to leap up and say so
so um
yeah go ahead
so uh a lot of the feedback that i
received in emails were that we should
amend out um
the exceptions to this
where
you know a healthcare provider could
just say oh
you know
basically could just nullify this whole
right um law and i believe it
is it
the exceptions are in page 1 14 through
18. there they are yes
so i think it was just a um
that the presence of visitors would
medically or therapeutically be
contraindicated
in the clinical judgment of healthcare
professionals i think that's very
broad
and open-ended and
just leaves a lot of room for
them to say no to anyone
would you care to respond to that
um
parents and
personal representatives
so we might try amending
that first thing to
incorporate the provisions of the
patient's bill of rights so it would be
patient-centered rather than
institution-centered right
etc they are
it's very hard to
legislate
their policies are
um
i i understand that it's relative to the
pandemic but i think what we're trying
to do here is balance out the
flexibility that you need with
some other changing condition that we
don't can't even name right now with
the care that each of us would want to
see
if it were our loved one
uh you know i think i think there are
things here i mean it it is
relatively clear to me and i assume it's
clear to everybody else unless we
somebody thinks we need to make it more
specific we're talking about one person
for each person we're not talking about
the entire extended family or
having your entire office come and see
you in the recovery room which happened
to me once and they were closer to me as
my family but i was still a little
startled
you know you don't really actually want
people to see you when you're drooling
but
um
so if
let's look at incorporating the
patient's bill of rights in that first
one and so that it's more patient
centered rather than yeah go ahead
either one
there already is a patient bill of
rights that has been violated through
the whole
pandemic
correct
so on that note
um should we look at bringing a penalty
for violating that patient bill of
rights
because if they're not
you know if if we've had this in place
and people have been dying alone in
hospitals without being able to have
loved ones even though it's guaranteed
in that bill of rights then maybe we
need some kind of
um
you know it needs teeth i i'm guessing
that a penalty is a matter for another
day because that would make it a second
committee bill and it would
need to be
and we've already passed the point of
that but that also is
definitely a question for another time
that was very very different than normal
operating procedures there's no
questions
absolutely
hospitals want to ensure that patients
have the ability to see their family and
their loved ones during those times
there's no question
you know
we've learned a lot over this period
things have changed
shortly after the pandemic began we
actually worked with the department on
creating some guidance around visitation
having that caregiver being able to come
in and be a part of that and that's what
our hospitals are trying to do
forget the fact
we want it to be but we have to have the
flexibility to be able to respond in a
way
that's that's what we're trying to do
we're not trying to prevent family
members
so if i may yeah madam chair are are you
yeah you're the chair right i am now um
so
again i say
that i don't understand how a nurse can
go in there
dressed in ppe with the mask
full blown but a family member can't
because that nurse can very easily
spread it just as much as a family
member when they go home
i
and therein lies my frustration
right because
if i have to do everything the nurse
does why am i going to be the one that's
going to spread it and not the nurse
that leaves that hospital and goes home
to their family
and i agree with you on that except for
one exception and that is
that at the beginning of the pandemic
people in my town
were
turning men's shirts
into
coverings for
the
folks who worked in our nursing homes
because there was no ppe and
i think that that's really
the point of a
and i understand the concerns about a
because
it it
but there was a time when we didn't have
any ppe we didn't have enough for the
providers let alone
other people going in
and that
that would to me
be a situation if we left a in
that that might be an issue uh just just
because of the unavailability
but i would hope that now that we've
been through this
that we don't run into this problem
again right we
we learned with this second round that
you know we knew was coming
was everyone prepared
that that is you know my question we
know now in the future
we need more we i think this has been a
lesson learned and i i would hope that
you know everyone is better prepared god
forbid there should be another nightmare
coming our way
well i think we've all learned a lot
yeah go ahead
certainly
thank you
madam chair
so on on a if if the concern is ppe
could
could we tighten the language to make
that clear and and perhaps
um visitors could provide their own ppe
even if the hospital does doesn't have
it you know just make it clear
um you know change a to the uh ppe for
visitors is unavailable
uh to be provided by the hospital
however
they may provide their own
and i think it would have to be sealed
right right nothing open like if if
people are going to bring their own
here's here's here's the issue with that
first of all on line 21
we have required
as it stands that the hospital provide
equipment
and in a time of
no shortages that
might be
appropriate we're also talking about
equipment that's expensive
so
um
right
yes
[Music]
yep
that's what i was referring to
well i was wondering if it might be
again it leaves things wobbly
but
if we simply eliminate the fact that
provided that any such required
equipment shall be provided by the
health care facility
well
if if it's may we don't need to put it
in there because they they can always do
it if they want to do it it's
uh but
uh
you know the sentence would then read a
healthcare facility may require visitors
to wear personal protective equipment
period
right
i i actually have a suggestion there the
words probably aren't perfect but um
shall be provided by the healthcare
facility unless there is a shortage of
ppe for staff in a shortage a visitor
can request approval of self-provided
ppe
how would you feel about that
in this is in for line 21 before the
period at the end of this
facility it would add unless there is a
shortage of ppe for staff in a shortage
a visitor can request approval of
self-provided ppe and obviously turned
into bill language as opposed to common
language
the language is very good actually i
mean it's quite clear as to what you're
intending
it said a visitor can request approval
of self-provided ppe
if it's not approved it's not approved
if you're required to wear if the
healthcare facility may require a
visitor to wear ppe and if what they
provide isn't approved then it's not
approved if you can't comply with that
regulation you can be denied
hopefully hopefully somebody bringing a
sealed package and something that is up
to the standards that are used in the
hospital would be accepted
if not i think that would be a different
problem and i have a lot of faith in our
hospitals and i don't think that they
would play any games like that so i
think that that would allow a respectful
dialogue where if somebody already has
ppe and they have it so they can go
visit their mom
if this happens in the next one
and one of if if i can there's
one other
concern that i had here
last year we had the change in the
durable power of attorney
and
that also allowed for the physician
aprn or a physician's assistant to serve
as that durable power of attorney if the
self-identified one isn't available i'm
curious if those the actual patients
durable power of attorneys are able to
visit them in the healthcare facilities
or if the medical staff is serving in
that role because visitation isn't being
allowed
so the the the people who have the
durable power of attorney are able to
visit people in the hospital
so
each hospital has developed their own
policies so they have consistency when
it comes to certain things again parents
end of life
they have restrictions primarily when
they're trying to do that they hope when
someone wants a covetation that is when
end of life at this point in time that
is
the other challenge has been our
emergency rooms have been um
otherwise um be here
in the future trying to fix this the
other problem i have heard from other
states that have put in laws
is unfortunately
folks are showing up at the hospital
thinking that they can come visit saying
there's a law that says i can come and
visit my loved one and unfortunately um
due to circumstances at that hospital
they have put in restrictions that are
not allowed for necessarily a visitor
and it has caused a lot of problems for
a front level staff and we really
need to avoid
well i'd i'd like to know a little more
about that because i mean hospitals
already have the right to do things like
establish visiting hours and and stuff
like that and then
you know there
there should be and
people have exceptions for end of life
ob gyn things like that
um
i guess my question is are people just
coming and saying oh i get to visit any
any old time or or are
or what kind of restrictions are the
hospitals putting on that have become a
problem because
the
the whole point of this seems to me to
be that
the problem is the restrictions and
i certainly get
that if you have an emergency room
that's so packed that you've got
people out in the hallways and and
everything else
that seems to me to fall under
b the presence of visitors would
interfere with the care rights of any
patient because you're balancing the
rights of patient a
with the privacy and the rights of
patient b
so
you need to make a determination there
um
because both of those people have rights
and
you the hospital are stuck between a
rock and a hard place because you do
have the rights of patient a and you
have the rights of patient b
so
that would be how i would interpret the
point
of of b
and that's how you get to the
flexibility of dealing with
you know what happens when you're in a
complete crisis situation and you know
we hope that you're still working at
making accommodations but
right at this minute
the accommodation can't be
i guess you made described what i think
could actually happen because you that's
your interpretation the next person
interprets it very differently
and
that's where the i think the tension
would be
um
but isn't that why the hospital is
supposed to develop a policy and post it
on their website
which they do and which they
certainly nothing in this
prohibits them from changing what they
have as a policy posted on their website
as circumstances change so you i mean
am i not right in thinking that
if there was a particular issue that you
you could
revise your policy
still have your policy
explain how you're going to deal with
the issues
but it wouldn't be under the same
conditions
well i think we probably have uh i will
just say that i know out there in the
real world we have a spectrum of people
who range from
yeah we'll will figure out about
reasonable policies too it is my right
to see my loved one any minute of the
day any day day or night and and so
by all means chime in but i you know
that is out there and that's not
something i'm going to advocate for
but
uh i do think that
uh you know i'm thinking about
similar bills that we've had where one
of the things we have
sought as a solution
is to make sure
i mean i'm thinking arts venues which is
very different but
they have to post their policy up front
and then people get to decide whether to
buy a ticket or not and
that makes sense to me and i know that
the two situations are not at all
equivalent but
what i'm trying to drive at is
what all what's required here is a
policy by the hospital and the hospital
has the flexibility to change the policy
um
but
they need to be stating the policy and
that gives the hospital some flexibility
and then
the poor candy striper or whatever they
have nowadays who's sitting at the front
desk
gets to say
here's our policy
it says you can't come at three o'clock
in the morning
and and and
they can point to that and and they're
not having to sit there
interpreting something in the front
hallway and that's not going to stop
people to come from coming and
demanding to see people and being angry
but i have to assume that you had plenty
of people who were angry in your front
hallway or outside your front hallway
because you couldn't get into the front
hallway before so
you know that's
a state law
i guess that's
what i'm still struggling with if they
allow the flexibility
they
do post it on their website
um
well the counter argument to that is if
you're doing it already why doesn't it
why do you mind if it's a state law as
well
but
go ahead and i'm just gonna just excuse
me one minute um
because we have people coming in for the
next hearing i'm gonna end it at uh
quarter past and i think i'll schedule
another meeting for next tuesday morning
if that's okay with people and and we'll
bring some drafting so that people can
look at it and will you send me your
language on that one piece so i have it
and i'll put it in but if anybody else
wants to bring other drafting by all
means bring it along and we'll pass it
all out and see what we can do with the
words
yeah go ahead thank you madam chair just
on the the question of
why why we need a state law it seems
that the new hampshire hospital
association respectfully i understand
that they really need flexibility and
they want it but
we also
our patients really need their rights
respected
and that's why we need this law and
that's why there can't be wiggle room
for them to just put in restrictions
whenever there's an outbreak of of a
you know a communicable disease
i think
the whole point is we were in an
outbreak of a communicable disease and
people were being harmed greatly by
these policies and and the flexibility
to restrict visitors
um during that time so
my concern for for a is section three
part a it still remains and i i think it
needs to be
curtailed so that they can't use it as a
means to wiggle out of this
and i'm i'm quite sure that
that section is the one we're going to
be fighting it out over in the in the
end
so yeah go ahead
thank you madam chair one of the other
points we might want to address in here
is looking at more access even in a
pandemic for an activated durable power
of attorney or surrogate because even in
a pandemic
if the patient can't make their own
medical decisions having somebody who
knows them and knows their wishes helped
to make that decision regardless of what
kind of spacesuit they need to put on
is very important to protecting these
patients rights especially if we end up
with another novel
novel outbreak like this where people
are just trying to find a solution
so that we can establish we can restore
some of the trust that's been lost
because i'm really worried about what
this is going to do to the health care
system over over time because a lot of
people
a lot of people feel like it's one side
versus another and we need to figure out
how to bring that back together because
people go into this profession to cure
people and help people
and
and right now there's a lot of trust
loss so if we can get those people who
are the activated durable power of
attorney or surrogates and have
perhaps more restrictive and more
specific language but allow them access
in greater
allow them more access i think would be
very important okay duly noted
uh with that i think i'm going to just
suspend at this point recess the
subcommittee and i will re-notice it for
8 30 next tuesday that's okay yep
and i thank you all there's lots
lots more to think about and
if anybody who is in attendance has
language they would like to propose on
anything we would also love to take that
into account
and on we go thank you all very much
appreciate it thank you so much
okay i hate to break up all the fun
we're having but uh we got to go to work
dog mom you're sitting in a very good
spot because we've had as many as four
dogs
right at that table this year
for reasons good reasons really
absolutely not that there needs to be
but i would take off my hat and respect
to the committee as i said to
representative weber earlier i'm very
proud to be a dog mom but
my parents taught me to take my hat off
to show respect so well we feel your
respect both before and after you're
taking your hat off thank you
open the hearing on house bill 1290 fn
establishing a task force on precision
medicine and biomarking
[Music]
biomarker testing and the prime sponsors
representative catherine rogers welcome
to
thank you so much
um thank you mr chairman and members of
the committee as you said my name is um
catherine rogers and i represent
merrimack county district 28 which is
the east side of concord i invite you to
go over and use our restaurants and
patronize our businesses while you're in
town
um i'm here today to introduce house
bill 1290 which would convene a task
force to study precision medicine and
biomarker testing
the task force would be charged
with making recommendations to the
legislature to foster greater awareness
understanding and access to precision
medicine and biomarker testing among
patients health care providers employers
and the public and private payers
you might be asking yourself what
qualifies and motivates me to speak to
the subject a poor attorney
no medical background and a year ago i
would have asked myself the same
question
but in january of 21 my life changed
when i was diagnosed with stage four
endometrial uterine cancer
i'm now undergoing
ah sorry about that
i
i'm undergoing intensive chemotherapy
and suffering from the side effects
the treatment has not gone well and
we've begun exploring alternative
therapies
and treatments some of those
alternatives involve biomarkers and many
of them are promising however these
treatments are expensive
costing between thirty five thousand and
sixty five thousand dollars a dose
um
and hopefully more and more providers
are covering that but many don't
i wish i'd been aware of biomarker
dating data years ago perhaps i could
have taken steps that would have stopped
or slowed the growth of the cancer i'm
now suffering from
nearly two-thirds of all medical
treatments in pre-clinical development
rely on macro data
in fact biomarker testing is available
for an ever increasing range of
conditions and diseases
however patient access to this testing
has not kept pace with the growth of the
science
more widespread knowledge among health
care providers and more efficient
coverage policies among insurance
carriers both public and private is
required to integrate biomarker testing
into the practice of medicine
an initiative and commitment by this
legislature
to promote biomarker testing
would contribute significantly to the
prevention and early detection of cancer
in new hampshire
as i said i'm an attorney by trade not a
medical practitioner but others will be
testifying today who provide you with a
wealth of information about the benefits
of this legislation
i simply ask that you move forward in
some manner so that we can spare people
facing the future that i may face from
appearing before you in the years ahead
for those reasons i ask that you please
support
and vote ought to pass on 1290
if not in this exact form
in some form it will accomplish the
goals that we've set forward and with
that i thank you very much for your time
i do have written testimony that i can
provide for the committee and i'll be
glad to try to answer questions but as i
said i think the technical questions
would be better answered by people that
are following me
representative weber
you won't be surprised to know that i
have an attorney question
as i read the bill you have taken what's
a pretty novel approach in that
uh you have this task force as a
subcommittee of
uh
uh the
shall convene yeah the task force is as
a subset of the health and human
services oversight committee and you
have also tasked the oversight committee
with appointing certain of the people on
it
uh
would it
i realize that it requires buy-in from
the committee and i can't
i'm not on it so i can't say anything
about that but is there anything that
would prevent the committee from
establishing this immediately as they
already have a mechanism for
establishing
subcommittees on various subjects and
my recollection is that as long as
there is one member of the oversight
committee on the subcommittee
is there any reason why they could could
not should they choose to do so
appoint this task force at their next
meeting
i see no reason they couldn't um as i
said the goals are to make sure that
there's more awareness that there's a um
imperture of official them that the
legislature is in fact um
making this a priority and something
that we want to look into in years ahead
i know that there's people
on the committee that have done research
in this field since the 1950s and know a
great deal about the field but i think
as i said the public and the providers
and then that group of people need to
know more about it need to be aware of
it we'd like to have an annual report
that can be there that's this official
stamp of the legislature that
this legislature sees it as an important
area to to keep abreast of so if there's
another mechanism of doing it
that will be quicker or we get to the
point i don't seem to have a problem at
this point
representative soloway
thank you mr chairman uh thank you for
coming to join us representative rogers
um you have specified in the draft
legislation a rather lengthy list of
commissioned members
with highly specific credentials
would it be easier more effective to
create a
a more agile commission of smaller
numbers
selected at the behest of the oversight
committee um i would leave that to the
judgment of this committee i serve on
finance and i'm an attorney so i can do
numbers and um and legal things i'm not
a medical person i don't know the best
way necessarily to pull this group
together this was as comprehensive as as
we could think of but if there's ways
that can accomplish the goals as i said
um that will be done in a more agile way
as you say um you this committee would
know better so i would leave it to the
judgment
follow up
a quick follow-up
and
given representative weber's comment
that we might
simply put this in the lap of the
oversight committee
would it be
acceptable to you to simply
let the build eye and let that happen
and get this moving expeditiously um i
would rather you not let the bill die
simply because the message that that
would send um isn't as positive as a
message it's saying we feel this is
important i would rather if if there's
another way to move forward to adapt the
bill
or to simply put it to
a study or or something at this point my
fear is if you you kill the bill the
message it sends
not that it's an intended message but
the message that it could possibly send
is this is an area that's either too
complicated we don't want to get into it
or it's too much or we're not we don't
think it's important and i think
i spend a lot of time with other cancer
patients and i think it's important to
to us to our families
to know that this is important
um and that's why an official stamp by
the legislature
that's that's positive
will go a long way towards people that
are are suffering now or are going to be
in the position that they're going to be
using some of this biomarker testing
possibly so i think that a positive
message is very important so if in some
form
it could be passed with a stamp that
says
this legislature believes that this is
something important for the future and
we want to see it keep going we want to
see
um yearly progress reports and so forth
so that's why i ask you very
aggressively
not to kill the bill but to find another
way to do it so you can send forth a
positive message because keep in mind
there's a lot of cancer patients
um and a lot of family members um and i
think probably almost everybody can say
they either know someone that they're
close to or have lost someone from
various forms of cancer so a positive
message isn't something they get a lot
and i think it would be very powerful if
this legislature could send a positive
message to that community
thank you
just a request of those who are in the
audience if you wish to testify please
fill out the pink card and send it up
now thank you representative folsom
thank you chairman and thank you
i'm sorry
[Laughter]
thank you for taking my question
i think i'm
thinking in the same vein as the
previous two uh
legislators that have had qui asked
questions
i am wondering if you would be open to
an amendment where
this uh
task force was
put forward in a bill but without all
the
the details lined up of who's going to
be on it but leave that to the
discretion
of
the oversight committee
um and then
uh
you know so it just becomes a little bit
more simpler so we can pass it and hand
it off quicker i understand and as i
said in my testimony i'm i'm open to any
suggestions i would suggest that that
maybe the committee work with um
mike rolo who's here from the american
cancers
probably not getting it right but
american cancer society anyway
because i know this is something that
they're very
excited about and so i would just ask
that you work with him
to move in one direction but i think
that all of us that want this to go
forward are willing and more than happy
to have
iterations that are different than the
exact bill
thank you
representative gay
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative catherine
i'm going to just say in the same
similar words
as long as we can get this through with
the respect that a bill gets
maybe we can amend it so that
it would acknowledge a
committee starting immediately
so we get both things we get speediness
and we would make it simple enough that
they could initiate it now
and we'll give the blessing of this is
important so that's why we're going to
make it into uh into an rsa i think i
think that would be wonderful and as i
said i would just ask that you work with
mr rolo from this cancer because they've
been working on this
all around the world and the country and
so forth and that they might have some
suggestions
follow up
does medicare cover this
um you may not be old enough i do i
don't i i don't know the answer to that
at this point i know that in my
particular case
that it covers it once you've exhausted
all the possibilities with chemo once
once chemotherapy is not working
um in my particular case then it would
cover some alternatives but i'm not sure
to what extent
so that's one of the the things that um
hopefully people can look into but i'm
not exactly sure at this point so
sorry
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative rogers for being here
today and i'm so happy to see you
my question is
the beginning of your bill says that
sixty percent of medical treatments and
pre-clinical development rely on
biomarker data i know that we have less
access to clinical research here in new
hampshire than we do down in
massachusetts and i was wondering if it
would actually make your goal more to
encourage well remove any barriers to
clinical research here in new hampshire
so that people can access innovative
care closer to home
um yes i think you're perfectly on board
with that in this
same line of thinking
thank you representative as the chairman
of oversight who will get to do all this
fun stuff with help
a lot of it i'm going to give to
representative soloway
i see nothing in here that says any of
these people
a representative a technologist so and
so on have to be members of the state of
new hampshire or residents we could go a
little wider on this task force
could we that was the intent is to to
make it broad as possible so that we
could get the best people to work with
us
we are fortunate in new hampshire
that we do have dartmouth hitchcock
which is one of the leaders in doing a
lot of work
in all the areas of cancer but i fully
acknowledge that there are experts
outside of the state thank you
representative merchant
thank you mr chair and also thank you
rod just for being here it's good to see
you as well
i look at this as kind of a
three-pronged approach one is building
awareness which definitely we need to do
and i fully support that actually
support the bill
second after we build awareness is
building utilization of it because
that's going to be critical to
help it's going to help patients help
people like yourself and others to
follow
the third one is not really addressed
here much and that's the payment source
is the economics to it and i would
encourage us to think about
once we get to the point where someone's
aware of it the providers utilizes it
but then the patient runs into the
barrier because no one's paying for it
and it's coming out of the pocket so is
there anything in here as far as
the bill or the amendment to try to
tackle that either
fiscal committee of new hampshire house
people from the insurance i see one reps
here from the insurance
industry but what about other people
coming from other areas that could help
on the economics of it i think that
there's probably other areas it was
that was something that was maybe down
the line a little bit after the other
two were established so i think that
that's why there's not as much in here
at this point but i think you're
thinking along the right line of how i
would think that
obviously if people are aware of it and
we've developed it it would be
cruel i guess to say oh here is this
thing out here that can save your life
but we're not going to help you so um
yeah i think that that's a great way of
thinking
representative woods
uh thank you mr chair and
thank you for coming and
as we've had discussions this is a
favorite topic of mine for some number
of years
um
it is a huge
undertaking to say the least and
sometimes if we bite off too much we
don't get much nourishment at all
some of the areas we are talking about
here are biomarker testing precision
medicine and molecular testing and they
overlap would
would there be any wiggle room to sort
of as a start focus on one of those
like you you're focusing on the
biomarkers in your comments
uh but
with precision medicine that's genetics
and that opens up another huge
area
and i think
would that be something that would be of
or do you feel like all three areas
should be included
i guess i
i always want everything
to start with but as i said i serve on
the finance committee so i'm used to
not getting everything
but you ask to begin with anyway so i
think
that
obviously it would be nice and it would
be helpful to be able to include
everything but if this committee in its
wisdom thinks that it's better
to start
small
or start not small but start in one area
and then move to the other
as i said i would defer to the expertise
of this committee and especially
dr woods representative doctor i know
that your background um as i say
ascertained goes back to the 50s on this
topic and you know more about this than
probably almost anybody in the building
so um i think your judgment is is
crucial on this and if you think that
it's better to target one area first um
instead of doing them at the same time
or doing the same time
i guess i would say i would defer to
your knowledge as i said i'm an attorney
i'm not a medical person
follow up
thank you
also
there are several dimensions of getting
to where we want to go as representative
merchant mentioned
the end point is that it's common
knowledge everybody uses it and it's all
paid for
but you also outline in
studying the role of clinical practice
guidelines
that
that gets into the clinical one's basic
science this is clinical practice
uh
would sort of leaving that part out
because developing that is another huge
huge huge ask
i i guess i would say i don't want the
perfect to be the enemy of the good here
um
so
however we need to wiggle or squirm or
whatever um i as i said i would ask the
committee work with mr rolo because
they've got some ideas and thoughts but
i think if you all work together that
you can come out with something that
establishes
or meets the goals that i've talked
about thank you but thank you very much
before i call on someone else i thank
you representative for letting us use
your room
[Laughter]
i've just spoken to the chair and i've
spoken to the vice chair and i've asked
what can we do to keep this room
um they said they'd get back to me i
don't want to go back to two i will warn
you it is very cold on certain days
however
um especially the folks that sit on that
side so
for the rest of you you're lucky but if
you sit over there it can get a little
chilly
they graciously have said nothing about
that but just soldiered on
representative kanark
thank you very much and thank you for
being here
my concerns do echo a great deal what
representative woods pointed out
and i'm concerned as well with this fact
that it gets into the science piece and
it is still some evolving science and we
have good people in industry and in
academic institutions working on it
and that's something that this task
force wouldn't seem like it could really
uh
make happen any faster whether it
existed or not
i was wondering you know should this
then be confined really when also i
should say advocacy is done very well by
for example the american cancer society
and perhaps better than us but we could
do some would it be better that maybe
this would focus primarily on the
questions of
when is it the right time that we would
be starting to
get this covered and how would we make
that covered
in terms of insurance or
medicaid we don't have control over
medicare obviously
um
so that we can stay out of the science
and stay in the policy which is really
more what the legislature should be
doing would would that be a comfortable
option for you
that would be a comfortable option as i
said i don't want the perfect to be the
enemy of the good here
um we have goals we want to make sure
that there's um a stamp from the
legislature that this is important
um and that it's important work to be
done
so however um
the wiggling or squirming needs to work
to make this work
i would be amenable too and as i said i
would just hope you work with the cancer
folks
on how you craft it to
to redo it a little
uh just to clarify uh representative as
i read through the bill it seems to me
that the about 90 percent of it is to do
with the task force
who's on it who appoints it what they do
and so on so there's really not a lot of
policy
in this except to establish the task
force am i correct right to establish a
task force and to give the
the stamp of of the legislature wanting
to move forward on this kind of work
thank you
representative
shapiro
thank you mr chairman
would you believe that um
being a reasonably aware guy i'd never
heard of the words precision medicine or
barium or a biomarker testing
and seeing the spill and doing a little
research on my phone
i realized that my daughter
who was suddenly diagnosed two years ago
with terrible devastating cancer
has benefited by just this biomarker
testing where she was they they were
able to identify the specific mutation
and
create a uh
you know a mutation specific medication
to target that genetic anomaly and
which has prolonged her life and given
her two great years
and so i'm so thankful for you bringing
this up
if anybody should be aware of this it
should be me and i was completely
unaware of it
well i i would believe that because as i
said
when i first was diagnosed with cancer
the cancer society worked with me to
develop this
but
i hadn't heard of biomarkers until
my oncologist brought it up to me and
started talking about it and since then
i have found um
i've done my own self-education a bit to
promote this so that people are aware of
it and more and more people that i
talked to
have reached out to folks they know and
found just as you did that it has played
a role um already in the number of
cancer treatments so the possibility for
the future is is hopefully very large
and very positive that's why it's
important that this legislature says
that
in some form or other and that's why i'm
guess i'm willing to wiggle all over and
do any kind of amendments as long as we
can now
give the approval of this not the
approval but the legislature recognizing
this is a future that we need to look at
thank you
any other questions for the
representative
uh representative mcmahon thank you
representative rogers relative to the
description on page
one
where it's stating the availability
of
patient access
and in the interest of
possibly
seen in other states
or other countries how this is being
accepted is there a existing paradigm
that could be used as an example right
now that you know about
of of these tests uh structurally being
available to patients
i'm gonna pass that question over to
some folks that follow me if you don't
mind because i would be answering just
off the top of my head and i really
don't know
so i'm gonna ask that that you hold that
question for um someone that comes after
me okay thank you i apologize no i just
want to make sure we stay friends you're
on finance we got to stay stay working
together without a doubt
no problem at all
anyone else
thank you representatives i have written
testimony i don't know
who i should give that to
oh
thank you
next up so he can prepare is
the aforementioned mike rollo
accept your phone number
and if you since i you and i are going
to be thick as thieves it looks like um
i'll need i'd like to have your
professional phone number your cell
number
various other means of contact
you can do that privately unless you
want to announce it to everybody
but i'm going to need to be calling you
on this
of course you can have my uh
cell phone is actually listed on the
american cancer society website so okay
it's not listed on the pink card well
you know you know why it wasn't because
i filled out the pin card without my
glasses so why don't i do this first all
right
for the record mr chairman my name is
michael rolo i am the government
relations director for the american
cancer society here in new hampshire
and for all the world listening at home
where my cell phone number is everybody
pins ready go
are we ready
six zero three
six six one
eight nine seven four
those of you watching the video use that
responsibly please
pardon me
oh i do not actually but they gave us
this one on top because it has our logo
on it so
but i don't have to wear it
but i can if you don't mind let me pass
up the written test
okay we get more of this there's more
okay
only because
i don't want to forget
we anything a tutorial
so i feel like most of my testimony has
already been asked by representative gay
representative liam lyon i'm sorry
leon sorry mr pronounced it perhaps a
merchant representative weber
representative salloway
representative canark and woods
but we should still do it anyways right
um thank you for for having such a very
spirited conversation about this
biomarker testing is
is really the way of the future in in
cancer care but it's already happening
now as well
and we'll get back to the actual
testimony but representative
gay had asked about medicare
it depends i guess it's the the best way
to answer it um
there are certain types of biomarker
testing happening right now they're even
covered by
carriers within the state of new
hampshire so there are
more common ones for breast cancers for
instance for certain colon cancers
so it's not
it's not that it's not being covered
completely
it's just that that i think the science
is probably outpacing
our ability to keep up legislatively so
and that would be part of i think the
committee's
scope um
i originally thought this might be a
stand-alone subcom
standalone committee rather
representative rogers thought it might
be a good idea to put it on the
oversight committee i leave that all to
you
our goal is to make sure that
this very important issue was studied as
representative rogers has said
and
legislative solutions are brought
forward but let me finish my
introduction so i'm mike rollo i'm the
government relations director for the
american cancer society cancer action
network
acs can which is a mouthful
and we are a nonpartisan advocacy
organization we are the advocacy arm of
the american cancer society and we
advocate for public policies
and legislative solutions
that will help bring an end to
cancer as a public health issue for
people
and that's why we're here before you
today in full support of house bill 1290
biomarker testing which is very
complicated and i'm not surprised
representative that you had never heard
of it because i'm not going to lie to
you i had never heard of it
and i do this i've been working for the
american cancer society this is starting
my 12th year
so
there's a lot to cover
so there's a lot to cover
but um
biomarker testing in case you don't know
takes why don't we read what a
definition of biomarker testing is so
we're all on the same page biomarker
testing is the analysis of a patient's
tissue blood or other biospecimen for
the presence of a biomarker
you say mike what is a biomarker
a biomarker is a sign of disease or
abnormal function that can be measured
in blood tissue or bodily fluid
and in cancer care biomarkers are often
used to help determine the best
treatment for a patient
representative
i'm sorry i
must represent a merchant i think must
have brought it up
it's like he had read my testimony ahead
of time which he hadn't and encrypt some
notes from it
but
the triple aim of us wanting to make
sure that we we can expand access to to
biomarker testing
is for better health outcomes
improved quality of health and to reduce
costs
biomarker testing is a heck of a lot
cheaper than
going down a road of treatment that may
not work and then having to start over
again
representative rogers had mentioned
she's exhausting
her current forms of chemotherapy and
they're talking about immunotherapy
which i don't want you to confuse with
what we're talking about today but the
very large scary number that she threw
out at you is not made up those are real
figures
and that's um
that could be in addition to what's our
the system
whoever her carrier is that she has her
insurance through has already put into
this so
we're hoping through through more access
to biomarker testing we can get better
outcomes for patients and for the system
in general um access to clinical trial
i'm kind of all over the place because
you've already heard most of what this
is all about but access to clinical
trials really is very important
and there are many that won't let you in
unless you've had access to a biomarker
test we only have one academic
medical institution in the state that's
dartmouth they do a fabulous job but
there are other options and avenues
available to patients that live in new
hampshire because we have such we're so
close to some fine institutions
in boston and the greater boston area
that um
you know there are limited access to to
those clinical trials based on access to
biomarker testing
and some of the the reasons why there
are there are issues to
to um
folks accessing biomarker testing
one of these days i'm getting used to
wearing these silly things uh improved
um coverage for borrow marker testing or
rather biomarker testing is is um
diminished based on
a number of things access to insurance
we've already talked about that
where you live
those that live in more rural places
like new hampshire
or anyone who lives north of concord
understands that more than i guess folks
will live south and southeast of concord
but most of the state is rural
and if you're not getting you're
receiving your care through a non-a
non-academic center there are less like
there's a less likelihood that you would
even get access to a biomarker testing
we'd like to help solve that and that we
believe that this study is a great way
to start
representative connerk asked first and
then followed up by maybe sorry i'm
getting it backwards represent woods
asked first followed by representative
conner about uh amending
and actually several of you asked about
amending but
we would be fine with that um i think
i've spoken to representative woods
separately and i don't disagree we can
take out some of those pieces that he
finds
are overreaching um and over complicated
because my end of the day my goal is not
to make things more complicated it's to
get folks more access to to this to this
testing and based on the conversations
and the study that comes out of
um
this commission it could lead to a host
of things i mean it's not just we want
to make sure that everything is covered
and mandated by an insurance company i
mean there are access issues based on
on what's even suggested by your
physician so i mean i don't want anyone
to think the takeaway isn't that we're
trying to attack insurance companies
because in fact we want them on the
commission because we want them to help
us study this
um
i'm trying to think of what else were
the questions that were asked that
you've got my written testimonials i'm
not i'm not one that likes to sit here
and read from and i'm sure you
appreciate that too but
um i wanted to answer one other question
that i'm happy to you can fire away at
me but one of the ones that was asked
maybe it was my representative salloway
ah my mind is fading so why don't i just
stop
if you don't mind mr mr chairman and i'm
gonna
be ready to to to take the slings and
arrows it's only fair since you shared
your cell phone number representative
canark thank you um looking at your
written testimony and we look down at
the bottom under disparities in equal
access yes
given that the factors here that you
list are precisely the factors that are
actually
universally across our entire healthcare
system not just for biomarker access
but for any kind of treatment whether it
be
maternity or just cancer treatment to
start with or anything
and certainly this is something we've
been exploring on the state health
assessment advisory council
it would seem like a lot of this is an
indictment of our
poorly functioning health care system to
start with
so i'm not implying that we should
somehow fix the whole health care system
but how do you think we're going to
somehow fix this one thing when we have
a health care system that has great
disparities built into it
that is a great question representative
and i i i don't when i was drafting this
testimony i certainly wasn't trying to
indict the entire health care system but
i'm sorry that's how you take it no i
did that wasn't my intention i assure
you but i only handle cancer i don't
handle everything else under the sun so
i would say that
the journey of a million miles starts
with one footstep in that
if you don't start somewhere you're not
going to get anywhere so
as i said my organization is concerned
with with cancer and how it affects the
approximately 8 600 people that are
going to be diagnosed with cancer this
year in the state of new hampshire alone
and we'd like to help expand that access
if i could though while
and i'm happy i'm going to answer if i
see other hands going up i want to draw
your attention to the last page of my
testimony because it's not from me i
have a volunteer that wanted to be here
desperately this morning because it
affected her personally her name is
nancy kearney she lives in silver lake
which i believe is your district
representative
um she had a doctor's appointment this
morning and i think all of you know that
it's difficult at best to get
appointments these days and she didn't
want to cancel not to try to reschedule
so she does apologize
but this is
what what we want to look at is actually
happening to people in this state so ms
carney who is a volunteer with with our
organization
as you can see in the testimony went
because to her doctor because she had
what she thought was a
less serious mole on her back that would
need to be removed her family has a
history
of skin cancer she's very fair-skinned
so she wanted to have it taken off and
then she thought she'd go and have it
looked at and they'd make an appointment
in a few weeks and take it off the
doctor said no you know what we're going
to prep you right now we're taking it
off have you ever heard of something
called melanoma
it's very serious it is the most it is
the most deadly form of skin cancer that
there is
um the doctor said but don't lose hope
there is something called biomarker
testing that we can have a biopsy of
this uh
of this
this cell these cells and we can decide
what the best course of treatment will
be nancy said fabulous she volunteers
with the cancer society she wants a
positive outcome
she had already lost her husband at 30
years old to uh to raise her children by
herself to a very rare form of cancer so
she didn't really want to not see her
grandchildren grow up so
she has a biopsy they send it off to a
lab in texas there's only one lab in the
entire country
that takes care of this and guess what
that lab is not a network surprise
surprise because it's in texas
i mean
carriers do their best to try to create
networks but you can't fault them for
not having someone in texas
so but we want to look at that
it goes off it comes back they find the
best form of treatment she gets the
treatment she's doing very well today
she still has to go for follow-up visits
but she's doing very well
fast forward a few more months and i'm
getting another point i promise she got
a bill in the mail for 8 500
for her test that was out of network
uh tough nut to swallow you know for
most people i don't know if i could
write a check for 8 500
i know i couldn't write a check for 8
to send off so that's why we want to
look at this i mean this is just one
story but it's happening to other people
in the state i mean these are real
people this is not mike rollo and the
cancer society is saying hey let's try
to
find something to work on i've got
plenty to work on it's just
this is a serious issue so
and this is just one patient's story so
a follow-up sir
may i see a follow-up i just sorry i did
not say that you uh were um criticizing
the healthcare system i did that oh you
do that okay you can do it all you want
that's fine so
since it you are focusing a lot on the
coverage because that is really the
thing that we can maybe have an impact
on and we can't make science necessarily
work faster you would also be
comfortable with getting this down to
something that dealt primarily with
coverage issues and so on okay thank you
i would the suggestions from from your
previously and from representative wood
about um um
clinical um laughter
so we actually read the actual phrase so
i don't get it wrong
clinical practice sorry we would be fine
with taking that out
and you know and if if you want to amend
this to be a stand-alone commission so
poor representative salloway doesn't get
tasked with doing it all by himself with
others that's okay too but i do make
this promise i'll help him
me too okay that this is this is what
i'm going to be doing hopefully for the
next couple of years with you all so
sorry
yes representative leon a question for
mr rolo thank you mr chairman and thank
you mr roller for being here today
i actually have two questions hopefully
i can ask the two the first is
i'm curious if you know how many
oncologists and specifically community
oncologists there are in new hampshire
and if there is any way to reach them
with these innovative therapeutics and
innovative
treatments because that seems to be one
of the major barriers i do not have the
exact number of how many oncologists are
currently employed in the state of new
hampshire
i'm going to
do like representative rogers did my
friend from the medical society who's
also here to testify in favor i think
he's still sitting behind me if he
didn't run away yet um might be able to
answer that although we so you know the
i'm going to get the acronym wrong nicos
the new england
the northern new england clinical
oncologist society
their acronym their name is even longer
than ours nicos
has been working on this issue their
parent organization which is asco which
is the american society of clinical
oncologists um has been working on this
issue across the country and they can
probably their their representative
wasn't available today to come but i can
um i can certainly try to get that
information from them for you because
they would they would want to be
involved as well with helping
with this so that's fantastic to hear
that nekos is involved there
my second question is uh when in my
previous job i worked in a lot of
diagnostics oncology diagnostics as well
and dealt with reimbursement at the
medicaid medicare level
and um working with that understanding
that there are cost savings when you can
target the therapy only to those who
will benefit but understanding just how
complex the entire entire reimbursement
landscape is
i don't know that that's something we
could actually address here in new
hampshire so i'm curious how increasing
increasing awareness and reaching out to
those oncologists to make sure that it's
a ground-up uprising uh might
actually get better treatment better
care to our patients without running up
into a federal brick wall right i agree
with you you you will not be able to
solve and i think representative connor
might have mentioned this as well you
cannot solve the medicare issue that's
a few 100 miles to the south of us
they're allegedly working and actually
there is a bill to address this
nationally as well
i think you'll probably pass something
in new hampshire a lot quicker but um
they will in washington um but we can
affect positive change for people that
are
uh
with private insurance and potentially
medicaid as well if that's what you want
to go that route is rooted as well
but you're right you won't be able to do
anything about medicare
representative gay
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my questions i never seem to get
one boil down um it
is this
am i correct in assuming that the real
singular
purpose of this commission is to get
care to people
which means which means we have to find
a way to get it paid for
as well as notify people make sure
but do you really have a hard time
getting to reach oncologists since it
seems like they would be really
fascinated with every tool
accessible to them well i don't want to
speak for the oncologist as a whole
but i do know that um
we have had volunteers in the past tell
us that they had issues
with access to clinical trials they
hadn't never heard of it i think much
like
representative merchant not merchant i'm
sorry so shapiro shapiro sitting next to
him um had mentioned
you know
they may have actually said it look i
i have
now lost let's see in the last
no sorry i don't exaggerate 28 years
my father
two aunts and an uncle
to to various forms of cancer
we are now helping a dear friend of ours
who's got a cancer diagnosis and and my
wife's grandmother is going through a
lung cancer treatment
as caregivers
yeah cancer affects everyone in the
state of new hampshire as you know
representative
when you are dealing with this diagnosis
they may have actually said it to you
when you hear those those little words
you have cancer it's like charlie
brown's teacher is talking to you right
you're hearing this
in your ear so i'm not trying to
disparage the the medical community but
not all
oncologists are probably created equal i
think we can agree on that i mean there
are
different doctors doing different things
all over the world so
and they you know i i
i think it depends i mean i don't i
don't want to paint any one person in a
box i think it just depends on where
they're receiving their care
follow-up representative gay thank you
so
pr
educating people is really a big deal it
is indeed yes and i do agree because i
i just found out about proton radiation
and there may be one
in new england
and one in houston and you know it's
just not
common but it's there
they're the
the good thing if you have want to say
one good thing about cancer i don't
typically have many good things to say
about it
it is an ever-evolving science
and we have made terrific
amazing strides in the last
decade or two in treating
certain types of cancers and making them
chronic illnesses not death sentences as
they would have been at one time
but that's only come out of research
and as you say pr i mean
a lot of what i work on is also about
prevention um
getting people to to get their
preventative screenings for instance
getting them not to smoke um
those things you know trying to help
people before they develop a cancer but
i think you're absolutely 100 correct
part of this also would be looking at
how are our patients receiving or not
receiving this information
um
it's it's a it's a lot to take on for
sure and and i don't think it's going to
be solved in in a month or two it's it's
a it's a multi-year again i'm sorry
represents all the way a multi-year
and representative pearson a multi-year
[Music]
approach it truly has to be if you're
going to do this
do this
[Music]
correctly i mean i could have asked
representative rogers hey you know what
these big bad insurance companies aren't
covering everything under the sun let's
put in a mandate to do that and john
hunt who was my chairman at one time
would laugh me out of the room and tell
me to go back to well he thinks he
doesn't i don't think he knows where i
live anymore but he told me to go back
to the cecos
um
and rightfully so because it's not as
thought out i mean i think this is a
very serious issue that needs a very
serious study so i think i've answered
more than you probably wanted to hear
but i'm sorry it's
it's uh it's a passion it's not
questions for mr rolo before we move on
to other speakers representative soloway
you get your vengeance
thank you mr chairman uh it's nice to
have you here mr rolo you have your
testimony of course always comes highly
praised by one of my county
commissioners
i did a little bias man
i wonder if you could track for the
committee
the transition that's occurred in
oncology
from primary diagnosis by sight of
diagnosis
to biomarkers for diagnosis and why that
is vitally important
can you do that for us if
if you can't that's fine i'll understand
but it
i thought it was so important
that you might want to educate us right
well i will do my best and i i am
i i'm going to give this caveat i am not
a medical doctor i am
to my my right i'm flanked by two um
very
very esteemed physicians so
i'm gonna do my best and they can stick
her and laugh at me after i leave but
and that's okay um
if i'm understanding your question
correctly
how let me ask it back to make sure i'm
understanding i don't want to ramble on
and it's not what you wanted to hear um
okay i can do that
you want to know
how
a biomarker
test at the beginning of diagnosis can
help with treatment or i might not be
understanding your question i'm sorry um
there's been a transition in
uh oncologic diagnosis
from
diagnosis based on primary site of tumor
yes okay
okay biomarkers okay yes so
you're correct so i try not to get
i'm not a technical person again i'm not
a doctor but i will i will do my best so
i think what you're asking me is
at one time
they would have diagnosed the cancer
they would have been let's make it very
easy
there is a tumor
you pick wherever you want it to be they
would cut it out
and they may
that may be it or they may have to then
do radiation to shrink the tumor because
they can't cut it out
or they're going to pump you full of
poisons
also known as chemotherapy to kill all
the cells and hopefully kill all the
cancer cells and not hopefully all the
ones that are keeping you alive at the
same time
um
and then they would
hopefully would go into remission and
you would have a few years hopefully
of positive life left right is that
and then now
um
[Music]
i think that well let me
it's practically part of my testimony i
didn't read so maybe you're doing me a
favor i appreciate this representative
because
sometimes a little scatter brain
very scatter brain 37 of the 62 oncology
drugs launched in the past five years
have required or are recommended that
your buyer test be used prior to use
new oncology drugs
therapies
most of the therapies these days are
targeted they're using precision
medicine
to to attack a tumor
there are
things like representative rogers has
just mentioned immunotherapies
where they are able to rep take your
cells or your
part of you let's just say that i don't
want to misspeak and and create
a
a treatment based on your genetic
structure your genetic makeup of your
cells
or or the cancer cell rather
to combat that specific cancer based in
your body not just let's stick an iv
drip in you and hope for the best
they're very expensive
and
we we're not talking about that at the
moment but that's another separate issue
but that we're not going to solve here
but
um
so
treatments today
not all
but are moving more towards how do we
best
suit the treatment to the individual and
not the this is all we have let's throw
the kitchen sink at it approach
and and a big piece of being able to
[Music]
utilize these new very specific targeted
therapies are based on
what the biomarkers are if there are any
of the particular type of cancer they
are trying to eradicate
am i answering it okay i want to make
sure i was understanding if not as
rambled on for quite a long mr rolo i'm
going to thank you for your testimony
and we are going to move on i appreciate
and again mr chairman i am here you have
my number and i'll send you my so um
i'm going to email the testimony in as
well so it'll all be in my tagline you
can have my email and all that too thank
you very much the chair recognizes john
williams and janice emery from the
department
good morning chairman pearson members of
the committee uh for the record john
williams the director of legislative
affairs for the department of health and
human services and with me is
janice emery legal resident at the
department under mr
williams and we're here just to make
three three primary points one is we
want to thank the prime sponsored bill
representative kathy rogers for bringing
this important legislation before this
committee as we've seen in evolving
science whether it's the internet
whether it's 5g technology as you
probably know
represent a group to research that the
goal here is to get ahead of the at
least the technology and access to
healthcare and we do think that that's
exactly what uh reference rogers is
trying to accomplish with this
legislation so that's point number one
point number two is how do we advance
this um well-intended uh and an
important initiative going forward and
as we know from prior bills that have
come before this committee dealing with
either study committees
or similar entities there is a very
conscientious approach by the leadership
to reduce the number of those entities
that are out there so really there's two
paths that this committee could follow
the one that was suggested by rev weber
earlier on when she identified pursuant
to and i'll speak slowly at this point a
person went to rsa 126 colon 15
roman 2. there's a mechanism for the
committee as we know from chairman
pearson who serves in both capacities
here on the policy committee as well as
the chair for hhs oversight the ability
to create councils task force
subcommittees and it actually identifies
task force as being one of the entities
that can be created
the
upside of that for consideration of the
committee and the legislature is that
you could convene
a study committee task force much more
efficiently and faster than the proposed
legislation would be able to be enacted
before the committee the downside is it
does sunset at the end of the biennium
just like the
oversight committee itself and would
have to be reconstituted in the next
biennium the legislation before you has
a sunset provision for november 1st of
2024 so it in essence caught it
conceptually puts forward the idea of
going into the next biennium so there is
a mechanism to doing that either in
existing law that allows the oversight
committee to establish a task force like
this and in fact this legislation can be
used as a charter for that provision as
also appropriate accurately identified
by representative weber there is a
requirement that a legislator is not
actually a committee member but a
legislator does have to serve on the
task force in this occasion and also
would have to be the um would have to be
the chair of that committee as well one
item that is missing and i worked with
our law clerk who recently drafted up a
legislation around a commission it does
um does not contain in the legislation a
provision for quorum requirement uh and
it also doesn't um specify when the
first meeting is to be called by and
whom by is going to be called the first
meeting so those are just a couple of
technical issues to look at okay third
part
the belief is that the drafters at the
office of legislative services utilized
an existing permanent
commission
rather committee under hhs oversight so
another rsa that i'll speak slowly at
this point which is rsa 126
a 15 lower case a which in 2014 and uh
and i know several of you who are still
with us from that era uh worked with us
on that legislation to establish a
permanent subcommittee under the
oversight committee for alzheimer's and
related dementia so there is a
president for what is trying to be
accomplished here within the task force
and what they are tending to do is after
that particular
committee on alzheimer's and related
dimension they're creating a new
subsection 15 lowercase b that's what
this legislation does and it does mirror
the language actually of that permanent
subcommittee the difference here is this
would be a sunsetted
provision not a permanent group as
before so the fact that it's already
contemplated that they're not intending
to be a permanent commission which i
think is distinguishable which is my
last point about the existing alzheimer
dementia uh we we are certainly fully
supportive of this issue being addressed
uh by the legislature and we applaud the
efforts of the prime sponsor for the
bill
i intended that we probably might get a
question regarding application to
medicaid as it relates to it and i can
reserve questions but those are
essentially my three points unless the
wonderful soon-to-be attorney some in
the near future janice has
miss emery would have anything to add
i think that mr williams covered the two
just minor
things within the bill um the technical
discrepancies and so i think that i have
nothing further to add at the moment
thank you spoken like a good friel thank
you
representative canuck a quick question
you mentioned medicaid do we have the
authority to uh
to change coverage and get coverage for
this
in medicaid
that is that is a good question and i
would imagine that when this group is
constituted we would have um a subject
matter expert from the department to
come here a mind is jane hitch
jane is a registered nurse who also is
very much involved with the
medicaid
and what is covered under medicaid for
provisions i spoke with miss hitch prior
to this meeting just confirmed that we
do in fact receive from the managed care
organizations as resident land had
pointed out for targeted therapy we do
actually now uh specify and work on a
case-by-case basis for appropriate
medication based upon these kind of
tests for uh
for genetic markers so we do currently
do that on a case-by-case basis but
certainly from an access standpoint and
globally as it goes from a case-by-case
basis uh looking at a more global for a
actual um not having to do it on
that basis
representative gay
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question now that you have
showed us multiple multiple avenues
towards creating study committees are
fancier than committees
is there any way that we could start a
committee now
that leads then would be adopted if we
pass this you know modify this to to say
the right thing
can we start now
bless it with the the bill
that would adopt it
so that we wouldn't have to wait until
it was signed by the governor it could
start but then it would become
legal or
more permanent buy the bill
so that it could continue
since you said this already is
thinking enough to get to 2024 but
isn't there some way to get it started
now
yes
brevity
thank you counselor and intern the chair
recognizes michael padmore from the new
hampshire medical society
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee good morning everyone uh my
name is mike padmore i'm the director of
advocacy with the new hampshire medical
society um i'll be relatively brief
because i think we've heard from a few
experts
on the intent of this bill what i really
wanted to just come and speak to is just
um
uh
first off thanking representative rogers
for filing this bill but then thanking
mr rollo for coming to us
last fall and and really just wanting to
engage the the medical community uh on
what our thoughts were around this bill
so i spoke with some folks um in the
oncology community in the pathology
community just to get a sense of where
they um might stand any feedback that
they might have
and in general um you know this was an
issue access to biomarker testing
that they were supportive of and when it
came to setting up a task force
you folks will all you know decide kind
of what form that takes um but they were
uh in general very supportive and would
just love to be involved in whatever
this bill whatever form this bill takes
um
so what i would just say is um please
keep us involved um i'll certainly work
with mr rolo i heard there was one
question from representative leon
in regard to the number of oncologists
in new hampshire i can certainly talk
with some of my contacts in that
community and then work with mr rolo to
follow up with you on that
and i'll be briefly in my testimony
there happy to answer any questions but
all together would just love to be
involved as we move forward in this
thank you mr padmore representative
folsom
thank you chairman and thank you for
taking my question
when we look at this list of incredible
people that need to be on this task
force
we have a hard time
finding people to serve
you've talked with your oncologist and
pathologists and i'm wondering are they
showing a willingness
to uh get their feet dirty and come join
some legislators
and be a part of the task force do you
think you would be able to help us
recruit those people yeah thank you for
the question and the answer is
absolutely yes that was actually really
the first thing that i talked to them
about was i said you know
can you start engaging your community to
find out maybe who would be the right
experts to be part of this and there's
an email chain going on right now
so uh certainly happy to follow up
however you want to list that in the
bill whether it's the medical society
making those appointments or whoever
that might be but happy to work with
whoever is the uh you know the appointer
um and um and make sure we can write
find the right folks wonderful thank you
representative gabe for one question
yes sir um thank you is it possible to
uh
turn a gathering
like being on the commission
to turn that into something that the
doctors who participate would get
continuing education
credits
as a carrot thank you for the question
and i'll also probably thank you on
behalf of the doctors uh they are always
looking for opportunities to do that i
don't know if that would be the case but
as my role within the medical society
that's probably one of the things that i
can do so i'll um i guess what i'll do
is as this continues to move forward
i'll explore you know what that might
look like because um the short answer is
i don't know but
i'll certainly look into it
okay representative leon last question
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question
i just wanted to see if you could reach
out to new hampshire on hematology
oncology they're involved with the main
cancer genomics initiative which is
working out of the jackson lab that
makes the jax mice it sounds like maine
has an amazing system going in order to
spread this into community oncology and
if we can take their best practices or
maybe glom onto our neighbor and work
with them we might be able to solve this
problem so i'd appreciate if you could
help us with that would you be able to
definitely and i was just taking down a
note and what i'll do is i'll follow up
with you just to make sure that i have
the right the right note down and happy
to reach out to them thank you
representative
weber sorry
having a brain cramp
thank you as a quick note on the
participation issue
would it not be easier
to find participants both from your
organizations and other organizations
from people who are very busy if this
legislature chose to allow remote
participation
um
thank you for the question
certainly that is always um does make
participation easier um a number of the
folks who i have spoken with are from
the dartmouth-hitchcock
community and you know considering that
is about an hour away from here uh
remote technology would make that a
little easier so i'll leave that all to
you but i'll certainly say it would be
easier
thank you mr padmore and with that i
closed the hearing on house bill 1290
now
before we get off that topic even though
the hearing itself has been closed
i'm hearing that it would be a good idea
for a work group to be convened to look
at a number of the possibilities and
options that we have heard
and i'm wondering who might like to be
on that work group
representative woods
representative leon representative
gay any anyone else we could use
probably two or three more a question mr
chairman yeah
would you prefer to wait for the meeting
a week from friday of the oversight
committee
and to ask the oversight committee to
move forward in that direction
representative williams needs to be in
on this
i'm not representative but john esquire
the question from representative soloway
was did it seem good to put this on
oversight's agenda a week from friday
and as the committee chair if you
instruct me it will be on the agenda
could you stretch our two hours to make
it seem shorter because we got a lot of
stuff on the plate we actually do have
quite a bit on the agenda for this
coming um on the 25th
let me consider it i would like to go
forward with the work group
even if oversight just makes some
decisions
uh two different sets of minds
can then bounce off each other
uh anybody else thank you rep
i keep demoting you um
any other representative
wish to be
on the work group i have woods leon and
gay presently i would like a few more
did i i don't see a hand i should
probably not be on this actually um
all right rep uh you don't want to be on
okay and uh representative mckay
i think we're running we still are short
that's what the kick under the table was
okay
why would it not
okay so we have now representatives
woods gay mckay soloway leon
representative rogers i hope you would
join in on this
group if you wish
and i'm going to say that whatever it is
i need it back for us to exact by march
7th that is your drop down dead date
if you are
wanting to do this as a formal work
group
please let me know when the first
meeting is going to be so it can be put
in the calendar
which means i need to know that by noon
o'clock tomorrow
so during a break if if the five of you
could consult with each other please
get back to me
before i uh go on to the next hearing i
want to remind not everybody was in the
room when this was announced yesterday
committee members have a pen and paper
handy this is our upcoming schedule
our next meeting will be not
on monday because it's president's day
the place is closed
our next meeting will be on the 22nd
tuesday
we're taking off monday the 28th and
tuesday march 1st
we're taking off that means we don't
meet
on monday the 28th
tuesday march 1st we are not meeting
don't come well you can but we won't be
here
we will meet
on the 7th of march
here in this room
we've got a lot of executing to do
we will meet if needed and i guess it
will be needed
on march 8th the tuesday at a place
to be named
i've suggested tandy's they told me we
can't
so there's the schedule going forward
don't ask i've read it twice slowly and
i read it yesterday if you were working
on a bill amendment or something
uh it would be very helpful if we had
some of those ready by the twenty
seconds
oh boy
open the hearing on house bill 1606
making the state vaccine registry an
opt-in program
and we are honored to have the chairman
of fish and game representative lange to
present his bill
thank you mr chairman thank you
committee members for
accepting my testimony i'm
representative tim lang i represent
belknap four i'm in my third term and as
the sheriff mentioned i'm currently the
chairman of the house fish and game
committee
um this committee i also serve on ways
and means in jalcar and this committee
though is probably becoming one of my
favorites to come visit because
i think it's your gregarious chairman
and his wit that he applies and the
intelligent questions the committee asks
thank you for your discernment
sir pandering done um
so i introduced this bill uh we've seen
this bill before
this bill uh makes a change to our
current law regarding the vaccine
registry um one of the reasons for this
bill as as we've stated before is that i
i think it might be interesting to
understand that in our current law under
um 141c 20
f
nowhere does it use the word opt-in or
opt-out
not in one single place or the entire
law is that defined that's defined by
the department they decided what was
going to happen to this registry and how
it was going to be treated
so i'm looking to define that
considering again we go back to um
one of the reasons for this bill
is our constitution right and i've made
this statement before in front of the
committee we know that in 2018
when i served my first term there was a
constitutional amendment that was voted
on in the house that passed both the
house and senate ended up on the ballot
in november of 2019
that ballot asked the citizens a simple
question shall we add this new amendment
to our constitution the amendment read
right of privacy an individual's right
to
to live free from governmental intrusion
and private or personal information is
natural essential and inherent
so we passed that that we passed out of
the house we passed out of the senate
with the two-thirds requirement it went
on the ballot over 85 percent of new
hampshire citizens said that is
important and we want to change our
constitution to include that provision
that government should not uh intrude
upon public um
private information
so this bill again in the opt-in
provision um kind of takes a invert
inverted action it assumes that the
citizen wants the data to be included
and then makes them ask it for it not to
be is that what they that's what their
rules currently say i'm looking to
invert that i think the citizens right
privacy needs to be explicit that you
need to tell a citizen when the state is
going to collect your data
that's the most important part that
constitutional
provision kind of clearly says that if
you're going to collect my data you have
to be explicitly asking me for it before
you start collecting and don't default
out default to collect it unless i say i
don't want it the constitution says
otherwise
um
i work at technology as i've told you
i've told this committee before the
default
for privacy officers in the normal
technology world the default is opt in
that's the default provision of most
privacy officers you need to ask
somebody for their data before you start
collecting their data so you've all
bought bought
things online i'm sure and there's that
checkbox that says hey do you want to
receive our emails right do you want to
do that but you have to check the box
you have to say yes you have to give
permission for that activity it's a
default action for technology is to ask
permission to
collect your data and to use it
you're going to hear in a little while
how important this database is and i
actually don't disagree with that
statement that this is an important
database to use
however
i
find it somewhat disingenuous in that
you if you understand this uh registry
it was originally authorized in 1998
over 20 years ago do you know when it
got implemented last year
so for over 20 years the departments had
the authority to take this very
important database put it online
they waited over 20 years to actually
decide it needed done somehow in new
hampshire's still standing our citizens
are still alive and enjoying a vibrant
economy um and and a
beautiful lifestyle here in new
hampshire
didn't seem to have an effect right so
so i i i
while i do believe that this database
could be important um in in working with
public health and understanding disease
control um i also recognize that it's
maybe not quite as critical as people
are making it out to be
one thing i'd again i serve on job cars
you know so i get to see the rules that
come before the jail car relative to
certain actions within the agency so
dhhs is one of those agencies that comes
on a regular basis and brings rules
and so one of the reasons why i'm
bringing this bill is one of the things
that concerned me when i saw the rules
around the registry
was who has access to the registry who
has access to enter data who has access
to read data and you would think it's
the department right some doctors put
the data in when someone gets vaccinated
and the doc and the department gets to
look at that and use that for public
health policy
yeah there's a little bit bigger than
that
so authorized user means any entity a
person which is authorized to enter
information into or access certain
information contained in the registry
including
administering current and former health
care providers makes sense health care
providers not sure why that's duplicated
schools
licensed child care agencies
and then departments uh department's
department's division of public health
services and agencies so this isn't just
the department we're giving access to
child care centers we're bringing access
to schools to this database for your
private data
and i'm not sure you even knew about it
i i asked the question you know on we
talked about getting vaccinated and
probably the last vaccination everybody
went and got was their booster shot if
they went and chose to get it
can you tell me the doctor told you
specifically that you could opt out of
the registry for that booster shot
that's now going to be reported did he
actually make an explicit statement to
you that oh by the way
you know this this is going to be
reported to the state unless you tell me
not to report it to the state which
really should be the standard
that's not what they said right that's
not what i i recall on any of these
vaccinations they don't tell you
somewhere buried in the millions of
pieces of paper that i think is almost
as difficult as buying a car
um is one of these acknowledgments that
you sign that says oh by the way
that you probably never read because in
point six font that at my age i can't
read anymore anyway
um but the other information i found
amazing is that
most of you think that the the intent of
this is to record all vaccinations right
because you want to record lot number
and all this other kind of stuff the
idea was originally it was to serve
public health but now we're talking
about it's going to be your central
repository for all vaccinations so if
you need to know what you had for
vaccines you can go to the state and ask
them
however there's more to it than that
so under the rules the things that are
entered into the information into there
is
excuse me one second
a vaccination event is what's recorded
in the registry a vaccination event
means an immunization an immunoglobulin
administration exemption
or refusal defined in section p above
refusal means
and means the act of not receiving a
vaccination on a particular day or at a
particular medical appointment for such
reasons as wanting to delay the
vaccination to another time not wanting
the particular vaccination at that time
behavioral or medical issues at the time
of vaccination or the religious
exemption from a particular vaccination
so what that means is every time you go
to your doctor whether you get the ex
you choose to accept the vaccine or you
choose to refuse the vaccine the state's
getting the data so it's no longer about
who's vaccinated and what the population
looks like it's about also who's not
vaccinated and keeping that data i'm not
sure that was the intent originally of
the bill is that even if you refuse and
you say no i don't want a vaccine the
state's still going to collect your data
in in what i consider a violation of
article 2 part 1 article 2b of our
constitution because we didn't ask you
for the data we're just doing it
so
i guess that's the summation of of
my uh
my comments i again i'm not against the
database i just think our citizens need
to be informed our citizens should be
have you should ask explicit rights to
take their data and put it into a state
database especially considering the
broad access that's given across the
state to people outside the health care
industry
that this data should you should
specifically ask and specifically get
permission to enter the data and i'm
asking you please vote otp on this bill
which does just that it requires health
care providers to explicitly ask the
citizen for their permission before the
state collects their data
any questions for the representative
representative delemus
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question i
actually have two of them but they're
very simple
first of all where which article is it
in the constitution now because i don't
part 1 article 2b
right to privacy
thank you
and then um if you now
i've gone to see my
my pcp fairly recently
and i wasn't really
he never said do you want a vaccination
have you had one or there were no
questions about any kind of vaccination
is that recorded as a as a refusal do
you know or is that just ignored or how
how does that go i honestly don't know
it's not defined anywhere huh okay thank
you
representative salloway
thank you mr chairman representative
lane nice to see you
um i noticed that the bill is
co-sponsored by
people who are identified as s-e-n
period i believe that indicates another
chamber of the legislature which i have
heard rumors exist
do you
happen to know if another bill from that
chamber
is likely to show up here on crossover
i do not know the answer to that i do
know there was some concern about this
opt-in opt-out provision and i know that
again i have a couple senators on this
bill they may have taken it upon
themselves to add it over there i don't
recall one way or another a quick
follow-up quick follow-up uh
do you happen to know the path of data
of
of immunization data if i get my
immunization at my local cvs
where that data then goes and whether or
not it comes back to the state
thank you for that question so i think
we've all heard
through
through the numerous
media agencies that there's a conflict
between the state data and the federal
data because some of the larger chains
don't even provide the information to
the state they send it straight to the
federal government um and then the state
tries to figure out how to reconcile
that and as a data guy would never want
to do that um but um because you're
gonna end up with garbage in garbage out
um and so uh but we do know that even
the iis the immunization i feel what it
stands for database um
is not accurate right so there are
citizens in new hampshire that have
gotten the vaccination they're not
reported in there at all it's probably
refusals that are also not reported at
all because
again if you
you know this goes to my point about cvs
by state law they require they should be
asking or telling people that they can
opt out but i think if you look for that
it's in again
you know six point font on the back of
some form that you're signing that may
may tell you or they may not even tell
you at all and again this would require
them to have the pharmacist
administering or the provider
administrating the
vaccine to let you know that that data
it's required
representative merchant
thank you mr chairman also
it's good to see you representative
lang a fierce
defender of private rights and i totally
support it
however when i go to the motor vehicle
department i don't have the ability to
opt out of what information i want to
give to the point of vehicle department
so therefore a lot of the data the motor
vehicle department has on my behalf i
would like to probably strip out but i
don't have
authority to do that
second when it comes to
the issue of information which we
fiercely guard
are you aware of the fact that there's a
parallel database
and why it brings people's attention it
came to my attention one time when i was
into a physician's office
and
they came up with a whole record of
is mostly for my wife
on all the medications she's on
so i said it's interesting
how did you get the information oh
the pharmacies sell it to the people who
then sell it to us and therefore we have
a record of all your medications
so therefore the access to all the
information we're trying to protect
is not being protected
so even though it's not in the
government side it's in the
non-commercial side
are you aware of that
so as someone who's worked with hl7
interfaces before in medical offices i
am aware that data is sold a lot of
times there's anonymized data and
sometimes it's not um and it's actually
the sale of that data is kind of
important right so we know that it's
used in you know i use diabetes as my as
my example because it was one of the
things i worked on was again working
with an interface to build extract data
from an electronic medical record system
to be able to provide it to
some clinicians to be able to do you
know what what's it look like so so we
know this happens um
you know if you want to sponsor a bill
next year i'll be happy to co-sponsor
with you and help you with how we
protect that data as well
representative gay
thank you mr chairman
now that pandora's box is opening
excuse me would you would you think it
was a good idea that whenever we are
offered a vaccine
that we get a sheet
of paper or something that we sign and
we have a receipt
uh
that would actually actually we're
acknowledging that we
know you know we're opting in or
i mean
i'm i'm sorry um
to be awkward
it became apparent that most people who
received vaccines in the past couple
years were not apprised of anything
they didn't have any kind of proof they
had no
no acknowledgement that there were risks
involved and all vaccines have risks
involved whether they're very relatively
safe or dangerous
but it sounded like nobody got anything
so it's
are you
envisioning
requiring people to be notified or
signing off
for the opt-in method so thank you for
your question and while i'm not going to
speak to informed consent which i think
our doctors do a fairly good job of in
in informing us about the dangers of
what we're doing i will say that if you
read the bill again in the last sentence
of the bill no person's personal data
such as name address date of birth
immunization or vaccination information
shall be entered into the registry
without explicit
written opt-in consent
so it's very clear that you have to have
a sp you know a very clear understanding
and not just something in 6.6 font at
the back of a page that you never have
to read an initial
representative cannon
[Music]
thank you representative thank you thank
you mr chair for recognizing me thank
you thank you representative for
hearing my question
um i'm not i'm not sure of how a
a
a recipient of a vaccine is contacted
in case there's a problem with the
vaccine they received is that
from registry information or is it
completely separate so thank you for
your question so again
um every healthcare provider who who
acts who gives you an immunization and
gives you a vaccination is required to
keep a record of that and they have to
keep all the import pertinent data what
your lot number was of the vaccine you
got all of that registered and required
data is required so if there is an issue
with that your provider can notify you
of those information so if they get
notified by the manufacturer hey this
these five lot numbers have problems
please contact everybody in your who you
gave that lot number two it's the
obligation of the provider then to
contact you
follow-up
um what if i got a vex
a vex scene from the state programs and
not my provider so that's an interesting
statement again so they're governed by
the same rules right so they also must
keep track of your
lot number and information they would
have the same obligation their providers
just by definition like all the other
providers in the state
thank you
representative king
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative lang for taking this
question it's a real simple one i've
seen other bills come through and they
have like some type of document that
goes along with it would you
would you see the need for
providing that type of document that
everybo every provider could use as a as
a template
thank you for the question
representative king again i i'd be okay
with that um again with a lot of the
times i serve it like i said i serve on
jail card and a lot of those forms come
through car as part of the rule making
process once the laws passed and
the department makes the appropriate
forms unnecessary
the department does have an opt out form
that if you after the fact decide oh i
want my name out of the database you can
use a form that go to the go to dhhs get
the form and they have a process for
doing that um i will say it's not easy
to find if you want to do that
representative merchant
it's a follow-up thank you mr chair and
also thank you for taking the question
that's a follow-up to episode of king's
comment um i did find the form and i do
totally agree it's not easy to find but
it does exist
and i think one of the concerns i'm
hearing is the fact that patients aren't
aware of it
so therefore if we were able to allow
the patient because one of the things
you are required to do
when you give a vaccine
is provide the patient what they call a
vaccine information sheet required by
federal law
at the time in which that's provided to
the patient if the form of how they can
get into the database and there's a link
on the database to opt out of it
would that not
go in the right direction at that point
in time or providing them both the form
a link to the form so they could easily
opt out when they wanted to
to make it easier for the patient at
that point in time versus them having to
go down and try to find it
so thank you representative merchant for
the question and again
i'm a guy who wants to get stuff done so
if that's the only way it's going to
pass out of this committee i'd accept
that he said but the reality is that
again we're making
work right so we're making work the
person could choose to opt out right in
the beginning and then there's no work
for the state agency to delete anything
that we could take it right up front and
and provide that same form and on that
same thing as do you want your data
entered into the database and then it
never creates the work for the state
agency
on the back side right so i'd rather opt
for reducing the amount of work than
increasing the amount of work
representative canarch
yes i agree with that it make makes a
lot more sense not to get in there to
start with if that's what the person
wants but what i am concerned is the
implication you mentioned about the opt
out you know being kind of lost uh on
the forums in a very small font and i
think
i think what representative king was
driving at is the same thing can occur
down the other side as well on an opt-in
form and it's certainly important for
people to understand the loss of
uh quality of information and tracking i
mean a lot of us get a vaccination in
the doc's office and often the pharmacy
and and i can't remember where what i
got when um and and you know this is a
way to be able to get it and so would
you agree that we have well first of all
that we have to get the enough
information of the person to understand
the implications of not entering into it
in terms of ease of tracking data for
themselves as well
and wouldn't it work just as well if
rather than worry about making it opt
out with a large form that makes it
clear and separate not just on the back
page if we did the same thing for the
opt-in but again prevent it from
right up front not saying here's how you
can opt out after we got your data but
instead you can opt out right now if you
wish to do so but not in the back of a
page not point six font would that be an
acceptable option so again i think
you're just doing the inverse of the
same question right it's basically a
checkbox so i want to opt in do i want
to opt out what i want to do check the
box accordingly right so again
uh that's a fine option again as long as
it's required and clear that a decision
has to be made by the patient right
that's what i'm i'm most concerned with
is that the new hampshire citizen
makes an informed and intelligent
decision right they check that box say
yes i want the state to take my data no
i don't want the state to take my data
and not just have the state take it by
default because they're not informed
follow-up representative canarch yes so
i think we're kind of getting to
something here that might be interesting
so we wouldn't have an opt-in we
wouldn't have an opt-out we just simply
haven't opt
you know they would have two boxes they
would have to therefore
make a move to either opt in or to opt
out but they'd have enough information
to understand the
the benefits and the downsides of making
either decision but that one form would
have to be filled up by everybody and
they would therefore be forced to
actually truly make a decision at the
time
would would you be comfortable with that
because that that kind of is
not an opt-in opt-out it's an opt i
would absolutely and i think that would
go to the intent of the original law
which which was there
and again i i would caveat it with one
thing no form means no data
yes if you don't submit the form the
data doesn't get submitted either
fair
representative acton thank you mr chair
thank you representative uh
just in general from taking a a larger
overview of this situation uh
is it a valid concern of mine that we
tend we seem to be
moving away from the responsibility to
convince
patients through education and
communication
to take part in
um opting uh providing information we're
moving to
more of a compel
situation where in this case
we do have the right to opt out but i
was i was never told when i didn't even
know
um
is that a valid concern
absolutely and again it's the basis for
my bill right is that is that we're
moving we're collecting data not asking
we're compelling basically for lack of a
better phrase because if you don't tell
them you can't do it then they don't
know they can't do it they're just going
to do it and so i absolutely agree we're
moving to where we're compelling
citizens and i i did want to add one
comment there are there are some someone
made a question about driver's licenses
and there are some data points you can
actually exclude some not all but you
can say i don't want you to collect this
data and you can you can have it removed
including your photo
um is one of the things you can have
removed and so there are points where
we've recognized there are certain
pieces of data we don't want the
government to stay on to so while you
might get your driver's license
initially you can then um as right there
they give you a form you can check the
little box they remove my room my photo
after i you print my photo my id
so yes is the answer to your question i
think we're moving to where we're
compelling more citizens to do stuff
that they don't necessarily know they're
even being compelled to do thank you
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative lang for taking my
question i'm just uh
perusing through the administrative
rules here and i see in its hep 307
points
the content and submission of
vaccination event reports
in section c of that number one it says
that they also have to enter the
registrant's insurer information
as held by the current health care
provider um are
i mean i i believe that that's probably
another point that people would prefer
not to have sent to the state
um were you aware of that and would you
agree i actually did i agree with you
100 again
it goes to what does it matter
um what my who my insurance carrier is
but for some reason the state's
collecting that data and dumping it into
this database to do that
i will say again as someone who's worked
with data a lot that almost all of this
data is available to the state through
anonymized data
they can go to insurance companies
asking whatever the icd-9 code is for in
vaccinations say give me a list of
non-identifiable data of everybody who
got a vaccine in the state of new
hampshire now they can give you that
data
um so i'm not even sure there's a real
need for the database we can create the
database just from the insurance
carriers alone who are paying for it
whether it's medicare medicaid or blue
cross blue shield or anthem or pick
somebody
that date is still available to the
department of health and human services
they don't need to drag it from the
citizen they can ask for the
non-identifiable data
representative merchant
point of clarification thank you mr
chair my understanding the data resides
in
department insurance not the department
health and human services so therefore
for the one agency to go to the other
agency i'm not quite sure about the
interagency play but the database is
actually insurance department not health
and human services
okay
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative lang for taking the
question
i know that the current database has a a
lot of issues it's not as good of data
as we would like do you think that
pulling the data from the icd-9 codes
might actually give us a more accurate
count than what we have today
thank you question again i think the
biggest problem around the data is the
fact that we have some providers
reporting directly to the cdc and some
not reporting to the state and then we
end up with conflict of we don't know
what the real number is anymore um i i
would postulate that our coping our
cover vaccination rates are higher than
being reported because the state
database isn't accurate
and that the feds are probably closer
but again i don't even know if the fed's
got all the data so i would just
postulate that the number's probably
higher on our vaccination rates and
we're being reported now
seeing no further questions thank you mr
chairman and thank you community members
chair recognizes paula minihan from the
new hampshire hospital association she
has written testimony to hand out to us
all and she has signed in in opposition
to the bill
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee for the record paula minihan
senior vice president of state
government relations with the new
hampshire hospital association
representing all our hospitals
the hospital association is opposed to
1606 um as stated this bill was um heard
uh very this committee excuse me heard a
very similar bill house bill 221 last
year
that tried to change the immunization
registry to an opt-in and the majority
of the committee members at that time
voted inexpedient to legislate due to
the constraints during one of the house
sessions back in the spring of 21. the
bill was ultimately not voted on hence
why we are here today
this bill does change the current
process for submitting information to
the state vaccine registry from an
opt-out to an opt-in
we have concerns that the opt-in process
would be cumbersome for both the
individual and the health care provider
creating barriers to producing a
comprehensive immunization record for
individuals and impede sound clinical
decision making if health care providers
cannot rely on complete information
for their members and
the purposes of the vaccine registry i
won't list all of this but it is the
immunization information system you also
hear it as iis but that's what it stands
for it is multi-fold and um i am
actually going to let the department
talk about more specifics i am
absolutely not an expert on this but i
know there are experts here that
can answer specific questions but it um
some of the purposes of the vaccine
registry is to have one location where
vaccines are administered at multiple
locations
allow for vaccine ordering tracking and
administration history
and minimize waste of vaccines through
proper inventory management etc
if the vaccine registry were set up
solely as an opt-in system the health
care providers would be required to ask
every single person every single time a
vaccine was administered if their data
were to be added to the registry and a
person could receive vaccinations at
many locations as stated earlier
physician offices pharmacies
school-based clinics
community vaccination sites hospitals
long-term care facilities urgent care
centers etc the time and paperwork
needed to document and opt in at every
point of vaccination would be
overwhelming for the individual
and a check of
okay
a
check of persons active in opt-in answer
would need to be put in place by all
health care providers before any data
could be shared the current vaccine
registry law in new hampshire is set up
as an opt out and this structure
requires the health care provider to ask
a person their preference once document
it in the person person's medical record
and set up their data submission system
to exclude that person if they choose an
opt-out
otherwise vaccine data is transmitted
regularly and a systematic and efficient
flow of data can be maintained
according to a study by the cdc in 2017
42 out of 50 states plus washington dc
have their immunization registry set up
as opt out clearly it is a position that
most states that vaccine registry should
be established as an opt-out
while it is true that
that if someone opts out of the registry
that person's information will be
non-existent in the registry it would be
incumbent upon that individual to
maintain their own records and share the
necessary data with their health care
provider
the key to any decision about a registry
is ult is ultimate utility any database
regardless if it's for vaccines medical
records vital records and the like must
be viewed as an important tool in the
toolbox for healthcare providers and
individuals alike why choose an opt-in
registry that would create an
inefficient incomplete system that could
not be relied on as a useful tool
clinical decisions could be hampered
important vaccines missed vaccines could
be administered more than once because
of the uncertainty of whether there were
done due to lack of documentation i have
provided some links which i realize
don't work on a piece of paper
i can
send it to you so you can
you use those hyperlinks to review some
of the information that as background
hospital association wants new hampshire
to develop a stable reliable and
comprehensive vaccine registry that can
be used by and for health care providers
and individuals
our hospitals and health care providers
have been advocating for years to have a
functioning vaccine registry in our
state as a reliable tool in their
toolbox we ask that no changes be made
to the registry structure before it can
truly get off the ground for all these
reasons we are opposed to
1606 and thank you for the time i also
want to point out
um my colleague
courtney tanner sent you from dartmouth
hitchcock a letter um from dr
loud the chair of the children's
hospital of at dartmouth chad
this morning
opposing this bill as well so i just
wanted to be on the record that you do
have that in your email
happy to answer any questions well i'll
try to answer questions but i am not an
expert on this
representative weber
thank you mr chairman and thank you just
if you know
i'm
inquiring about your statements about a
person could receive vaccinations at
many locations this is one of your
objections
are not those
locations each isn't each location
currently required to let the patient
know or the patient's parent know if
it's a child that they have the option
to opt out
yes that's my understanding i think
what's getting confused and i think this
was
discussed during 1608 earlier and i know
that was passed in on the
docket for this week in the house
what happened with the covid vaccine
is very different than what the normal
childhood vaccine process is um and
1608 as you know there's now going to if
this bill were to become law that will
require a notification by the department
to notify people that they have an
opt-out opportunity covid19 that was
just an extraordinary process as you all
know
but yes
childhood vaccines etc there is an
opportunity to
opt out um and that's what um as i
stated that's
at wherever it is offered
yep
representative cushman so could i have
one follow-up yes you may
so as much as i support opt-out rather
than opt-in
i'm wondering
if you could explain how having an
opt-in system
is more onerous than the current opt-out
system if the opt-out system were
working as the opt-out system is
supposed to be working and i need to ask
um
to defer to the department because they
can explain it better but when you think
about it if we have 99 or whatever it is
of individuals
are currently opting in so the process
you do it once you do the opt out once
request
or
discuss
and then if they choose to the
individual can opt out if you're going
to do the opt-in every single time that
is that is really cumbersome so i'm
thinking of 99
versus the one percent that would want
to opt out you know what i'm saying
now representative cushman thank you mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question
um concerning the
the opt-out requirement only once it's
my understanding that that's in rules
um so
it's not really a true opt-out if you're
only alerted one time and not with every
vaccination
years could go by at the same practice
where you receive something and then
maybe at that time you don't want it so
i do think that it needs to be done
every time anyway our constitution
requires that
um
but my question
is um what are the processes that the
hospital systems have in place i know
that you you speak to all the hospitals
pretty frequently what are their
policies and procedures for ensuring
that the opt out information is being
given to every patient
um it's really more in the physician
offices
and they do have processes i don't know
specifically what they are but they are
aware um and i think it's cl and again
the department um can clarify um miss
tilly can
clarify but there is a next it doesn't
explicitly say out opt out in the in the
law in 141 but it does talk about the
opportunity to
they don't again doesn't use the word
opt out but it is in the statute as well
as in the rules
representative gay
thank you mr chair
thank you how does the data get into the
database how does anybody know that a
person got a vaccine and which one it is
etc
it is the requirement of the provider to
get it into the vaccine so
again
the mechanics are really the
department's responsibility i will defer
to them to answer that
it's it's it's it's like logging in to
the system so the provider that
provides a vaccine
does that so the provider must do it yes
i think there are pediatricians that
might be testifying that can explain it
because it's a lot of most of these are
childhood vaccines when you think about
it
one more
so opting out would mean they don't put
the data in they it gets taken out
there's a form again how did the
department
if they have to take it out how did it
get in
i will have the department explain it
but if they opt out at a later date then
it gets there's a form that then the
department
how did it get in to start with when
they're giving them the shot and they
have to
it sounds like you say the provider puts
it in
okay so we're not talking about later
i'm talking about right then if they
opted out right then
then maybe it's in there i am not sure
again the mechanics because i don't work
in a physician's office i will defer to
the department or to a pedia
pediatrician's office to try to explain
that a little bit more clearly than i
can
thank you miss minihan the chair now
recognizes patricia tilly and anne-marie
mccurry who might be able to answer some
of these questions that uh
ms minahan said they would
good morning thank you my name is
patricia tilly i'm the director of the
division of public health services at
the new hampshire department of health
and human services thank you chair thank
you committee for hearing our testimony
today the department is here today to
strongly oppose hb
as you have heard throughout the session
immunization is considered one of the
most important public health
achievements of the last century
immunizations are a safe
effective way to protect your children
and adults from disease including some
cancers as we've heard about the impact
of cancer earlier this morning
it helps
are because of childhood vaccines we no
longer lose our children to diseases
like measles polio or whooping cough but
this bill is not about those life-saving
vaccines we're not here to talk about
measles or chickenpox or even covid19
we're here to talk about the backbone of
the system the way the department and
healthcare providers ensure
that health records are accurate and
that we have the best information to
give to individuals and caregivers so
that they can make the choices that are
right for their families
and right in our statute it says that no
individual is required to participate in
the immunization information system
no one is compelled
the new hampshire immunization
information system the iis or the
registry is the single secure repository
of accurate complete and current
immunization records in new hampshire it
provides benefits to individuals health
care providers and the department
including preventing administration of
duplicate immunizations increasing
immunization rates and by promoting the
most up-to-date immunization
recommendations and helping to remind
patients when immunizations are due
consolidating immunization records from
multiple providers
patients and families benefit from
having access to a complete electronic
immunization record that includes
information from those providers no
matter where it was received as you've
heard
do you know that by age two babies
toddlers um
more than 20 percent of them have
already received care from multiple
doctors
it ensures accountability of publicly
purchased vaccines to minimize waste it
supports public health activities by
identifying communities with low
vaccination rates to ensure access to
vaccination and prevent those infectious
disease
the new hampshire iis does everything
that policy makers typically want it
enables the department to effectively
manage its resources it consolidates
data from multiple places and it
provides real and potentially
life-saving benefits to granite staters
it helps our health care providers
and
if the individual doesn't want to
participate there is an easy way to say
no thank you your health care provider
provides the information
to have the
opt out i have the opt-out form i will
send it to you
and they can provide that information to
you and all of us can google it right
now off our phones
hb 1606 proposes to make
the new hampshire iis opt in
this will do exactly what policy makers
have asked us repeatedly not to do it
will make the process more cumbersome
complicated and costly the current
opt-out process respects an individual's
right to privacy while ensuring that we
can be accountable for our publicly
purchased vaccines ensure that quality
help ensure quality health care for kids
and adults and give us the data needed
to control those infectious disease
outbreaks within our community
again by rule no information can be
submitted to the registry without the
opportunity to opt out
on the other hand
opt-in programs in other states have
been costly they create unnecessary
paperwork and lead to incomplete and
lower quality data needed to protect the
patient
and the community
however we are not like other states we
deeply respect new hampshire's culture
of privacy and choice
and that is why opting out of the new
hampshire iis has
been designed to be straightforward
administrative rules hep 307 outline the
process for patients to opt out if a
vaccine recipient indicates they want to
opt out their health care provider is
required to complete
the form
that form is held by the health care
provider and directs them to ensure that
the information is not
sent to the state
public health should never know who has
opted out
privacy is protected
the department urges policy makers to
consider the experience of texas one of
the only two or three states in the
country with an opt-in policy
texas right now is working to implement
a change to become opt-out after
conducting an evaluation of the cost of
their opt in model that found that it
cost two to two and a half dollars per
child compared to the estimated cost of
about 30 cents per child with an opt out
model
the additional cost for texas's opt-in
iis was estimated to be well over a
million dollars annually new hampshire's
health care providers cannot afford that
additional burden
fewer than five percent of new hampshire
vaccine recipients are estimated to
desire the added pro privacy of opting
out of the new hampshire iis
the vast majority of individuals value
the benefits of full participation
i will take a minute here to talk a
little bit about covid because as you've
heard from the hospital association
covet 19 vaccine was a different sort of
animal
many of us many adults in this room
received their vaccines within a
pharmacy setting
those vaccines were provided to the
pharmacies by the federal government not
the state of new hampshire
that data went directly to the federal
government it did not pass go and enter
the new hampshire iis system and
therefore you were not given an
opportunity in some cases to opt out
because that data never went to us in
the first place so i just want to make
sure and if there are other questions
about that i'm happy to answer those
later
changing the new hampshire iis to an
opt-in system will require healthcare
providers to work harder
not smarter
an opt-in system will increase
cost and unnecessary paperwork for
everyone it will create additional
burden for the majority of individuals
that want the convenience and safety of
a consolidated record
the current opt-out system securely
balances the need for choice
and optimal convenience for individuals
and health care providers
this bill is not about what you think
about covet or covid vaccines it's not
about potential requirements for school
or for work what this bill does is make
things unnecessarily more complicated
and costly for the vast majority of new
hampshire residents
we urge the committee to oppose hp 1606
and i will provide examples for you of
our opt out form
and the sort of documentation that we
have used in our latest booster blitz
for covid that talks a little bit about
the new hampshire iis and helps to
provide
information for all vaccine recipients
so they can make the choice that's right
for them thank you chair
any questions from miss tilly
representative gay thank you mr chairman
and thank you i will ask that same
question that i just asked a few minutes
ago
how
what's the nuts and bolts of the uh
provider who gave the shot to the child
i'll use that old-fashioned term
i didn't get immunizations as a child i
got shots
okay so how do they input the fact that
this patient either
that they got that they got a shot how
do they put that information in
thank you thank you representative and i
too do not work in a pediatrician's
office so i know that some of the
pediatricians that are coming up to
speak can talk about how they
operationalize that directly in their
offices what we know from the department
however is that information does not
ever go into the iis they're offered the
opportunity to not participate in the
iis and if the parent says no that
information does not get sent to us they
manage their own electronic health
record within their own entity and i'm
sure that they can talk more about how
that process works but the most
important information to understand is
that the information does not get
relayed to new to the department of
health and human services
one follow-up
does this information have to go to a
federal collection i just heard that for
the first time thank you for the
opportunity to clarify that covet 19 was
totally different than anything else
so um so the reason i was speaking about
information going direct to the feds
because it was about covid19 vaccine but
for your typical measles mumps rubella
polio that information does not go to
the federal government we provide an
aggregate amount okay thank you
representative canark
after we've heard from miss mccurry
thank you so much for the record my name
is anne marie mccurry i'm the
immunization section chief for the
department of health and human services
i also just wanted to provide further
clarification that the department on
covet vaccination any of the information
that is in the nhiis that we are
required to report to the cdc redacts
any personal identifiable information
therefore the cdc the federal government
does not receive any identifiable
information they would only have the
information that for instance a male age
35 living in manchester received a covet
vaccination
representative canark thank you very
much i'm still a little bit confused and
i just wanted to clarify one thing so an
opt out once a form is filed with one
injection
then that's captain file and
the pediatrician's office or provider's
office so they know that person is an
opt-out and will be forever more until
they change it they don't have to go
through that each time is that first of
all that's my first part and the second
part then isn't the opt-in is it your
impression that it would be different
that the opt-in would have to be done
for each immunization versus
having it occur once and that would
state to the pediatrician this is an
opt-in person and everything is going to
go
that is correct that is our
understanding so again they're offered
the opportunity to opt out the first
time they have offered vaccine that i
assume gets recorded within their ehr
that information does not come to the
department of health and human services
this
proposing to do an opt-in could
potentially add increased burden to
those healthcare providers by
continually having to offer some sort of
piece of paper and um process that both
within their electronic record and
certainly if it were a paper form that
would certainly be additional burden to
any healthcare provider
a follow-up then please
follow up would you be
happier if this could be crafted such
that if we were going to go with an
opt-in
that it would be instead that they would
also fill it out once that would be kept
on record of course it would have to be
at each provider's place i understand
but that would be once and they would
keep it so it would work symmetrically
with how the opt out works would that be
less cumbersome or do you not foresee
that that would be would solve that
problem
again the part of the problem or one of
the concerns certainly not a problem but
one of the concerns i think all of us
will have to think about is we know that
the vast majority of individuals
will want to participate because it has
benefits to them so right now you're
looking at managing paper for a small
proportion of people or your entire
paper your entire patient population
i understand
representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman
and perhaps you can clarify something
for me
when the sponsor introduced this bill
they um
referred to child care agencies and
schools and doctors offices
um it sounded to me like they had
general access to this database
and could you explain
if that is the case is it limited
is do they have open access how it works
thank you very much for that question
representative so as we've all heard we
are launching the iis as we speak we are
it is a new system we're moving it
forward within the rules it gives us the
authority to provide
read-only access for child care
providers and school nurses now you may
ask why would those have an interest in
looking at a read-only access of the
patient or the students or the children
that are within their care and that is
because both school nurses and child
care providers have a duty to ensure
that immunizations are up-to-date for
attendance when within either schools or
child care so again this is not
willy-nilly access
this is access for the child care
provider or the school nurse to
determine if the children have
up-to-date vaccine
follow-up
so just to make sure i've got that
straight
you
family wants to send their children to a
child care center
the child care center in order to
ascertain that the
children have been vaccinated has some
kind of access to this system can they
see other people's information as well
as the child
the
authorized users are only out loud
access to view the information that
would be relevant for them so their
their within their own patient profiles
and i would just follow that up by
saying so again if i brought my child to
child care and i chose to opt out of the
system i would be required to provide
that documentation myself as opposed to
the school nurse or the child care
provider again looking at the group of
individuals that they're authorized to
look at
and that they could determine if they
are up to date with their vaccine so
this is an opportunity for convenience
for both the
parent as well as the provider
follow-up representative shapiro
yes
so once again i just want to make sure i
have it clear
they have access to the students that
are coming to their program
um
is that by um is there
is that what's allowed or is there is
the system actually not
permit them to scroll through and see
other information
the authorized users are signing a
confidentiality and user provider
agreement
that specifies their ability to look at
specific records
okay thank you representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you both
for being here to take these questions
with the child care providers are they
providing a list of all the children who
are in their care to the state in order
to get that authorization
no
okay good thank you can i have a
follow-up that one i had to ask you you
may have a follow-up thank you my other
question is we're hearing about people
who who don't feel that they were
informed about the opt-out process is
there any recourse for them is are there
any penalties for people who don't
doctors who don't inform
we do not have a penalties in place
right now however there is a system also
to withdraw your information so once you
agree
to allow or you passively agree in this
case um you don't opt out of the system
but you have a change of heart and you
would like to remove your information
there's a process by which you can
withdraw that information
and also if i may add
it's very important for us to also be
aware that not all immunization
providers are required to report to the
new hampshire iaas
so those providers who are not providing
publicly funded vaccine would not be
required it would be a voluntary
participation so these conversations
would only be taking place
in those offices where a publicly funded
vaccine were being administered so
we just have to be very careful about
knowing
when it is appropriate to have that
conversation about iis and their
opportunity to opt out because it is not
for every vaccination event
thank you
representative merchant
she
eloquently answered the question i was
going to ask thank you representative
cushman thank you mr chairman thank you
for taking my question
um so uh just a quick clarifier um so
are you saying that the covet
vaccination information um is not
currently in the iis
we made every attempt to get all
information on covid into the iis during
the state of emergency
that was a requirement to do so the
opportunity to opt out was temporarily
suspended under the emergency order
the department is very much wanting to
work with the legislation here to
ensure that people do have the
information and their ability to
withdraw should they not want that
information to be retained
the department is also aware that
not all providers such as federal
pharmacies were participating in the iis
at the time so they were not offering
that opportunity to opt out we are
working with our federal partners to go
ahead and
be able to give that information to us
in the future but the department has
specifically stated to them we will not
accept your data because you did not
provide that opportunity to opt out so
not all data is in the iis for covid
yes i'll just confirm that our data set
is incomplete as many of you have heard
in the media and for all of these
complex reasons we received some during
the emergency order so up until about
june of 2021 from 20 early 21 to june we
were receiving
a lot of data then we received
less data after july
follow up
thank you for that um
okay so and i understand that the
part of that
problem was that the system was getting
set up and you were working out the bugs
um but i it's my also my understanding
that that's been going on a very long
time can you tell me exactly how many
years and how much money
and how many requests for increases in
funding have been brought
for this system
since the beginning
that's a very complicated question thank
you and i cannot provide you off the top
of my head a list of all those dollar
amounts we have worked with the
legislature as you notice for and as the
sponsor of the bill noted for almost
decades now to determine how we set up
our immunization registry technology
funding and concerns around privacy have
always been drivers of how we move
forward so we have had some stops and
starts we have had funding over time
that has not been available or been
available and um we worked very closely
with the with the legislature to ensure
that our rulemaking
provided the best privacy protections as
possible so that's my roundabout way of
saying to you i don't have the complete
list of dollars right now
with
the covid19 pandemic we received
additional funding from cdc to support
the development of the iis we were going
down this path anyway at this time we
were on track to implement in 20 and 21
prior to the pandemic these things came
together at the perfect confluence of
both additional funds and the need to be
able to have a system to track all of
these complex vaccines that are take
that took place over the past year and a
half
thank you very much
chair calls laura condon from bedford
she's asked to speak for three minutes
according to the pink card
thank you very much my name is laura
condon i'm from bedford i'm a new
hampshire director of advocacy with the
national vaccine information center and
i have served for five years as public
member in the board of directors of the
new hampshire vaccine association there
has been some repeated misinformation
that i really need to correct before i
get to my own testimony
nowhere in current law is their mention
of opt-in and opt-out
and representative lang spoke to that
but the intention of the law is clear
that it was intended to be voluntary
then very very importantly if you look
at the statute for the immunization
registry there is no mention anywheres
of an iis or an immunization information
system this is not a mincing of words
they are two very completely different
programs
what statute does is statute has
authorized a vaccination registry an iis
is two components one component is a
vaccine ordering an inventory program
and the second component is the registry
only the registry is provided for in
statute and in fact the
inventory and ordering program would
never have even been anticipated in 1988
1998 when this was enacted because at
that point in time the state was not in
the vaccine business
vaccines were purchased and held in
inventory by doctors who provided
vaccines so this constant repeating of
an iis attempts to stretch the law and
incorporate something that is not
provided in statute and you really need
to be
aware of that
so then the points i i would make like
to me is that privacy is is essential
and
the opt in would protect privacy state
law requires that vaccine providers keep
a record of vaccinations they give your
doctor has a record of your vaccines
state law requires your doctor or
pharmacist give you a record of
vaccination the time of vaccination you
have a record
if your child is in school or daycare
the school or daycare requires a record
they have a record the state vaccination
registry not an iis is a duplication of
vaccination records already required
multiple times
the rules do not create an effective and
cost efficient registry
in statute it says as written the
vaccination registry rules
shall promote promote effective and cost
efficient disease prevention and control
efforts
the question was asked how much money
has been spent
on this vaccination registry
in
2014 1.36 million was given to dhhs
through the executive council for this
registry
an additional 15.5 million was given in
and at that point it threw the executive
council from the cdc and at that point
in time at that executive council
hearing dhhs testified that their this
was 2019 that their registry was active
you heard today them admitting they're
just getting it active now miss condon i
will stretch it and give you one more
minute i appreciate that mr chairman um
the vaccination registry is not workable
for doctors they are overwhelmed with
the work this creates at the january
19th vaccine association board meeting
board member pediatrician dr pat edwards
complained to dhhs board member and
mccree mccreary that her practice is
totally bogged down by the state
vaccination registry and she fears she
may not able to receive vaccines and her
staff is ready to quit
there i you know people are being told
they're given the opportunity to opt out
in fact hannaford
pharmacy is violating that provision
when you look at their form to get a
vaccination you consent to vaccination
buried in tiny font in the middle of
that says that you will participate in a
state vaccination database makes no
doesn't define it as a registry and
there's no opportunity to opt out if you
want a vaccine you must consent to the
registry they are violating state law
they have been for years
there is no evidence that this vaccine
registry is useful for preventing
disease or outbreaks
it has become a marketing database and i
urge consideration of requiring that
there be a user fee for those that use
this database doctors pharmacists that
they fund this given thank you very much
now thank you
i i you're gone off mike thank you
we can do that
rep you got to come back
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um
so
it's my understanding that
many people are not being made aware
that they have the opportunity to opt
out
for those
are you familiar with
some stories about some practices
sending out an email saying you have
until this date to opt out and
checking off that that was providing the
opportunity and in that situation isn't
it likely that many would have missed
that message and then unconstitutionally
had their data swept into a government
database
thank you very much for the question
representative cushman in fact i'm well
aware of that
because as an advocate parents send me
those letters and those were sent out
last year to parents from a few
different practices that i got them from
and parents were given 10 days to opt
out so if they happen to be on vacation
miss that email whatever they were
automatically swept in there's no
provision and statute or rules that
limits you to a 10-day opt-out period
but in fact they were given a 10-day
opt-out they were scrambling couldn't
find the forms as we've heard before the
forms are very difficult to find they're
not provided by doctors so yes i would
say very much so that there probably
many people got swept into this registry
had no intentions of being part of the
registry
let me ask a question
medical practices and the
increased amount of work paperwork that
they will be facing has been cited
several times
i cannot speak for every group in new
hampshire but i can speak for the one of
which i'm ceo
i while i really don't want my people to
have to do more work
i have actually discussed this issue
with my staff
and the general consensus is this is the
price we got to pay for freedom
would you believe that
i'm not sure what the price is that
you're referring to extra work and more
cost on the part of the
local provider if you would stipulate as
others have said that if we have an
opt-in program
it'll take more paperwork
my staff says more paperwork as much as
they don't want to do it
is the price that we need to pay to keep
our freedoms
well i i think they misunderstand that
um as i have testified it was
pediatrician patricia
edwards who did um speak to the vaccine
association that her practice is
actually overwhelmed by this registry um
she fears her staff will quit it is very
burdensome for the enter the the
information and in fact if a patient
opts out
the doctor only gets the um excuse me if
the patient didn't opt in the doctor
doesn't need to do anything i will not
attempt to restate my question right
they don't need to enter representative
gay
thank you mr chairman thank you so much
for being here
if i understand this properly just what
you said is the absolute truth if you
choose not to be
have your child or yourself
entered into the registry it means the
doctor or provider doesn't have to do
anything right so no work less work not
more
thank you right right
representative king
thank you mr chairman and uh thank you
miss condra for the taking this question
um
i'm a little perplexed on one of the
examples you gave of a provider that
wasn't actually following the rules
is is that
kind of set up because the bill doesn't
say opt-in or opt-out so they're kind of
doing their own thing or
is it
or are there actually rules that they're
supposed to be
following there are rules if you look at
the rules you know written and approved
by by gelcar
um and and i
posed those rules i don't think that
there was full disclosure um it does
require that you know and i will use
hannaford as an example i do have their
their form that a a customer must
consent to to receive a vaccination
there's absolutely no disclosure made in
fact it refers to it as a state database
it is does not identify it as a state
vaccination registry so it um it muddies
the waters and really misinforms
consumers so they're not being properly
informed as required in rules
thank you thank
you and thank you very much for your
testimony thank you the chair calls uh
jake berry from new futures
he has handouts written testimony he
wants to speak for two to three minutes
and he says he supports the bill
that's my mistake mr chairman i
certainly meant to suggest that uh i
meant to uh say that we opposed the bill
uh
out of out of habit i suppose
so uh we'll change we'll change your
pink card thank you we don't want to
have to do another one
i appreciate that sir thank you um good
morning mr chairman
honorable members of the committee my
name is jake berry i'm the vice
president of policy of new futures
as many of you know new futures is a
nonpartisan nonprofit health policy and
advocacy organization we work to
strengthen public health and health
equity all across our state
i want to note that i'm here not just on
behalf of new futures today but on
thousands of people who feel they can't
safely and securely access
these hearings or proceedings today
under the current pandemic
to that and i have passed around uh
testimony not only my own written
testimony but testimony uh from
several community members several public
health professionals in opposition to
this bill
uh as well as several others before the
committee
i don't want to repeat too much of
what's been said here this morning but i
do want to emphasize our strong
opposition to this bill
i simply put the state vaccine registry
isn't it is a critical public health
tool to get life-saving vaccines to
individuals families and communities
that need and want them
i say public health tool because it
helps to protect the health and safety
of our entire state of our entire
population especially children
it's in place to help people access
their vaccination records it helps them
to it helps to identify any coverage
gaps and reduce duplicative doses
and it helps to generate reminders of
any recall notices or
needed reminders
in short it helps to
increase access to vaccines to those
again who want them and those who need
them
uh and it only works the vaccine
registry really only works when people
participate as you've heard today to
shift to an opt-in system would insert
unnecessarily and harmful barriers to
participation
this would limit the impact of the
registry and would leave certain people
more exposed to deadly to deadly
diseases
with that in mind we ask you to to
oppose this bill by voting at itl and
i'm happy to take questions
and thank you for your uh brevity uh any
questions mr barry
uh representative king
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
i'm a little confused because this is
about opt-in and yet
as i'm going through the testimonies
it's about
requiring vaccinations and actually
following vaccinations
i'm wondering if there's a disconnect
here
certainly i i i the testimony is not
intended to advocate for requiring
vaccinations it is again intended to
uh
or just to maintain the opt out system
that we current have to encourage access
to vaccinations again we're not talking
about it requiring anybody but we do
want to ensure that
vaccinations are available to to those
who want and need them
representative weber
thank you and thank you for taking my
question is one who is myself paperwork
challenged
um
is it
not a concern
that
those people
whose lives are more chaotic than others
and who are more in need of various
kinds of services
are
precisely the people who might not be
able to keep track themselves
of vaccinations and other medical
records
and yet they are exactly the same sort
of people who when faced with the
paperwork requiring an opt-out
uh
sorry
when faced with the sort of paperwork
required for an opt-in each time a
vaccine is given
are going to have a hard time
filling out that paperwork and making
sure that their records get capped
so thus making it harder for them
in the future
when they need the records
certainly representative and thank you
very much for the question um i think
that certainly applies to me i can tell
you i have a hard time sort of following
my own vaccination records and i think
that that absolutely does apply to
many individuals uh you know those
who we are uh uh you know very much
concerned about those who face
socioeconomic challenges who have
complicated family lives at home
certainly
have a hard time uh
maintaining their their own medical
records and i think that this would
certainly be uh
[Music]
additional challenges for them as well
follow up
and as a follow-up
are these people not also
often folks who have to seek medical
care
in different locations different
practices they are less likely
than
maybe some others to have
a primary care
health care provider or a medical home
of some kind where all of their records
are centralized they may be getting they
may be either moving from place to place
or from clinic clinic in their pursuit
of
uh health care
yes certainly once again thank you for
the question representative uh some of
these individuals were many of these
individuals that we're talking about who
face again these socioeconomic
challenges and others are ones who face
uh they experience many complicated
medical conditions they have to you know
they're having to see uh specialists
they're having to uh
uh
go as you say different places see
different people and again i think that
adds to the complications and
maintaining
and organizing their own records and so
on certainly
any further questions of mr berry
seeing none thank you so much for your
testimony thank you all
chair recognizes mary benke
opposes the bill wants to speak for
three minutes she's representing
nhna i'm gonna bet that's the new
hampshire nitrogen alliance no
no i'm sorry that's the new hampshire
nurses associate got it
which i believe have been through
in front of you before so good morning
thank you for this opportunity to
address the committee my name is mary
banke and i have been a registered nurse
since 1994.
today is a member of the new hampshire
nurses association's maternal and child
health legislative advocacy group i am
here to represent our membership's
opposition to hb 1606 which will change
the current vaccines registries policy
from out
excuse me opt out to opt in by forcing
patients and parents of children to opt
into the program rather than allowing
them to opt out as is the case under
current law
and i
want to emphasize the child health
mission that we're all on here you know
it's not just our experience as adults
with vaccinations and our responsibility
to protect the children of new hampshire
the registry was designed with multiple
security protocols so all patient
information is private and secure this
information is protected by hipaa which
means the information cannot be accessed
by anyone except your health care
providers plus these providers must
complete a training before they are
given access to the system to ensure
they understand how to use a system and
how to keep your information secure the
registry uses the same security measures
as other electronic medical records you
may have
and i consulted with
the
association of school nurses to find out
what that training was about and they
provided me a lot of information on that
particular statement
new hampshire is the last state in the
country to implement a vaccine registry
after years of planning the rollout of
the immunization information system
coincided with the pandemic
in spite of this providers have been
uploading immunizations into the system
since last april
under an opt-in model they would have to
get signed permission from each patient
for each immunization it slows down the
process tremendously creating extra
paperwork and red tape for families and
busy clinicians changing the program to
opt in would only slow down the progress
that has been made and does nothing to
protect individual rights it is a very
small percentage of parents who choose
to opt out
as an example of the value of state
registry vaccines excuse me state
vaccine registries i will briefly share
with you the following information
in 2010 63 confirmed measles cases were
reported to the cdc by 2019 1282 cases
of measles were confirmed in 31 states
that was the greatest number of cases in
the us since 1992. of the
1282-128 needed hospitalization 61 had
complications such as pneumonia and
encephalitis it was the state's vaccine
registries that provided data and
support to the public and private sector
efforts to protect their populations and
limit contagion the current opt-out
status of the new hampshire registry
allows families an easy way to choose
not to participate
ensuring optimization of the registry
which is designed by the cdc as a best
practice
hb 1606 would weaken new hampshire's
newly established vaccine registry a
critical tool in increasing vaccination
rates and combating infectious disease
in conclusion the nha is asking this
committee to vote this bill inexpedient
to legislate
thank you for your time and service to
the people of new hampshire thank you
very much and for your time management
as well i think that's something nurses
know a question from representative
delemus
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my questions i
i obviously must be missing something
what why isn't the um opt out
option offered every time there's a
vaccination
pardon me why why isn't the opt out
option
offered
every time there's a vaccination
i'm not sure i understand what you mean
well i've been i've been listening and
and i hear that the opt-out is offered
once and then you're automatically in
the
opt out
category you put in that
that
group
why why is that why why isn't the opt
out
option offered every time that there is
a vaccination
i'm really not clear and um or prepared
to answer that question
it must be
okay
well i can can i have another question
yeah you try again thank you i'm sorry
if the if the opt out
option isn't offered every time that
there's a vaccination administered
doesn't wouldn't that actually add to
the small
numbers
of
you've got these this registry and
you're saying that there are a lot of
people who are not
opting out but if you're not offering
opt-out and they people are unaware that
there's the option of opting out
wouldn't that add to the small numbers
go ahead go ahead yeah possibly you know
i can't really predict the future but
what i feel is that you know to
expedient to make the estate registries
a useful tool an accurate tool that we
can base decisions on protecting the
public you have to have the most
participation possible i don't think
anyone was malignantly in
intended to deprive people of their
rights and that's my personal opinion
any other questions
thank you you're welcome
representative cushman thank you mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question um i do want to point out
because you did say in your testimony
that the law states that it's an opt-out
program and that's not true it doesn't
say that anywhere
but i would like to know um how
specifically
would we use this data in the event of
an outbreak would we then target people
who are unvaccinated and you know go
you know
try to tell them door-to-door and tell
them that they need to be
i would leave that to the public health
in this state to answer you know the
mechanics of that but right now if you
have access to good accurate data
you know which the registries did
provide they were able to strategize and
you know isolate populations notify
practices that may have had more people
at risk and this tool i think would be
very effective
seeing no further questions thank you so
much for coming for your testimony and
free time
and dr eric
i'm trying to look at the second letter
of your last name is it an l or an h
my wife's a doctor she writes well he's
he's not bad there's just one letter and
that's my eyesight actually
somebody else filled up the card for me
so that isn't my writing
so it is possible you might not be able
to read my writing
hi i'm joo here tam dr tan i'm one of
the pediatric residents at dartmouth
hitchcock and i am dr eric shasta i'm a
practicing pediatrician in manchester
and in bedford
thank you
absolutely i'm dr eric sessler i'm a
practicing pediatrician general
pediatrician in manchester and in
bedford i'm the current president of the
american academy of pediatrics new
hampshire chapter
and i'm also speaking on behalf of the
new hampshire medical society and i'm
going to ask the person at the table
also to fill out a pink card please
we could absolutely do that
okay i will please fill out a pink card
so while she's filling that out i'll be
able to kind of go first briefly so
vaccine registries are an important tool
for us as medical professionals to be
able to help out with the care that
we're doing as it's been stated before
we're the last state um in the us and
district columbia to be able to set one
up
and so the opt out is an important part
of that to make sure that we actually
have that tool be as robust and useful
as we can and it's a tool that's
important both for families with regards
to the organization stuff that we've
talked about previously as well as
medical professionals so that we're more
likely to have the information that we
need at the time to make the best
decisions for the care of our patients
and for the families
and so for those reasons that's why we
noticed that these are most effective
for us as a setup as a practicing
pediatrician i will be able to tell you
that we do talk about opt out every
single time we give a vaccine
and so we have that you know discussion
with families the forms are sitting in
our offices available for families to be
able to sign so our rooming staff for
example will bring it up as part of that
initial piece johnny's eligible for
vaccine x y and z
we are now registering or where now
there is now a vaccine registry within
the state if you would like to be able
to opt out we have that as a scenario
the rooming staff will then talk to me
for example i'll answer the family's
questions and we have the form right
there that they can fill out as a
process
it did come up previously that there
were pediatricians that that mentioned
about the registering being difficult
that actually is more the ordering
system and the fact that there isn't a
computer interface yet between the
registry and the form not because
actually the process is that difficult
it's that we're still working on the
electronic interface and that's actually
what's causing a lot of pediatric
practices difficulty with regards to
this system
so in the interest of time i wanted to
express
why i personally think that the vaccine
registry is vital to medical care not
only on the primary care level but also
on the critical care level
i recently this past weekend working a
24-hour shift had a patient come in who
essentially came in for an asthma
exacerbation
their
their care was initially just
transferred to our practice actually and
we had no records of their vaccination
status considering that they had most of
their vaccines prior
to the initiation of our vaccine
registry not only did this complicate
kind of our management style but it also
led to kind of unnecessary
testing and other kind of medical
considerations given that we did not
have these records at hand and i think
the important part here is that care
management does not change unless
there's a big kind of consideration to
make and without these records and this
being complete records it made a
severely significant kind of change in
our medical management and that is not
something that we take lightly
necessarily
so i think this speaks links to how the
vaccine registry can be critical to our
management style itself
as having these records complete will
alter our care
thank you and i just wanted to add one
other quick story our families who move
from state to state are surprised that
new hampshire doesn't have a functioning
vaccine registry it comes up on a
regular basis for us with regards to
families who struggle to get the records
that they would like for the care that
they would need and i want to be able to
make sure that i can make that first
visit as effective as i possibly can
and when we don't always have that
records it's actually quite difficult
and unfortunately we've all had the
experience where trying to get records
from various different health systems
doesn't go as smoothly as you might like
it to
and having a vaccine registry makes it a
much smoother process for us to be able
to get all the records that we need for
families to have the records that they
need
at their fingertips
thank you
representative
weber
thank you for your testimony and um
doctor i'm sorry the pediatric resident
i didn't get your name properly but
could you detail for us some of the
medical
interventions that you were required
that you felt were necessary because you
did not have vaccination records
available to us what what was
the consequences for the patient
in terms of both medical care and cost
so i think um otherwise speaking
it would it would really or result in
extra testing particularly to make sure
that our patients if they do have these
vaccines on borders or not
other considerations would be medication
management changing what kind of
medications we might need to treat these
patients with
thank you
apologies the whisper was just to remind
her to be careful with private
information with regards to how we
answer those questions
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you both
for being here today um i
have a two-part question the first is it
sounds like a lot of families see the
value and i'm curious if making it
opt-in would be a burden to those
families who want this system and then
the second part of my question is i had
to go to the emergency room with my
very young child when we were unable to
get into the doctor for any of the
immunizations
before that visit so we were stuck in
the ambulance bay as bit of an airlock
chamber and they just they just did all
those different diagnoses if that is
a risk that a family is willing to take
if their information isn't in there
because they choose not to opt in
is that a reasonable choice
i guess the question is
that that's just the consequence of
somebody choosing not to opt in
thank you very much for your question
representative um so i'm gonna start
with the second one and then go back i
may need a quick reminder on the first
question but the second uh piece is that
families should always have the right to
be able to refuse a vaccine and that
happens with regards to my conversations
with families on a regular basis as well
as the vaccine registry so i'll often
talk to families about the idea that you
know you're advocating for your child if
you choose and not to vaccinate that is
completely your right to be able to
choose that i just remind families just
make sure you tell the medical
professionals you're working with in the
emergency room or any other sessions so
that they can have that consideration in
mind in case it were to alter care
with regards to the decisions that you
might make and it might have to do with
if a child has a fever in the emergency
room the list of things that it could be
is different if you've had the different
childhood vaccines versus if you hadn't
so absolutely that's a family's right to
make that decision and so it's important
that there should be an ability for
folks to not be in that registry if they
would choose not to be
and that's why we want to make sure we
have that option and i apologize what
was the first question again mine well
my baby was unvaccinated just because of
when he was born thanks to carvid
but this first question was you have so
many families that want to have this
information in a database is having to
just check a box and say i opt in an
undue burden for them
um it's not necessarily a burden for
them as the piece of from a family
perspective the vaccine registry still
functions as far as an opt-in with
regards to an individual family the
problem becomes is how well it works
when you're talking about the aggregate
data in general
so for example as a provider
when you're creating that initial opt-in
you don't know what's going to happen to
you down the line with regards to if
you're in an emergency room and you
can't have the records at the fingertips
at the times that you necessarily want
it so the opt-out process allows us to
have a much more effective tool
as a whole with we've got more families
involved because again there's the vast
majority of families will choose to opt
in from that standpoint
i would like to say from the resident
perspective the logistics of kind of
working through that
often comes at the um
at the expense of our time so it might
help it might delay care
having to have that opt-in process
representative folsom
thank you chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um
i'm hearing from at least i think i'm
hearing from you as pediatricians
is you're concentrating on just those
immunizations
that are given
to children and are required for school
and things like that
you're not necessarily speaking to
immunizations that people can choose to
have
or not have later in in
as they get older
for the most part i thank you for your
question you're correct because in this
case the vaccine registry is focused on
the state-supplied vaccines so depending
on which age range we're talking about
at which vaccines we're talking about
not all of them end up being supplied in
the same way
so yes the majority of these the vaccine
registries historically were started
back in the late 90s
and the early 2000s across the the
country were for the school documented
vaccines so with regards to the
conversation before schools day cares
things like that
um so
the fact that
most of these were set up just to follow
those childhood vaccines
um adding in now the the covid19 people
that have gotten their immunizations
wasn't necessarily the original intent
of these registries
that is correct these uh the registries
were set up as an idea
essentially before and even in new
hampshire this first came up basically
long before covid is with regards to
being a useful tool for us as healthcare
professionals thank you
we would like the cove i mean the more
information in the tool the better but
with regards to vaccines but it was set
up not with regards to covenant 19 in
mind
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking the question
you raised a
point about the pain point being
the ordering side more than the
registry itself
can you speak to or someone can speak to
is the data that goes in when you
register the vaccine
used on the ordering side in other words
if you don't put the ordering
the vaccine into the information system
it won't have that data to order a
replacement vaccine can you kind of
speak to that do you have that knowledge
to help me understand this i i thank you
very much for your question i do have
some of that knowledge and can give a
little bit of shed light on that so is
from a practice perspective those two
systems work hand in hand in that i have
to supply the state either kind of the
data within the vaccine registry or an
opt-out
with regards to this is how much vaccine
i need
and so the state doesn't necessarily
know which families opt out they just
have the information that i did one of
two things i either supplied the
information as part of the vaccine
registry or gave them an opt-out form
for the families that chose to opt out
and that's how much vaccine i used
during and so it's part of the tracking
system from that standpoint
so the difficulty we're having is the
documentation is it has to be all by
hand so someone from our staff has to
actually enter in that data because
we're still working on with the state on
making sure that there's an electronic
interface so that my electronic medical
record will supply the data needed with
button push as opposed to manually
entering that's actually been the
difficulty not that the system itself
the registry is difficult
and it's a hurdle that all the states
have had to go through with regards to
like electronic medical records but
that's the part we're still working and
that's where it's been difficult
anything further uh representative
cushman
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so i i just keep
hearing the the argument that um there
will be lower participation in the
registry and we won't have as much data
if it's an opt-in but if the opt-out is
being
the opportunity for an opt-out is being
provided as it's required by law
wouldn't the participation be the same
when we think about vaccines in general
i apologize thank you very much for the
question when we think about vaccine
processes in general
the presumptive approach that that
someone is going to be able to do a
vaccine so i apologize i'm going to use
the example of a vaccine a family that's
uncertain about doing a vaccine if i
present the choice to a family as a
you your billy is due for these vaccines
for today
is different than would you like to do
these vaccines for today the acceptance
rate of a vaccine process is a little
bit different depending on a presumptive
approach versus one that's you know so
opt-in versus opt-out from that
standpoint so that's why we suspect if
we didn't opt-in our utilization of that
system would drop significantly it's
still extremely important for a family
to have an option to opt out they always
should
but that's why we're worried that going
to an opt-in system would decrease the
utilization of that system completely
follow-up thank you that sounds quite
manipulative
my question is on the researchers who
have access to the database
so under the administrative rules and i
understand you're here representing um
the new hampshire medical society and
you
are
a doctor at dartmouth-hitchcock so you
probably are familiar with some of the
research that goes on um
my question is under the rules for this
researchers can have access
to
the information it says to persons
conducting health related research upon
receipt of approval
so they they submit a
request
are you aware if there's any limitations
of whether that
is only is it scientific research is it
political research um do you know
any of the rules that i've got
by training um so i have not not aware
of how that would be used in that
utility in that instance thank you okay
thank you
any other questions
doctor
sorry representative kenner just a quick
one um is it your impression
particularly with this issue about
concern about
participation
that
many patients or parents do not
necessarily understand the implications
of how their care in future could be
compromised by not being involved with
having a data set that's useful
thank you very much for your question
yes that would be my concern that it
requires more effort to explain what it
is
um as we kind of go through i want
families to be able to ask questions and
understand the process but that would be
the concern that an opt-in would make it
more onerous for us to make this a
useful tool
representative merchant
thank you mr chair and also thank you
for taking my second question
we've heard a lot of things about what's
going into the database as a
pediatrician
one of both of you
what data is absolutely necessary to be
in that database in order for you to do
and care for the patient in this case
obviously be a child what actually has
to go into the database because
what i'm hearing is it seems to be extra
data going in there that may not be
helpful from a medical point of view
thank you very much for the question i
would say in this case i need to make
sure that it is actually billy smith so
all the different things that would
require to make sure that it's this
billy smith not that billy smith that
i'm getting the information on so that
would be the key piece and then the
immunization piece so from a medical
perspective that's the pieces i need is
the immunization information and
whatever is required true to me you know
to be 100 certain that that's the
individual i'm talking about
seeing no more hands thank you so much
for your testimony appreciate your
coming opportunity
the chair recognizes
the honorable neil kirk
long member of the house sometime
chairman of finance
good afternoon to you mr chairman and
punster now emeritus of the house
uh i take second to you in that category
sir i hope your committee is fully aware
of your talents and have benefited from
their exercise there have been more
eyeball roles than i can
count um
i was at the conception of the uh
registry in 1998
and indeed it is an opt-out registry the
statute is very clear in section three
although it doesn't use the words opt
out
that this is an opt-out registry and the
reason for that is important for this
group today
i think the prior witness indicated
something which i call human inertia
most people tend to do nothing
when faced with
life
and activities so if you set up a system
where doing nothing has one result
you're going to get that result
if you set up the opposite system you're
going to get that result
at the time we put this into effect it
was the judgment of all folks at the
table that most people really either
didn't care whether their information
was in the registry or affirmatively
would want to be there and a very small
minority
would be very concerned about privacy
and not want it there
i personally am one of that small
minority but i recognize that there is a
social benefit to having this
information
from a public health point of view
and so the agreement was we'd create an
opt-out system basically if you did
nothing you were in and if you wanted to
be excluded you had to take an action
the intention was that you would be
presented with that opportunity
literally a piece of paper right before
you before the jab
the first time at least with each
provider that was the concept
that's not what's happened in practice
the representatives from the department
of health and human
services are extraordinarily hardworking
well-intentioned people
and they took the legislative directive
public health when it comes to the
vaccine registry very seriously
they still haven't grasped
the concept of privacy
that should be embedded in that
department and is embedded in the
constitution you have house bill 1622 by
representative edwards which attempts to
put the department on record by
establishing a privacy
organization within the department to
change the thinking of the department
because right now the thinking is public
health is absolutely imperative and
privacy takes second place
i think that's changing
and representative edwards bill will do
that but now you're faced with the
dilemma in representative lang's bill
how do we go about dealing with the
balance between public health
and privacy
i can assure you that the constitutional
amendment is really not in play here the
constitutional amendment would not be
violated in the current system opt-in
uh sorry opt-out or in the proposed
system opt-in because in both cases
people have a choice
that's the key thing
with the chair's permission
i'd like to suggest an amendment which
threads the needle
before you do a representative just for
the record the bill in question i i
believe is 1662.
representative
yeah i apologize that's all right i just
wanted to get it
on and yes proceed please with the
amendment thank you
thank you
the world has changed since uh 1998
and
covet 19 has changed
um some of the issues that we thought we
had decided well in 1998.
covert 19 has brought privacy to the
fore with opt-out opponents increasingly
vocal and possibly more numerous than
before
that is it's less clear to me now that
fewer people would opt out
i'd like to suggest a compromise for the
committee's consideration and that's
what this amendment does
it requires a person
and although it doesn't say this and it
should the first time
a provider proposes to
inoculate or immunize or vaccinate the
person that the person choose and you
see that right in front of you i choose
either to participate or not to
participate in the registry
so there would be a conscious
option before everyone not opt-in or
opt-out but you choose
it would be done once
for each provider so if i went to
hannaford's as
was suggested hannafords would have to
give me this option
only the first time
if i went back and back and back
they would not have to give it to me
again the only time they and if i didn't
want to participate i could fill out the
department's form by the way one of the
problems with the department's forms is
because they really want to get
everybody in the registry is they made
it difficult for people to opt out they
made it difficult to withdraw
because you have to get a provider
signature but gee i've changed providers
or i no longer have a provider what do i
do how much time does it take come on i
want to watch the football game i'm not
going to do this so the department needs
to recognize that everything has to be
as easy as possible up front no
unnecessary hurdles
one other thing
i think the committee should focus on
the opt-in opt-out there are a lot of
questions raised about the kind of
information that's in the registry who
has access to it and things like this
these are important questions
but they deserve bills of their own
because this bill really focuses on one
part of it there are problems with the
registry that this committee should
address but not necessarily through this
bill
going on with this
amendment
those are the only two things that you
have to do
choose and there's a check off box
it says
i understand this decision will not
prevent me or my child from receiving
immunizations and i understand i can
reverse my decision at any time and then
you sign it
it also says that if you sign it you're
still not relieved from your obligation
to get vaccinations
in statute okay and that's all it does
notice a doctor signature isn't required
you don't have to have anything
notarized it's very easy very simple
but i'd like to point out the things at
the bottom of the page because they're
equally important
number one no other substantive
information shall appear on the form
it's important that
the department not add other things to
this which would complicate things
number two this form shall be on a
separate piece of paper or on a separate
electronic screen
it can't be buried
number three c
no one shall administer
a vaccination immunization until the
form is completed at least for the first
time and i admit
that first time doesn't appear here and
needs to
and finally
if the patient
elects not to participate
then no information about this form goes
to the state
the reason for putting the form in
statute
rather than going through jail car
two reasons gel cart takes forever it'll
take you six months at least to get it
through and during the process
perhaps the department will change the
form in a way that the legislature
hadn't intended and gel card doesn't
catch
so for those two reasons time and making
sure that what the legislator sets as
policy in fact occurs requires this form
to be in statute
there was one other disturbing info
piece of information that you folks had
that needs to be dealt with but again
not in this bill and that's the
vaccination event
because that definition which is in
rules not in statute
allows the department to get a huge
amount of information that was not the
legislation
certainly not at the time in 1998 was
the legislature's intent so
to sum up
let's make sure that everybody makes an
informed decision let's make sure that
this informed decision is made the first
time you go for a vaccination
and let's assume the legislature sets
policy not the department and that
privacy and choice is very important
even in this area where we all agree
that a vaccination registry contains
very important information for providers
it's very important for individual
families and people and it's very
important for public health
and the statute is clear as to what uses
will be made of this to prov to protect
public health
we shouldn't denigrate the registry we
shouldn't try to denude it but we should
allow individuals to choose whether or
not they want their information to to be
in there even if it means at the end of
the day that the registry is not as
useful as it would otherwise be
thank you mr chairman i'd be pleased to
answer any questions if there are if
there are any
representative connect
thank you very much just a quick one um
you made a comment about so that the
department could not add any other
further information
but um i was wondering because we again
a person or a parent or a patient may
not be aware of some of the downsides of
not having this information available as
we just heard for the from the previous
testimony
would it be reasonable to at least
modify this to say that this could
compromise
the ability of a provider to access
needed information for care in the
future
uh thank you representative knurk you've
come across as usual with one of the
problems with all these forms
if you put that down you're going to
have a major battle as to what you
should be saying there because one side
will say you've gone too far and the
other side will say you haven't gone far
enough
if you can thread that needle more power
to you but please it's the legislature
that needs to thread that needle do not
leave it to the department because no
one will be satisfied with what the
department does
it you should include the department in
consultation so you get the information
and they're pretty good at presenting
good information to you but ultimately
it's a policy decision it shouldn't be
left to rules
representative delemus
thank you mr chairman
and thank you for taking my question
it's really simple you had said
the first time someone goes to hannaford
then they're presented with this form
what if they go after going to hannaford
they go to you know dr
oz
does he present this the form again is
there is there so is it the first time
you go to a different provider for okay
um just just so you know i don't think
you want to use dr oz's name he's
running for senate i don't believe he's
practicing at the moment he certainly is
not writing his column anymore thank you
thank you representative weber
thank you and i'm i'm following up
because i'm i'm intrigued by the forum
because it's simple which i really like
and simple and the same for everybody i
think is a very good idea
my question has to do with the timing
it's clear
because what it says is prior to
receiving any immunization which would
say to me that
each time
johnny comes in
you know if the doctor says okay johnny
is due for a b and c this time
and the parent says yes we want to go
ahead with that they get the form and
and
in your testimony that doesn't sound
like it's your intent
but i wonder
i mean
i i i thank you for the question i i
understand that
so
what i'm grappling with is
the
i mean part of me says that it's
probably best to do that each time
simply because somebody has to think
about it
and we seem to be encouraging that
and it's a simple form so it's not a
huge roadblock
but
could you
if that was not your intent
which you said it wasn't could you also
propose to us the exact language to use
for
this the first time you go to the
provider and then you will be provided
by for the the form by each subsequent
provider if you would think about that
and let us know that would be helpful um
thank you representative weber i have
thought about it and i do have the
language i've modified the form i will
send the language to you folks
the the intent is
that
the first time you go to a provider you
get the form you make your decision
after that let's make life easy for all
of us you don't have to be asked 16
times
but if you go to a second provider a
different provider that's the first time
you've gone to the second provider then
that second provider needs to give you
the form
just for the first time so you may fill
out this form many times during your
child's medical career if you change
doctors during that period of time or
get your vaccinations from different
agencies i have a question um
where would you put this in the bill are
you replacing something or adding a new
section um
i would delete the language that
representative lang has which is 2a
and this is simply an amendment to
section
um
141 c 20 f roman 2 by adding the bolded
language all of my bolded language here
is in addition to
the existing language in section roman 2
which says no patient etc shall be
required to participate in the
immunization registry
and the then the amendment follows
representative
merchants
thank you mr chair chairman and also was
good to see you
former representative neil kirk the
honorable the honorable now yes um in
regards to the forums
is there
your opinion if you will of instead of
relying upon the paper form which goes
in the provider's office and it doesn't
trans travel with the patient from
provider to provider to provider
of putting in the registry
the patient's name with a notation i
have opted out
uh um
thank you for that question but i
personally would have a problem with
that
it's none of the state's business to
know
that i've opted out
that's a private matter
the only thing that the registry is
supposed to contain is my vaccination
history if i choose not to give it to
the state they shouldn't get that
information we went
we were head to head on this issue 20
years ago
that perhaps would
would violate the privacy amendment
because this is unnecessary information
that the state is collecting
that they know my vaccination status so
in effect
your suggestion would mean that i
couldn't opt out they would at least
know that i had opted out and they want
to know that for very valid public
health reasons after all there's an
emergency there's a another pandemic
they need to know who's vaccinated who
isn't uh where the clusters are they'd
love to have that information but i
think it goes beyond what they should
have
especially with respect to the privacy
amendment
follow-up
i hear the concern
honorable kirk um
by st making the statement you opted out
of the registry does not mean that you
actually are
saying you have or have not received a
vaccine it's just a question at that
point in time if i'm a medical provider
and trying to find out if therefore be
able to ask the parent or the
patient
about the status of the vaccines because
right now if
there's nothing in there for the medical
provider
to know whether the patient even opted
out of it doesn't mean they didn't get
the vaccine just means they didn't want
to opt into the registry there's two
separate things going on one's the
information the other was just not
acknowledgment that i opted out of the
registry
thank you for that question my
understanding is that the physician's
office keeps a record
his own medical records of the
vaccinations he's given to you
and regardless of whether that
information stays in the office because
you've opted out or goes stays in the
office and goes to the registry because
you've elected to participate
has has no impact on on that information
if you look at d here it's very clear if
the patient elects not to participate
um no personally identifiable
information about the patient's guard
shall be disclosed indirectly or
directly to the state of new hampshire
if you choose not to participate in the
registry no information about you your
name your address whether you were
vaccinated or not goes to the registry
representative weber
just to be clear so this amendment would
be a replace all yes from the original
bill thank you
representative gay
thank you mr chair and thank you thank
you
your honorable
i've i'm going to disagree with you i
love the form i think it's wonderful but
i think the intent is not written into
the form and therefore i think if the
combination is better
my opinion is also that
in a busy office you're supposed to
remember if this patient has been here
before what if it's a different person
why not just use the form every single
time it's very easy to check yes or no
and that way
it still goes in the record for every
single vaccination somewhere on here it
has to say which vaccination it was
um because the doctor's going to keep it
i know this is supposed to be a question
so i'm working on that i i think i
understand the question yeah so that's
two two issues here
every time put the name on
and
okay
the yeah
there's a price that we pay
for bureaucracy there's a price that we
pay for privacy
filling out these forms is going to be
somewhat onerous it will as the
department told you it's going to cost
some money
from my point of view that's not an
unreasonable price to pay for protecting
privacy however
and this is in direct response to your
question representative gay
if you do it every time
is the extra benefit from that worth the
extra cost
and that's a policy question for this
committee
personally i think it's not
but i certainly wouldn't be a verse if
the committee said no we think every
time is the right way to do it
seeing no further questions and and
thank you
mr kirk
i closed the hearing on 1606 the chair
would like to see representative lang
and representative emeritus kirk up here
a few minutes after we close
we will readjourn for the next hearing
somewhere between 120 and 125.
reconvene
well like i said to the representative a
while
go with what i'm thinking and not what
i'm saying
i apologize
i
apologize thank you
thank you
i gave one to here
privacy
um
as well
so he is doing well
but he could
he's getting
better are you here for um
is
pharmacies
it essentially says
so
um
some privacy lawyers
i don't know what's going to happen with
that that's probably a build for the
next session
but something like that
i tried
um
otherwise it's dead thank you for that
advice
so
it's just it's something that i thought
some of that has extended to
um you know where are the servers
the nsa
and
thank
all you
even
know your computer
things
oh
okay
yes yeah
thank you
regulated
oh
paulie
um
oh
yes
mmm
itself
questions
okay
so
not bad
is
my bill
this believe me is not a housekeeping
bill
but you know what when lucy ever jumped
in as she did it led me to have a
lengthy conversation with the
commissioner of dhhs
who said there's a lot of people
appointed by title
to the ethics committee
and she said they may be ethical people
but i don't think they've ever studied
athletes so if i went to them for advice
it would just be economic
constituent group or whatever i said
let's put together what an ethics
committee should be
six to eight people at most
all trained in ethics that when you have
an ethical question they won't give you
a political answer
so we're rewriting the bill so
housekeeping turned into a complete redo
of the statute
sure
it's odds what we tell our patients
is
if you get the vaccines
here are the odds
of you still getting covered and the
severity these are odds these are
generalized
and if you don't
you won't have horrible reactions to the
vaccine by definition
which the
two daughters of one of my providers had
horrible reactions to the vaccine
so let's tell you
all the truth
and if you want to go on this podcast or
that blog
and get ideology
any
end of the
so we have to say we don't know
this is uncharted territory
how many years did it take to figure to
get the little bugs out of the polio
vaccine system because yeah it was odds
and my parents
in 1955 when it first came out
knew that there were a few kids that had
harmed for life
there were also a lot of kids that
didn't get polio
so they knew it was ours
then you work to see what you can do
regarding those
uh
interesting
how
much populations
uh
thank you
okay
um
foreign
okay
there's
this
continuously
you
okay
we're here
oh
uh
um
hello
myself
i said
all right good afternoon
ladies and gentlemen i'll call to order
the
or back to order health human services
and elderly affairs
and
we will now be hearing house bill
1080 relative to the rights of
conscience for medical professionals and
i recognize his honor chair
mark representative mark pearson to
introduce
the bill
thank you mr chairman
years ago
i remember watching public service
announcements
on the boston tv stations
talking about repression
of conscience
around the world
as i recall
they were sponsored by a liberal
protestant church denomination that my
parents and i belonged to
it made quite an impression on me
to see how
this one or that one
were compromised forced into violation
of their conscience
by persons of power
the bill before us speaks to one group
that i believe could use our help
medical professionals
the guts
the bill is the
health care freedom of conscience
document
that was sent to me by people in another
state
where this was also enacted
i've learned it's considered model
legislation
and has been introduced and is being
introduced
in various places
my testimony today has been informed in
part
by reading of the various emails that
have come to all of us
and while yes
the issue of abortion is one issue
that faces
medical professionals this bill is not
an abortion bill
what about for example
the physician
who is strongly
let's say
encouraged
to prescribe medicine by the mba
who runs the medical facility she works
for
follow the money
this is a real life example
of something that happened
what if the conscience
of this medical provider says
that's not nearly as good for my patient
as some similar brand
you will
wink wink
nudge nudge
just inside the line but the point is
clear
prescribe what we tell you
always careful
that you can't quite nail them on that
statement what about the conscience of
that person
now where am i getting my information
for
all of this
it's not from a guy at the gym
i don't go to the gym gyms cost money i
walk my street is free
it's not from a podcast i don't even
really know what a podcast is
it's not from a blog i think i know what
they are but i don't go to blogs
as for tv news
those nights that i watch
one news program i will confess and it
may shock some of my colleagues i watch
abc because david muir is a scotsman and
i'm going to stand with my fellow
scotsman
where i do get my information
is from the three pcps who work for me
from local colleagues of theirs
i like dr parties the shrimp is usually
top of the line and there's interesting
conversation
i also get my information
as
my three and those others go to
conferences and come back
there's a lot of
information out there that i'm not sure
i can trust
i trust the people that i've just
mentioned
when primary medicine was mostly
stand-alone practices
the local doctor would set her or his
policies
and they kind of swapped around on
certain things and i was a little too
young to understand why that doctor
on certain things
another doctor in town did them but they
had some kind of an understanding
so the good medical care could continue
and yet their rights of conscience it
would seem would be protected
now most primary care providers work for
large groups
where the employers make decisions
the young physician is three hundred
thousand dollars in debt and knows
better than to rock the system or bite
the hand that pays the bills
we hear laments
from numbers of our physician friends
and people begging to come to our
medical facility because in there some
of them are told you have 15 minutes to
treat that patient
what if the patient needs 28 minutes
i know what it was like once to be
rushed through something
because the next one had to come in
because the doctor was told the next one
has to come in or the insurance company
says you're going to get reimbursed
for 15 minutes
i know what it's like when we take 28
minutes to do it we're a non-profit
organization we have bake sales
so that we can treat the patient the way
the patient needs
now
this is relevant
to my bill because
physicians are quitting medicine
for a variety of reasons but some of it
is i want to be treated as a
professional not as an employee of a
for-profit organization
but also some are quitting
some i've talked to
because they've been asked to do things
that violate their conscience
now some email authors objected to the
possibility that a doctor would refuse
his or her patient
some treatment meaning they would not
have any care
for that person
well
as we heard actually articulated in this
very committee
that if a doctor didn't want to treat
somebody for lack of vaccination status
another provider could be providing such
a thing
it's not that there's one doctor
in town
and it's not that that doctor is going
to say i now refuse to treat you too bad
to be you remember they can be
discharged from practice
we know other people in our area who do
things that perhaps certain physicians
do not wish to do
things get done the patient does not
suffer
and if it's a case of well there's not
continuity of care have you ever heard
of a hospitalist
our facility was the last facility in
south central rockingham county
where the doctor would get up at three
in the morning trying not to wake me up
to go to the hospital because one of our
patients was admitted
hospitalists don't know the patient but
they know medicine
and so when somebody's in the hospital
your family practice doctor probably
doesn't go there's a continuity of care
somebody else is there
as we've heard in our committee
giving what the patient
wants
probably needs
and honoring the conscience of the
provider
do not have to be opposites
i've been told that this bill is not
needed because there are provisions in
the law now well if it's true
then why are some providers finding
themselves in serious difficulty with
their employers
someone i asked to provide research on
this question told me
that only in vermont and colorado
are their lacks of the kind of
protection we seek here new hampshire
for once isn't last we're third from
again back to that list of blue states
i'm coming to like much to my surprise
and to my humbling
new york and california have protection
this is getting a little scary
i do not seek to deny a patient what
that person truly needs
i am trying to recollect those rights of
conscience ads i recall from my youth
and protect the individual providers
from the decisions of some increasingly
finance driven
big medicine operations
and not at the expense of patient care
thank you mr chairman
thank you representative pearson and
will you take questions i will
i recognize representative weber
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
chairman for taking my question
thank you chairman emeritus
you have spoken well
eloquently on the issue of the
pressures
financial pressures and otherwise on the
medical profession and how
that impacts a medical professional's
choices in practice
but
am i clear that this bill in front of us
speaks
only
to the issues of
provision
care surrounding abortions
sterilization
and artificial contraception and has
nothing to do
with the pressures that an insurance
company brings on a physician when they
say thou shalt see a patient for only 15
minutes
you are correct and as you seem to do so
admirably with my bills
have
suggested to me
uh an amendment that i would like to
broaden it from abortion i said it's not
an abortion bill and you have correctly
pointed out what's in the bill
i would like to broaden it to
matters of conscience
so thank you again
follow up
may i suggest that if it is broadened to
matters of conscience globally rather
than the very specific limits of this
bill
would you not agree with me that that
should be the subject of a further
public hearing as nobody who wanted to
comment beyond the issue of abortion
would have noticed that they needed to
be here and say something
that would seem fair yes
thank you representative weber
representative soloway
thank you mr chairman um and
representative pearson um
thank you for your eloquence i uh
strongly support the conversation that
you have just had with uh the
representative from walpole strongly
support that
do you believe perhaps sir that at the
same time physicians who make choices of
conscience
need to be protected from those who
would punish them
for making uh choices of conscience so
perhaps if somebody is outside
demonstrating
against a physician who has acted
on matters of conscience
should they not be protected from that
in what way sir
um
i am aware of physicians
being
murdered
for their choices of conscience
i would be against that
um
and if the question is picketing outside
i support free speech even if it's
speech that i do not like
okay
thank you representative
thank you representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question i understand i was a
little confused at first and i
understand that your intent is to
broaden this to other issues that affect
um health care providers and certainly
there are a lot of them i got the wrong
seat here i can never it's like i have a
pole in front of me at the boston garden
the chair has that when i sit there too
yeah
um
so if we are going to broaden it or even
if we aren't going to broaden it
um it seems to me that there might be
as there frequently
are
competing
goods and in this case between the
choice of a medical practitioner
and
the ability to run a business
and there might be some trade-offs here
so if i could just give you one example
and
maybe you could tell me how this might
get handled
certainly there would be more examples
if we broadened it but even with even
with the way it's written now
what if you were a provider who provided
services for family planning
worked at planned parenthood
and you had a religious conversion and
decided that you no longer believed in
um
birth control
that exact case actually came up
in a conference that my wife attended
and there was someone who did have such
a religious conversion
and in this particular case that was the
change of what the provider would no
longer do
went to the owners the owner said you're
too felt too valuable to lose we have
four other doctors here
who do not have such a new belief as you
do and we'll work around it
okay i would just
follow one follow-up i would assume
that that is a pretty unusual situation
and i would also assume to be fair
that if somebody had that religious
conversion they'd probably leave that
job and go find a job somewhere else on
their own
but if push came to shove
and the
owner
or the operator of a medical
practice
couldn't have
couldn't insist that someone provides
certain services
wouldn't that be a
burden on on a business or a burden on
an organization
it's kind of curious this year that all
of us who one day argue for business
argue against it the next day and then
vice versa would you believe
i'll take that as your answer
okay all right thank you uh
representative merchant
thank you mr chairman also thank grips
that appears i'm taking my question
all
many bills we've heard
before this committee seem to be a
balancing act between rights
the right to the parents rights of the
child
rights of the employer the rights of the
employed
and it it's a challenge trying to figure
out where that line gets drawn
in this whole thing
i don't see anything about the rights of
the patient what i'm trying to get to is
that
if you are going to a provider
and they don't want to do the procedure
there's nothing here that says the
provider should be required
to inform the patient where they may go
to get the provider you talked about
before in a small town there was a way
for it to kind of magically work its way
through
but in doing it this way and things have
changed now in 2020
or 2022.
what about the rights of the patient to
be informed about where they could
possibly go who could help them in a
situation where the provider before them
is not willing to do it
i do know in some cases where a provider
has the ability to exercise conscience
said providers have
said here are places where you could go
i'm not saying that's universal and it's
certainly not in the law but that has
been my experience more than it has not
been
follow-up
thank you mr chairman
would you be opposed then to an
amendment that would require the
provider
to exercise that right to inform the
patient as part of their ability to
object to it to inform the patient there
is alternatives so the patient's
informed at that point in time not left
in the dark
my sympathy is to say i would not be
opposed to that i don't want to give a
final answer as i work through the
amendment but thank you for that
suggestion and i don't have a pen down
here so i hope you're all writing it
down for me
thank you
thank you representative canuck thank
you very much sort of a two-parter one
is if we're going to broaden it
then would you agree that or i should
ask
should it be broadened such it would
protect a healthcare worker who might
work at a facility
which already prohibits abortion
sterilization and contraception that
would give them the right to do those
procedures and still work at that
facility
in other words they would still be able
to follow their conscience if they think
that is proper medical care and their
institution normally does not allow that
would that be acceptable to add to this
as well when broadening it
wow representative kirk was right about
you you are brilliant
let me think about that one too that
that is totally not crossed my mind i
would have to think about it
okay seriously hoping to follow up a
follow-up representative and follow up
another hypothetical
having to do with emergency care because
where i live indeed
for certain things there is only one
provider so let's say a woman comes in
with a ruptured ectopic pregnancy
it is late at night
they are in
the memorial hospital in conway the
closest other facility is going to be at
least an hour away and the person on
call does not it's against their
conscience
to
care for that patient and treat that
ectopic pregnancy and that person will
die before they get to huggins hospital
i don't see anything here i don't i'm
not sure that i saw anything about
emergency care would
that would prohibit the person from
violating this or shall i say would this
bill immunize that provider from the
clear-cut malpractice that they would
have done by not operating on that
patient at two in the morning i would
suggest my notetakers add that to the
list because my statement would be in
in situations where you're the sole
provider and other alternatives are
unrealistically
far away
don't go there to work
well then could i maybe make one more
follow-up because that was for emergency
care but actually that same situation
was unrealistically far away
again
uh for many of us we have to travel a
very long way up in my neck of the woods
to obtain health care and so it might
not even be an emergency and you might
have to travel for an hour and a half to
be able to
fill a prescription if somebody has an
aversion to something or well probably
prescription not there's more pharmacies
but for other care because the only
provider
might not have met a problem i think
maybe you just confine it to emergency i
suppose
i like that yeah representative leon has
some guidance for us on that subject
thank you mr chairman uh would you
believe that on page one
line 15 it says that an abortion is not
defined as removing an ectopic pregnancy
so that already is something that right
now is carved out and there's there it's
fine for somebody to uh
it seems that that a life-saving
treatment ever a ruptured ectopic
pregnancy
wouldn't
fall underneath that conscience i'm not
sure if i'm understanding that correctly
or not
that's in
in the section on page one from lines
twelve to sixteen that specifically says
ectopic pregnancy on line 15
to remove an ectopic pregnancy
but that's just the definition a person
might still object the provider might
still object they might call that an
abortion even though we know it isn't
okay we'll leave that for our discussion
at the end do we have um
plenty of others that we need to hear
from so with your patients selected now
recognize uh representative mckay
um thank you mr chairman and thank you
chairman
we're almost full of chairman
how do you take into account those
individuals who have no conscience at
all
dr makai i hope they would not have
gotten through medical school
thank you for your brief response and
guidance
let's see we have uh
representative woods please
uh thank you mr chair and uh thank you
mr chair for taking my
question uh are you aware of the ama
code of ethics
uh and its comment which
addresses
the point that you're trying to do is
make it a more general form as you know
or are you aware that the rsa already
embeds the ama's code of meth code of
ethics as the guideline for which
physicians are
are held
yes but insufficiently it would seem i
would appreciate you shooting me
something on that but the question
remains why then are people getting in
trouble with their
their uh employers
that i'll just uh just to read
a physician may decline to establish a
patient physician relationship with a
prospective patient
or provide specific care to an existing
patient in certain limited circumstances
that list several
and in there is
or is incompatible with a physician's
deeply held personal religious
or moral beliefs in keeping with ethics
guidance on exercise of conscience
so in terms of
you're trying to expand this in a more
general
conscience manner that seems like it's
already covered
and might be something to refer back to
would that be
something you're looking forward
i really like it when my friends help my
bill get better
representative webber
thank you again and i i have a couple of
other situations that i'd like to
inquire about
uh one would be
what about
you spoke of when
somebody had a conscientious objection
and there were four other members in the
practice who could take care of the
issue
my concern would be what about the
person who is employed by
one of the reproductive health care
centers whose business
focuses on
reproductive health care
both from the
point of view of promoting
healthy pregnancies and also from the
point of view of providing
people with legal
alternatives
when their reproductive choices are
different
is it
would this bill not
require if somebody working there
underwent
a conversion and decided that they could
no longer prescribe
birth control or aid in the performance
of abortions
would this not require them to keep that
person on and pay them even though they
were unable to perform any of the core
functions of the job that they were
hired for i should hope not
what i'm trying to speak to
is
the situation of a provider
where occasionally this comes up
but but as a follow-up mr chairman
may i
you may follow up once
okay i have a whole nother question but
this calls for a follow-up
on page 2 uh
31-35 there's an anti-discrimination
clause
that i wonder if it would not require
that person to be kept on staff
indefinitely even though they no longer
provide any of the core functions of the
job they were hired for i would be quite
happy to rewrite that thank you for that
reason if that is the core or a
serious percentage of what that facility
does
then why are you working there it must
be painful for you to go to work and see
what's going on why would you
cash your paycheck under false pretenses
no i i'm with you i appreciate that
point thank you
and i will hold my other
uh for instance for another time
yes just a little later on we got 12 uh
individuals to hear from uh but first is
a representative shapiro
yes thank you mr chairman um
i know you accused me of defending
businesses but i just wanna i just wanna
i was complimenting you sir i don't
i just wanna pursue this a little bit
more and this is a this is a question
but it's really
um
a suggestion of something to think about
and
since you talked about broadening
the freedom of conscience
and since one of the examples where you
used was how we know that
practitioners have
experienced speed ups in the way they
work and i personally am very
sympathetic on this issue i know
lots of people who've left the field
because at some point it changed so
dramatically that they felt they were no
longer able to really
be present with patients anymore they
were thinking about the medical record
and they were thinking of all the
paperwork they had to fill out so
i think it would be great if something
could be done about this but i guess i'm
one my question is if you were to
broaden it
how would these situations be parsed
in terms of
the business is right or in some cases
the businesses need financial need to
stay in business because they're under a
lot of pressure too
and the
practitioners right of conscience or
really the right to just practice in a
humane reasonable way
if
anyway my question is might something be
put in the bill that would help people
negotiate those kinds of situations
i would suggest that completely revising
how we practice medicine in this country
is a little bit bigger than i want to
tackle
um but i'd love to be part of a work
group that did
in terms of counseling which was not
part of your question but part of your
prelude
that's another issue too that could be
addressed in terms of time blocks that
would be another issue too i would like
this bill as significantly rewritten now
to address procedures
thank you but thank you for the
suggestions this sounds like some good
things to do over the summer thank you
thank you uh representative snow
as usual the one guy that has problems
with the microphone right
uh on page two
uh uh line 27
is a section that seems to absolve
the practitioner from any civil or
criminal liability
for any
action or lack of action that they take
with regard to any of these issues
but then again
on
the third page under civil remedies
we have a number of different civil
remedies that can be taken now the low
civil remedies only apply
to the institution or health care
provider
health care company
that does it and
even though the
the
provider themselves is civilly protected
is that
accurate am i assuming that these civil
remedies only apply
to the company that operates the
facility not
the practitioner that that
refused
was unable to do it my understanding is
whoever is punished
for being forced
to do an act against conscience whether
that
however that punishment is being fired
being whatever
that is the one who has
a civil case
that would be my assumption if you
suffered because of a violation of this
law
you're the one
who gets
remedial action
if that is not well written i'd be happy
to look at that
i i i probably the last one that could
really suggest how you'd write it any
clearer and i think you should be
applauded but make it as clear as you
did however i can still see a little bit
of a problem here where
a person
has this one section that says they're
protected as long as they're acting
based on their conscience did not do
something
and then how do you make the
determination that they had a right to
do that at the time they did
versus the company's pressure to do it
anyway
i guess i'm not making myself clear if
the company harmed materially
the practitioner
by firing demotion whatever
then that person thus punished
would have recourse
so it would be a practitioner i believe
so
the
client not serve though no no the the
the person who's being punished gets
recourse the recourse may be against the
one doing the punishing
i guess she answered my question the
client the client or the recipient of
the service has no recourse
only the practitioner of the company
that's what this bill is about that's
not to say there aren't other issues
that could be addressed on other
occasions this
bill is primarily to protect the rights
of a medical professional who is acting
according to his or her conscience
and this teeth in there because a lot
without teeth doesn't work
thank you okay thank you
any further questions from members for
the prime sponsor
seeing we're clear at the moment i will
then uh thank you mr chairman
and i'll recognize representative
welper
uh to come to the table and he is in
support of the bill
and he's asked for two minutes
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is
representative kurt welper i represent
stratfor district 3 the towns of
stratford and new durham
i come here as a co-sponsor of this bill
primarily because when i was talking
about it with
the prime sponsor
i was suggesting the bill myself
and he said well you know so i said okay
fine
um
i want to say one thing of my own i want
to respond to a couple of things i've
i've heard
so the first one is part one article
four
of the new hampshire constitution rights
of conscience unalienable
among the natural rights some are of
their very nature unalienable because no
equivalent no equivalent can be given
for
or received
for them
of this kind
are the rights of conscience
this sets the rights of conscience
above
almost all of our other rights
and i hear that respect here in this
committee and i'm really excited to hear
it
everybody that i've heard so far said
well we agree with the intent of the
bill
when i suggested the bill to chairman
pearson
he said
i wanted a broader bill
he said no we should just stay focused
on this one thing we're going to hear
all kinds of other things
in the upcoming
session and i'm sure you've heard some
of those a lot of them having to do with
vaccinations
we chose to make this bill very narrow
and i encourage you to leave it very
narrow
the broader you try to make it
the more objections there will be
and the fewer cases
where it would actually apply
for example we talked about it was
mentioned in the questioning about was
what if somebody goes to cmc or somebody
works for planned parenthood
and they have a conversion
what happens
well that's a real problem but in such a
case i want you to think about what the
right of conscience really is
because if it is this right that is so
powerfully expressed in our constitution
then it's powerful enough to cause one
to leverage employment
voluntarily
because the conscience itself will act
on the person like it did on abby
johnson when she was a medical director
for planned parenthood in texas
and when she saw what they were actually
doing at planned parenthood her
conscience drove her
to become the pro-life advocate she's
been for the past couple decades
her conscience drove her to that that's
what conscience does
so we don't really have to worry
about one who comes to
a new feeling of conscience
while they're employed they'll leave
they'll take care of that themselves the
same thing with the doctor who's on call
right it's wonderful to see that the ama
recognizes the importance of the right
of conscience but that doesn't protect
anybody in our real world
it's just a guideline that's supposed to
be followed
so
it's a good expression of why we need
this bill
yeah i'll leave it at that webwelper
welfare that's the time we have for you
you know we thank you very much
as uh before you step off though are
there any questions for representative
welper on on what he had to tell us
today
no questions thank you again sir
i recognize uh dr richard johnson
to come to the table
and he's in support of the bill and sir
you had uh wrist written testimony
is that something you can pass out prior
to your
talk
your appropriate pros will keep us
interested
so we want to have that
passed out and real quickly
dr johnson you have the floor
and
it's we're keeping this to about two
minutes to two minutes 30 seconds
thank you so we can hear everyone today
appropriately so you are on
thank you mr chairman and member of the
committee my name is richard johnson i
am a new hampshire physician i'm also
the state representative for the
american academy of medical ethics
uh
thank you for taking my testimony in
support of hb 1080.
is there a problem
the answer is yes
i'm going to quote
if you have qualms about abortion
sterilization and birth control
do not practice women's health
so wrote julie cantor md
attorney in the new england journal of
medicine
the result of this line of teaching is
actually denying
pro-life women care
especially difficult obstetrical care
from a physician that she can trust
because they share the same values
a 2019 national survey of
more than 1700 faith-based professionals
healthcare professionals found that 32
percent
were pressured
forced
or actually punished
to participate in training or performing
a procedure
that they found objectionable based on
their own ethical principles
over 70 percent of these respondents
said they would rather leave the
profession
than be forced to violate their
conscience
so you see conscience
our conscience is developed by moral
reasoning
therefore it's more than just a private
moral sensibility it is rational
and its claims and conclusions can be
communicated
and taught to others
when healthcare professionals believe
that they themselves are morally
responsible for their own
decisions their own intentions and their
own actions
they must maintain their moral integrity
they should never be treated as mere
channels for the preferences of others
individual integrity is not simply one
interest among many it's a fundamental
value
that warrants the highest highest level
of moral consideration and respect
no professional organization or
governing body should ever mandate
participation in medical practices or
procedures that violate the conscience
of a health care professional
or trainee
the right or i should say in protecting
the right of conscience the state
is in no way inserting itself into the
doctor-patient relationship
rather right-of-conscious laws promote
freedom
protect patients and allow health care
professionals to uphold hippocratic
principles that have guided medical care
for hundreds of years
we need to protect the conscience rights
of new hampshire's health care
professionals okay dr johnson will you
take questions i will
do we have questions from the members
i i would like to just say one thing i
hope you noticed that i used the word
health care professional i am not using
the word
what do you all use
provider
okay we'll still be very important
distinction
when you're talking about these issues
representative merchant you had a
question
thank you mr chairman and dr johnson
thank you for taking my question in
regards to the survey when we're clear
about the database in which the survey
was taken not for or against it but be
clear for all of us that was taken from
faith-based health professionals correct
in your opinion is that a somewhat
skewed
biased survey
the survey was focused on
faith-based health professionals because
it wanted to find out what faith-based
health professionals thought
not what the general
population of health care professionals
thinks so yes it was a targeted audience
it wasn't biased it was a known target
thank you dr johnson any further
questions for dr johnson
okay thank you very much sir thank you
we will recognize
madame abby rogers and madame janis
emery
from health human services and elderly
affairs
and they have some information to
provide us relative to the
bill on the table
good afternoon
representative mcmahon members of the
committee
um we're here today just to talk about
one technical aspect of the bill
currently the bill would create a new
chapter 126 ee
and sorry about that
as we can see
on
page 2
romans 6 line 11 beginning at line 11
there are numerous health care providers
implicated by this bill
and because dhhs lacks oversight over
these providers we would suggest that
perhaps a more fitting place to
put this would be
under the office of professional
licensure and specifically
we might suggest rsa 332-m
that is all that we
have to provide at the moment and we're
happy to take questions
thank you very much for being succinct
and clear
questions uh representative merchant
uh thank you for the recommendation
about where to place the rsa
i haven't seen rsa 332 but sometimes we
get into oplc we get into specific
professions versus getting something
broadly
is that rsa broad or is that something
specific to physicians surgeons and so
forth
thank you for the question uh we
suggested that because that would create
a new chapter uh in the in that in 332 m
would be a new chapter so that would
specifically fit with this legislation
and that's because we felt that that
would be the broadest way to do it
because it encumbrances provider as a
lot of different definitions in the bill
any further questions
thank you very much
i'll recognize uh next
ms kayla montgomery and ms liz canada
representing planned parenthood
and they oppose the bill
and they're asking we trying to keep
this as uh close to two and a half
minutes if you will sure thing
and then we thank you very much
for that
good afternoon honorable members of this
committee my name is liz canada i'm the
advocacy manager of planned parenthood
of northern new england and planned
parenthood new hampshire action fund we
we oppose house bill 1080.
because this bill is so sweeping it
allows almost anyone who works at a
health care facility to refuse to
participate in sexual and reproductive
health care services including abortion
sterilization or the distribution of
contraception
therefore house bill 1080 imposes a
significant hardship on women
particularly patients in rural areas of
new hampshire
everyone has the right to trust that
health care workers will provide the
best care possible
not worry that they may instead impose
their private religious beliefs on their
patients
planned parenthood opposes
discrimination in all forms
however religious freedom does not
include the right to harm others
the boundaries for moral or ethical
objections are not defined in the bill
resulting in limitless possibilities for
providers who refuse to give essential
care including timely prescriptions
the bill allows any service to be denied
by anyone who is employed at a health
care entity including administrative
staff schedulers pharmacists aides
social workers just to name a few
for example
a woman with an appointment to see a
provider about birth control may not
even be able to see her doctor if the
receptionist refuses to process her
paperwork based on a moral objection
perhaps because she's unmarried
a cashier can refuse to sell condoms
a pharmacist can refuse to fill a
woman's prescription for birth control
regardless of whether it is prescribed
for contraception or for other medical
reasons
especially for those in small towns or
rural areas in new hampshire this bill
could
mean that they cannot get the timely
care that they need this could cause
long-term irreversible harm to those
seeking care
there's a there's an important
distinction between religious
accommodations that do not harm third
parties and those that do harm third
parties in the case of this bill we are
not talking about an accommodation that
will merely allow a provider to meet his
or her religious needs
an accommodation for example might be to
make exceptions to a wardrobe policy
that's not what we're talking about
in this case the bill directly imposes
hardship on a single group of people to
allow for providers to make moral
judgments about the health care needs of
women
under this bill there's no obligation
for a refusing provider to find someone
to deliver care to a woman even in a
life-threatening emergency worth seconds
count this bill does not include any
protections for patients even if
someone's life or health is at risk or
someone is the victim of sexual assault
this body is not unfamiliar with this
bill it was voted down 2018 in a two to
one
margin
and so just want to close with one thing
if the legislature enables providers to
refuse to participate in the delivery of
reproductive health care like
contraception and abortion based on
their personal beliefs then what other
essential health care will providers
refuse to deliver we urge you to vote in
expedience legislate
thank you thank you montgomery did you
have any comments to add
thank you for your cooperation
i recognize
representative weber for a question
thank you so much if we enact this
statute protecting the rights of
conscience on
of of those who object to the provision
of these services
should we not repeal the burdens on the
rights of conscience of those who choose
would choose absent our most recent
statute
to provide reproductive care
to those who need it but they are
forbidden to do so by our current
statutes
i'm not fully understanding that
question but i think that if this uh if
this was enacted we would have to look
at
a whole lot of statues because this has
very broad implications on what it would
do
could i could i just clarify the
question a follow-up representative
weather should we not afford equal
rights of conscience
not only to those who object to these
procedures but also to those who believe
as a matter of conscience
that the services
should be provided and should be
provided without the limitations in the
current statutes yes
there needs to be a balancing and part
of the issue with this bill is there is
no balancing here for patients there's
no protections for patients
and there's not even any referrals in
this so if someone came in and they
the provider that they were seeing
didn't believe in birth control they
wouldn't the patient wouldn't be able to
be referred to some place that did
provide birth control so there's no
there's no patient protections here in
this bill
representative merchant thank you mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question
i think we're referring to the broad
scope what is considered a health care
provider
it's on page 2 lines 11-16
and the way it is written is very very
broad to your point
i do also wanted to follow up with sense
with representative weber
is trying to balance things but until we
get to the point of trying to balance
things
we're dealing with this bill here before
us so
would you be looking to try to narrow
that scope of who's considered a health
care provider to really the person
providing that direct service to the
patient versus all the other people
within the facility
so i don't think that we're in the
business of sort of rewriting this bill
when i look at what's in front of us
we know that this has broad implications
and that
we don't think that this bill as is will
work in new hampshire if you all feel
that this bill you know if there could
be rewrites but when we look at what's
written
the implications are
drastic and they have broad implications
on patients being able to receive
quality care and frankly care that is
ethical as well
thank you very much any further
questions
thank you very much
ladies appreciate your attendance here
thank you
dr
recognize
uh jason hennessy
representing the new hampshire right to
life
and the gentleman is in support of the
bill
i know you requested eight minutes but
we gotta go fractionalization so can you
do it in two well we like to aim high
right all right two and a half
thank you mr chair and your cooperation
would be sincerely appreciated i i will
abridge uh my name is jason hennessey
thank you for for hearing me out i am
the president of new hampshire right to
life new hampshire's largest pro-life
organization with uh with thousands of
members and i'm here on behalf of them
to speak in support of hb 1080.
many of you have heard about
the uh
the the uyghur problem in in china like
for instance being forced to eat pork
against their muslim religion and i
would argue today that uh that without a
healthcare
provider right of conscience it's very
very similar
so um
so hb 1080 basically allows us to uphold
the
rights of conscience which are enshrined
in our constitution for healthcare
professionals
according to a research letter published
in the journal of the american uh
medical association in 2019 46 states
have laws explicitly protecting the
right of health care providers to refuse
to participate in abortion
of those
of those four remaining one state
exempts any procedure contrary to
somebody's conscience so that leaves
only three states us vermont and
colorado
and so the question becomes well do we
actually need a law to protect this is
this a problem
well
federal law you know some people say
federal law protects the rights of
conscience too
so right next door in vermont in 2019
the university of vermont medical center
was issued a notice of violation by the
federal hhs's office of civil rights
which which was followed up by a civil
suit with the department of justice
which i was originally going to read
verbatim but i'm going to summarize for
the sake of time
hhs reported that a nurse complained
was
so
uvmc forced the nurse to assist in an
abortion against her religious or moral
objections the nurse had expressed an
objection for many years and was
included in a list of objectors but they
knowingly assigned her to an abortion
procedure
um when the doc when the doctor
knowing about the nurse's uh religious
beliefs
had her had her in the room he said
don't hate me
the nurse again objected another staff
were present who could have taken it
taking it on but she was required to
assist
she reasonably failed fear that they
would fire her or report her to the
licensing authorities if she didn't help
another article reports that the nurse
has been traumatized ever since
and also that she she left that hospital
eventually
the investigation also uncovered that
many uh several other people
who had similar concerns and that their
act their staffing policy actually
uh materially violated the church
amendments
so if i can just throw in one little
thing of that story i had a lot more but
that's all i want to throw in
um
so the the reason that the federal law
doesn't doesn't protect us here in new
hampshire after the turnover in
administration administrations in august
of 2021 it was reported that hhs and doj
drop those suits
so there's no longer
any enforcement going on and this is
what happens when you don't have state
level protections
okay let's hold right there because we
have questions for you representative
shapiro thank you mr chairman i'm still
struggling with the comparison to um
uyghurs being forced to eat pork
i'm assuming that they're not offered to
go to another restaurant where they
don't have to eat pork but wouldn't
health care providers be able to take a
job someplace else that was
better suited to their ethical concerns
well so so thank you for the question
representative so so what one comment
i'll make is that
uh
for instance dartmouth is the largest
health
provider in new hampshire and if you're
in certain parts of the states you can't
go anywhere else
and if you take a look at their
their residency obgyn they say
write on their faq on their website
quote residents who do not provide
abortions themselves are still expected
to counsel patients make appropriate
referrals and manage post-abortile
complications so if you're a resident it
is very difficult to switch programs
if you're a physician in a rural place
it's very you may not be able to go
somewhere else
any further questions
for mr hennessey
thank you very much sir
did you have any any handouts you had
i'll be emailing it to the committee
okay thank you very much thank you i'd
like to recognize uh ms shannon mcginley
with cornerstone action
okay
we'll put that there thank you ms
mcginley uh next we have is ms susan
clifton
who is she still in the room
oh there you are thank you madam
she's in support of the bill and she
graciously offered two minutes so we
thank you very much
you have the floor thank you
thank you mr chairman and members of the
health house health human services and
elderly affairs committee
my name is susan clifton i'm a resident
of sandown i'm a retired registered
nurse who worked in maternal child
health for in an acute care hospital for
about 30 years
my family is one of many health
professionals
nurses a doctor pa
and other health care professionals
many of them work in the health care
system in new hampshire
i was shocked and dismayed to read that
new hampshire is only one of three
states
without right of conscience protection
how can that be
never thankfully in my nursing career
was i ever put in a position where i
would be forced
into doing something that went against
my conscience
a conscience formed by my amazing
catholic faith
which has always and unequivocally
taught about and upheld
the dignity and sacredness of human life
never would i have imagined that i or
one of my children
would possibly be coerced into becoming
an accomplice
in the direct killing of an unborn child
this would be unconscionable
we are endowed by our creator
freedom of conscience would fall under
in the pursuit of happiness and life
i said that wrong in the wrong order
sorry
how do we achieve happiness by choosing
to do what is good
and avoiding evil
simple truths
to force anyone to go against what they
know to be objectively true
and just that is
that all human life is sacred
and then to deny our very freedom of
conscience
formed and guided by our faith no
this freedom is what our country was
founded upon
we are in a world that has largely
abandoned god and instead increasingly
relies upon the whims of man
these are dark times
of great evil much of it disguised as
good
i ask that we together make new
hampshire stronger
by helping to return
to those principles that made our state
and country strong in the first place
would you take some questions ms madam
thank you sir would there be any
questions
no questions here we'll have to thank
you very much
for your testimony
i'd like to recognize
ms kathleen yanian
representing herself
she asked for two minutes and she's in
support of the bill
good afternoon and thank you
representatives and the chairman
my name is kathleen yani and i'm a
resident of chester and a retired
registered nurse having practiced for 34
years
i have worked in acute long-term care
kidney dialysis
and as a union president of the title 38
employees for five years at the va
medical center in manchester new
hampshire
i am in full support of house bill 1080
protecting the medical professionals
against prosecution for acting according
to their ethical religious and moral
convictions
the term patient advocate is a highly
respected and valuable role within the
health care field
i have witnessed and assisted staff in
my union role as they spoke up and acted
in the best interest of their patients
i don't believe there is one health care
professional who hasn't
section 4 under this bill precisely and
accurately describes adverse actions
suffered
when a provider goes against the tide
these are real and happen for lesser
actions
healthcare professionals are good people
a safety net
in the system
you want them to care for you
many will leave or be fired if
unprotected
let's consider for a moment euthanasia
in place of abortion
would it be acceptable to order health
care professionals to participate
or provide this to patients
why not
the care of the disabled is commonly
described as expensive and burdensome
does this sound familiar
in regards to abortion
we need medical professionals who value
the most vulnerable of our society
the baby in the womb the disabled the
elderly
i urge you to consider this tidal wave
described often as the culture of death
and please protect those who may be
caring for you and me
thank you
thank you would there be any questions
for ms yanian
no thank you very much madam
now you recognize next reverend david
grisham
jones
representing himself and he uh comes to
us in opposition to the bill
thank you mr chairman it's a privilege
but i turn it on
how's that
uh i serve as pastor to the community
church of durham a dynamic christian
congregation here in new hampshire and
of course i want to speak against this
bill
in my tradition and in my faith
religious freedom is always and
necessarily coupled with moral
responsibility indeed this is what we
mean when we say that every one of us is
created in the image of god
we are given life and breath to freely
love god and to freely love one another
and this very freedom endows us with the
energy and spirit needed to sustain
communities of compassion institutions
committed to wellness and relationships
that protect integrity
and choice
what religious freedom does not do not
in any religion that i know
is grant us license to deny much needed
health care to those who need it or sow
the seeds of distrust and contempt or to
stigmatize the legitimate choices of
women seeking to do what's best for
their own bodies and i'm concerned that
this is precisely what hb 1080 and
legislation like it is doing
here in new hampshire we are responsible
all of us together for building
institutions that promote the health and
honor the integrity of all our neighbors
all our friends all our sisters and all
our brothers that's our human
responsibility our moral and spiritual
responsibility and to shirk that
responsibility is to compromise our
religious freedom hb 1080 would deny
patients in our state particularly in
rural or underserved areas essential
health care and timely prescriptions in
the world this bill creates a refusing
provider is under no obligation to find
someone else to deliver quality care to
a woman in need leaving that same woman
especially in a life-threatening
emergency without any access to
critically needed medical care this kind
of world not only perverts the notion of
religious freedom it endangers the real
lives the sacred lives of our sisters
mothers grandmothers and friends it's
not a world i would want for my
parishioners in durham or for my wife or
for my three daughters or whatever
grandchildren are coming our way
in my tradition which is indeed the
biblical tradition of judaism and
christianity freedom is gifted to human
beings and human communities so that we
might freely and joyfully care for one
another and create networks of
protection and healing and even
celebration when we use that same notion
of freedom to marginalize the poor among
us or to stigmatize women seeking the
best for themselves or their families we
have wandered off the map of justice and
righteousness i'm against this bill
would there be any questions
see none thank you very much sir for
your contribution
i'd like to recognize frank nack
i hope i pronounced that right sir
representing the aclu of new hampshire
they oppose the bill and you have
written testimony which you'll pass out
right now
and
you have two minutes
once you sit down
he could
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee thank you so much for the
opportunity to testify today uh my name
is frank knack i'm the policy director
with the aclu of new hampshire
you all have my testimony now so i will
not read it much of what we uh we have
in the content there has already been
discussed i think i'll just focus on one
aspect that i think was raised by a
legislator earlier which is the need to
balance
and the fact that we we have a proper
balance in new hampshire right now we
both i think as was mentioned we have
federal law that ensures that people can
exercise their religious freedom
unless it causes an undue burden on
their employer we also in the new
hampshire law against discrimination
have a similar protection in existing
law and i'd also like to point you to
footnotes two through five in in my
testimony
which has the explicit language of the
various um professional health
organizations the american medical
association american college of
physicians american nurses association
the american academy of physician
associates
and i think it's important to look how
they wrote their their ethical standards
versus what this bill would do and i
think the main difference is that there
is no exception in this bill
there is zero opportunity so if a
patient comes in i think as was alluded
to earlier
where they have to have an abortion to
save the the patient's life and they're
in a small rural place where they can't
find someone else that doctor could
refuse or a nurse or someone else on the
medical staff could refuse the care
um and there is nothing under this law
that that profession would actually be
protected under this law and so i think
the blanket uh
zero exception language in this bill is
extremely concerning and so i would hope
that this legislature
you know legislators here in this
committee
will oppose this bill it is dangerous
and it is in fact the healthcare denial
act so thank you
thank you mr kanek is there any
questions for the gentleman
no well none none being seen thank you
very much sir thank you all
like to recognize ms emily baker
she's in opposition to the bill
and you have two minutes miss baker i'm
actually emily baker i'm a physician i
didn't put that on there because it
didn't say pardon me
doctor no you weren't dr baker excuse me
that's fine
so my name is emily baker i'm a optician
gynecologist i've worked at dartmouth
for almost 30 years i do something
called maternal fetal medicine had the
great pleasure of helping women navigate
very difficult circumstances
i'm i understand the
other new hampshire medical society
individual couldn't come testify so i'm
representing them in his stead
i also may
participate in resident education at our
program so this is the background with
which i come
i'm in opposition to the bill
it
ultimately targets a major segment of
our population reproductive aged women
in a way that would limit their health
care opportunities to plan their
pregnancies
to space them
to avoid the medical risks associated
with pregnancy
and
it's especially true of which is a broad
bill which involves pharmacists and
providers where you end up in a
situation where you could actually have
difficulty getting medicine for
reproductive infertility treatments
rei procedures and health care for
contraception which is
women's health care and it's the one
thing we know that prevents abortion is
really excellent contraceptive care
that's the only thing that does it i
would like
if i may since the question got up about
training
at our program as many programs in the
country
no one is expected
to participate in a termination of
pregnancy period
not expected it doesn't happen they do
need to know how to manage complications
and i will submit this is an example for
problems for our state
of someone has a termination of
pregnancy they come to their rural
hospital
and they're septic
they have an infection
and they're going to die if they don't
get treatment and we have somebody says
i don't participate in termination and
helping you because you did it is
something i won't do
so
let's hope that doesn't happen but
that's a consequence that one could see
will you take some a question of course
thank you representative merchant thank
you mr chair and thank you dr baker for
taking my question
i'm looking at the page 2 under line 16.
i want to be clear
why i'm asking you as a physician
whereas his sterilization that would
also include a vasectomy for a male
correct
yep
true i guess i'm so focused on women all
the time i forget that other half of the
population
my bad so that answer was in the
affirmative
that i don't take care of manners
i'm just looking for equal access to
health care exactly no that's my point
okay i hear you another thing if i have
one second is that yeah
that
in in addition to our trainees not being
expected to do abortions
it's already the circumstance
where
no one in the
in the
places where abortions are done have any
expectation in providing we're very
careful the places that do it i say we
just because it's the big state because
we're
i have great sensitivity people's
beliefs
don't want to harm anybody that way
especially in this climate
no one
would want to put anybody in that
circumstance where they felt like they
had to participate in something that was
against their place for abortion in
particular thank you very much
representative gay
thank you mr chair and thank you very
much for taking my question i should
have asked this earlier
what does it mean to you
artificial contraception
i actually don't know
i mean they could be
referring to
methods of contraception that
imply that the pregnancy can't implant
or it's an abortifacient
that's
potentially what the intent is
okay
thank you i'm just speculating
me too
any further questions
done being seen i thank you very much
madam thank you appreciate your
contribution i'd like to uh now
recognize
representative max abramson
i don't know if he's back yet he had
testimony on another committee
but i don't believe don't believe he's
here uh that was our last um
submittal
so we have uh we're all we've completed
those who are requested to testify
anyone else would like to make a comment
in
right here okay then we will call this
hearing on house bill 1080 to a close
and we thank you very much and
we'll
take about two minutes for the chair to
return to his position
unless
he wants me to remain but
that's right
so come on back and house bill 1077 will
be starting very shortly
could everybody take your seats please
are on what the heck are we doing 1077.
open house
bill 1077's
hearing
repealing the prohibition on conversion
therapy for minors the chair recognizes
the honorable david testerman to present
your bill
thank you mr chairman uh
uh dave testerman i'm a representative
of the town or the city of franklin in
the town of hill
in
merrimack county
uh today
i have a relatively simple
bill
when you have bad law
you need to get rid of it
and this
this particular law
is bad
it was passed a few years ago really
with some
some lies about what it does
and what what kind of
therapy is given to to children
it is
it talks about you can't talk you can't
talk to children about
sex
is what it really boils down to
and you can't go to your pastor and say
can we do it
now i've got a a friend
who is a is a pastor and i said how do
you get around this bill
well i can't except
we can have religious discussions
so it can be
circumvented but that's not the reason
we need to get rid of it
so
i'm a simple person i've got i'm an
engineer i'm a pilot i i i i don't wax
eloquently
like the the chairman did up here
uh
so
this is one that i think we
we have to pass
otp
thank you
representative testament um i remember
those discussions they were held in this
committee
and
what's
is it your understanding of the
law now
that if a
[Music]
sixteen-year-old
wants to go to a licensed counselor in
the state and say
i'm conflicted i want to talk it out in
terms of my
relationships or attractions
even that is forbidden yes
so it's not
a matter of
parents dropping off their 14 year old
and the therapist throws the kid in the
closet and locks the door and yells and
screams
if that's what it is i would oppose it
but
that doesn't happen
and i'm you know i'm disappointed that
there were certain members
of the house who
raised those kinds of issues
any other questions for the
representative presenting the bill
representative gay
what procedures are used for conversion
therapy
as i understand it
it's a matter of
therapists would talk to them
you know about their fears
you know what they think
and so on
it wouldn't be taking a cattle prod to
them it wouldn't be locking them in a
closet
it wouldn't be any of those kinds of
things that a lot of people
have tried to have a scare tactic
in place
any further questions for the
representative
saying none thank you representative
testerman thank you
the chair recognizes i know she's uh
she's got to be in a couple of places
this afternoon is holly stevens here
presently yeah
from nami in new hampshire
congratulations on that appointment
sisters
thank you chairman pearson and members
of the committee
although your name does say
representative mcmahon in front of you
would you believe i've had a conversion
for the record my name is holly stevens
i am the
director of public policy at nami new
hampshire
nami new hampshire is a non-profit
grassroots organization whose mission is
to improve the lives of all people
impacted by mental illness and suicide
through support education and advocacy
on behalf of nami new hampshire i'm here
today to speak in opposition to house
bill 1077 repealing the prohibition on
conversion therapy for minors
you know one of the things that we're
taught is that providers should do no
harm in their treatment of patients
and conversion therapy does have the
potential to do harm
and it can cause shame and trauma which
can have lifelong effects
it also does have the potential of being
life-threatening
suicide is the second leading cause of
death for individuals who are age 10 to
24 years in the state of new hampshire
it's also as well as nationwide as well
lgbtq
youth represent a significant high risk
there's a subgroup within that cohort
and they're at a significantly higher
risk with a rate of suicide attempts
that is four times greater
than for
for the lgbtq group and for
youth that are questioning
it's two times greater um than their
straight peers
also the suicide attempts by this uh
particular subgroup of youth the lgbtq
group
um are four to six times more likely to
result in injury
poisoning
or an overdose that results in medical
treatment
and again that's four to six
times
more likely than their straight peers
and more related i know we're here to
talk about conversion therapy
not just suicide rates
but specifically related to this bill
and the potential for harm of conversion
therapy
lgbt youth who come from
highly rejecting families
are 8.4 times more likely to have
attempted suicide
than
lgbt peers who reported either no levels
or low levels of family rejection
the practice of conversion therapy in
any form
is a danger to the mental health and
well-being
of youth and young adults so nami new
hampshire urges that the committee votes
inexpedient to legislate on house bill
and i will take any questions that you
may have any questions representative
soloway
thank you mr chairman
welcome back director stevens i i like
your new title
can you parse for us
a difference between
counseling and conversion therapy
it's my understanding
that
conversion therapy
would be done
when the youth
is not interested
in exploring
where they're at
where counseling
regular counseling if if a youth was
questioning which is one of the groups
that i talked about
and they go and explore that with a
therapist that is not conversion therapy
that is just therapy
conversion therapy is when the youth
goes in for treatment and
their um
i mean the whole program i mean the
term conversion means to convert
um so you're trying to convert somebody
from one thing to another um
mr chairman just a quick follow-up just
a quick one uh uh director stevens just
a quick question do you think it's
possible in the context of legislation
to actually parse the difference between
counseling and conversion therapy so
that we have clear
boundaries between those two
i don't know that's why you get paid the
big bucks representatives all away
who told representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you
director stevens for taking the question
i'm pulling at the same thread i'm not
sure if you've heard the terms directive
counseling and non-directive counseling
the directive is when you're trying to
achieve a certain goal and the
non-directive is exploring along with
the patient and i'm curious if
having a ban on directive counseling in
terms of
gender would make and sexual identity
would make more sense so that any of
these
non-directive counseling sessions where
they are working with the child and
exploring with them would be clearly
allowed in the law while prohibiting
those where you're trying to direct them
to any predetermined outcome i am
sincerely hoping that there are some
counselors behind me that might be able
to answer that question for you because
i don't have the expertise
to answer that
thank you representative mckay
thank you mr chairman and thank you and
congratulations
um the title of this is
conversion therapy
my understanding is that therapy is for
illnesses
and that
the
illness of
gay lesbian bisexual
implies that that's an illness but do
you have an opinion on that
that question
i don't have an opinion on that i have
been out of the mental health field for
a number of years and i would have to
my understanding and i think you
probably know better than i would mr uh
representative mckay is that that was
removed from the dsm
some number of years ago so
[Music]
follow up follow up
you're absolutely right the
diagnostic statistical manual
is the
[Music]
the
group
that is used by all professionals
and there is no
description in there of an illness for
any of those
categories and i i sometimes get them
backwards but it's lgbt
transgender
questioning and all of those different
groups
i don't consider any of those
as illnesses
but that
my opinion is not particularly
significant when the dsm is utilized by
all professionals
and
so that i
i think you agree
that there is no description of an
illness for any of those categories
wouldn't you
i made it a question
i again i will i i will leave that to
some other folks because i did was down
in the uh another hearing where they
talked about
gender dysphoria as being an actually
recognized
medical condition so i don't want to
opine on that given the fact that we did
add transgender into that
the chair has a question for you
um we spoke about the suicide
of those
with us with a self-identity in a
hostile family
i am aware
in two cases
of individuals
but also in of literature
of those who are very much questioning
and certainly want to go in a direction
and while they do not want to be forced
in it they may want to be walked towards
it
that is their goal in counseling and
with gentle therapists
and having been denied the availability
of that because some counselors are
scared to go into an area they think
they can't go into anymore those people
kill themselves
so that suicide
is not
just
um
l b
letters
in hostile homes it is in people who
really want something different than
what they're experiencing and would like
something lovingly to walk with them and
absent that their suicide's there too
are you aware of those numbers
i don't know are you asking me
specifically for numbers of questions oh
just you do have an awareness of that
category of suicidals
questioning youth are four to six more
times likely to well that quite
questioning youth and
youth who are have identified
as lgbtq have higher rates of suicide
down the line i'm breaking out the
questioning youth into two categories
one of which is they're questioning that
they don't like what they're
experiencing and while they certainly
don't want to be abused in counseling
they want a counselor who understands
and accepts them for where they are that
is to say they don't really want to be
what they're feeling at present and
could somebody work them through what
others have called a developmental stage
and absent that friendly counselor there
have been suicides
would i be able to do some uh research
and look into that for you
representative pearson i don't know that
off the top of my head okay neither do i
i know of it and i would be most
appreciative thank you representative
shapiro
yes thank you mr chairman
would you believe that the statute
that's in place which bans conversion
therapy
actually does quite a good job at
parsing the difference between
counseling
questioning youth
and
banning conversion therapy
the wording is that conversion therapy
this says what conversion therapy is not
conversion therapy shall not include
counseling that provides
acceptance support understanding and
identity exploration and development
including sexual orientation in other
words
that's not that's not considered um
conversion therapy that is allowed that
is what i think people are referring to
so would you believe that this law as it
stands
does quite a good job at allowing people
to continue to work with people who are
questioning their
gender identity or sexual
orientation
as is
from taken from somebody who's worked
with adolescents most of my life
most of who have questioned their
sexuality
i would believe
that i'll just leave it at that
representative folsom
thank you um
chairman and thank you for taking my
question
um i have um
great sympathy for people who
have written
and gone through and produced a bill
that other people then were confused by
and people thought
that they were
being
not allowed a service because of a
confusion and thought in the bill
and what i see happening is the same
thing
in the conversion
therapy language
there is enough ambiguity
that many many counselors
are concerned
about the fact that they don't dare talk
to them and i've gotten lots of emails
from counselors specifically stating
that that they stay away from this issue
they don't counsel kids or young adults
or adults
even with this issue they just can't
take them as patients because they don't
know when they're breaking the law
and so
if if you know if people vote not to
repeal this
i really hope somebody comes along and
helps clarify
this a whole lot better so that
people the these counselors that are out
there that could be doing this
counseling
would then know where the boundaries are
and be able to
um
add to the mental health
professionals available to these people
that are are questioning do you think
that that is a way to possibly solve
this problem
i don't know um i wasn't prepared for a
lot of the uh
what what i
i'm meaning notice respect seems like a
little bit of a discussion
around exec session type
ideas so
those i'm not prepared to respond to if
that's okay
follow up
i i don't you know i don't want you to
ever feel pressured in your seat but we
are here trying to draw as much
information as we can out so that we can
make good policy we're not
in any way trying to give you a hard
time
it's our way of saying
give us more information i i think
though the people that should give you
that information
are counselors who are struggling with
this
i don't know if there's any behind me or
not
but they might be able to guide you as
to what language they would be
comfortable with if it was in the law to
do that type of counseling i can't speak
for them
having had a relatively unpleasant
experience recently in that very seat
um
you can
go if you want to
well one what after one person
representative cannon
thank you mr chair
thank you for taking my question
would you believe
[Laughter]
um
would you believe that conversion
therapy is more of a coercive therapy
rather than traditional therapy
i would believe that
thank you
and thank you so much
well we're going to let her off the hook
because
we have people she's deferring to others
graciously
okay
um
chair recognizes dr glenn jameson from
east kingston
thank you mr chairman and members of the
health and human services
elderly committee
my name is glenn jameson
i use the initial w for my first name
wallace
reside in east kingston new hampshire
i'm a registered physician in new
hampshire
and a board certified psychiatrist with
45 years experience
thanks for your time and willingness to
listen
um i'm here to ask you to vote to
support
house bill 1077
which would repeal the prohibition on
so-called conversion therapy for minors
overturning statute 3 to 32 l
i do not testify in support of
conversion therapy as a matter of fact
i'd like to know where you find it
it's not happening
anywhere around here
what i'm testifying
to
is
opposition to any kind of prohibition
like this law
which tacitly promotes state intrusion
and control in the psychotherapy process
to me that violates the sanctity and
fiduciary nature
of psychotherapy
any sort of enforcement would require
state authority to insinuate itself into
the therapy space
and that's the sensitive area where
clients are most vulnerable
clients are encouraged to speak their
minds without fear of censorship or
coercion or retaliation
they're prompted not to edit material
but to simply report what comes to their
mind
now that liberating
practice is sharply constricted
by title 332l
and here's why
representative testerman described
title 332l is a bad bill
and i'm here to tell you why it is
on the surface it appeared to be an
effort in harm reduction but that's
clearly not what it is it was not a
response to any known or identified
problem
at the time of passage no one on the
committee could identify a single
therapist in new hampshire who was doing
conversion therapy
subsequently there has not been a single
reported violation
what was the call for it
the driving force could not have been
clinical i'll leave it to your surmise
as to what the driving force was
also
i don't think that the job did that good
that the bill did that good a job
of uh parsing
um
so as to avoid ambiguity
the premise of the conversion therapy
law makes no sense at all
and that is that the therapist decides
the goals
and seeks to change that's the word
aspects of the individual but the
therapist doesn't bring therapeutic
goals into their therapy
those come from the client
to learn about the client's goals which
are the only goals that count
some inquiry is obviously involved
but this law endangers that very process
of inquiry which is now perilous for the
therapist
simple questions may appear
tendentious
or an effort to change someone's
sexuality
adolescents and youth are notoriously
uncertain
about gender issues and these cannot be
separated from other issues
during an interview
who decides if the line is crossed
who will monitor or assess this
the statute
332l
generously allows for what it calls
quote sexual orientation neutral
interventions
whatever that means who's to say
injecting government agencies to monitor
would not work
the state should not be dictating
therapy goals or even assessing them
the law of unintended consequences
applies here
what has been the actual effect of title
332 is ironic
those whom it presumed to help
have been harmed
a new barrier was created
which made therapy less available to
adolescents and young adults
the law
has had a chilling effect
and here are the real life consequences
adolescents can't find treatment
therapists steer clear of anything
remotely touching on gender
and no one will risk seeing this
population
thus many adolescents and young adults
can find no help in new hampshire and
may need referral out of state
and that is not for gender issues that's
for all
issues i challenge anyone to find
psychological help for some anxious
adolescent who's caught up in a highly
charged struggle over gender issues
which may in fact be a struggle between
the school and the parents
it's public knowledge that schools can
be heavy-handed in applying their
policies
someone needs to be a voice for the
anxious adolescents out there in need of
therapy they can't come forward
themselves to report this problem how
would they approach the legislature to
complain that they can't find a
therapist anywhere
lastly statute 332l has no enforcement
mechanism no sanctions for violations it
simply refers any presumed violator to
the quote
relevant licensing authority for quote
such discipline
as the relevant licensing authority
deems appropriate
if a client made a complaint
that wouldn't go to a court for a fair
hearing but to the quote relevant
licensing authority
this strikes fear into the heart of any
therapist all therapists have had
experience with hostile
or aggrieved clients who wish them harm
and who wouldn't mind reporting them to
their licensing board
and professionals of all kinds are
surely daunted by their own particular
licensing boards which sometimes
function like the proverbial man with a
hammer in his hand
so every therapist's own license is at
stake
in some
psychotherapy
must be safe
it must be a safe experience for both
client and therapist those who seek it
are the most vulnerable and they're at
their most vulnerable please vote in
favor of bill h.r
thank you thank you dr jamison will you
take questions yes i will
representative merchant
thank you mr chairman and also thank you
dr patek my question
um what i'm hearing from your testimony
of the written testimony i've looked at
there seems to be a
level of confusion the way the law is
written
and it sounds like that seems to be the
essence of it and i think what i
have seen so far is
a lot of times the expertise that you
need to write the rules right down to
that level our granularity
probably doesn't exist in the
legislative committee
would you be a supportive of trying to
then assign a board with the board of
psychology mental health and so forth to
write the rules to clarify this so
therefore we're not repealing it per se
but allowing an agency to take a deeper
dive into it to provide some guidance
that you folks all need
to buy clarity to it
microphone please
is that working now it is that takes me
back to the earlier point of what
was it a response to is it a response to
any known
problem or identified harm
i'm not sure that there's a need for any
bill addressing issues of conversion
if it's not happening
why
try to describe it in granular detail so
with all due respect i can't see the use
of a committee like that
representative shapiro
yes thank you mr chairman
sorry
i'm not hiding
um
so i i'm afraid i missed your
your initial comments so
are you
a physician who works with teenagers
yes i have worked with teenagers
on and off many years in various
capacities
inpatient outpatient
eating disorder programs
drug and alcohol programs yes
so
so my question is
when this bill
passed and conversion therapy was
outlawed
which is just a few years ago i think
within the last
four years
did did this create a
significant change in the way you
practice did you stop talking to
adolescents
about
their
[Music]
questions about identity their questions
about sexuality
did you
turn kids off when they talk to you try
to talk to you about those things
because you were concerned about the
consequences
of the current statute
well sir uh in that period of time
since i moved to new hampshire five
years ago
um i have done exclusively inpatient
psychotherapy inpatient work
in hospitals
um so many of the questions surrounding
conversion therapy don't apply
but some of them do
and i would have to say
that i myself have been very much more
careful
about these subjects
avoiding them whenever possible
and
when i listen
to a client who is distressed about some
gender issue
i feel very brave
because i realize that uh
that might be forbidden territory and
it's hard to tell where the line is
drawn
follow-up
yes
would you believe that
having practiced with adolescents for a
very long time that
and knowing a lot of other people who do
that
i don't know of anybody who has
been more concerned or afraid of talking
about these issues in fact if anything
my sense is that there are more and more
therapists
who are
increasingly comfortable talking about
these issues as these issues have become
less stigmatized just my experience
i'm surprised i think
our acquaintances don't overlap greatly
because i know so many who are we should
get to know each other yes
any additional questions for the doctor
representative leon um thank you mr
chairman and thank you doctor for being
here and taking these questions uh
is it um
accepted practice for a therapist to
guide an intended outcome with their
patient
no
so it really is not unless you're in
drug and alcohol therapy
and then of course there's an outcome
that is sought but that's agreed upon in
advance
and follow-up follow-up and would that
then mean that conversion therapy as
it's laid out is already a violation of
the code of ethics and already would be
addressed by the licensing boards
whenever i hear it described
i've never heard you know case studies
of it
yes it does seem to be something that
would be in violation of general
standards of the licensing boards
if it's coercive
if it's not a matter of
client assent or agreement in advance
that would be
an ethical violation
thank you yeah sure
representative gay
thank you mr chair and thank you
it seems pl
i'll make a statement you tell me
whether it's true or false or whether
you agree
it seems to me that the real problem is
when a child or teen comes to you and
says i'm feeling like i'm not the right
i'm not feeling like the sex that
physically i am
and i don't like it
and i want to change i want to be like
what i think everybody else is at that
point
the child or the team
is directing
to change how they feel
that seems to me
where the danger is because if you help
them
try to change
then it sounds like you're being
coercive
so is that the real scary issue for a
psychologist
well whatever you do in that situation
you are at risk of being
seen as
introducing change or promoting change
you know that's
really your idea rather than the clients
so
it's not so much an issue of what
the adolescent
asks you to do
it's the whole territory if it
leads to some sort of change
you're at risk
representative cannon
thank you
madam chair
thank you for taking my question um
would you
would you consider it inappropriate
for a parent to bring their child in to
see a therapist where the parent is
telling the therapist what they expect
the outcome to be
well i would consider it inappropriate
for the therapist to take marching
orders from the parent
i think the therapist would need to sit
down with the family and figure out what
was going on underneath
i don't think it's inappropriate for the
parent to
to you know see a therapist or
request an audience with a therapist but
for the therapist to say well yes i'll
change your child for you that would be
terribly inappropriate
follow on follow
up
um
would you would you believe that
originally when this bill was brought
forward a few years ago that part of the
concern in the
transgender community especially was
that
many um there were many situations
throughout the country that were
parents working with
quote unquote therapists were trying to
change the
what the child was thinking
and that and that this bill originally
with good intentions was to try and
uh circumvent that before it started in
this state
so would you
um
would you consider if this group were to
bring forth an amendment at least
reading it through before we decide to
do anything
consider
consider reviewing an amendment to this
bill that's being brought forward to
help clarify
the difference between coercion and
regular therapy
i certainly wouldn't rule out
reviewing an amendment yeah thank you
sure
representative folsom
thank you madam chair
thank you for taking my question
do you think that there is a chance
of a poor outcome
if because of the fear of therapists who
are licensed and trained
to work with these young people who are
desperately seeking for help
do you fear that they may then end up
going to people who are not trained and
getting their information
willy-nilly from
whoever thinks that they know better
i think that's a legitimate concern
i can't say that
i have experience of that
but sounds legitimate
representatives now
see now that's a simple answer
anyway thank you very much mister
sure i think there is a distinction to
be made that couldn't be answered before
there are having
worked in community mental health for
48 50 years actually
saw a number of children who have been
in that sort of situation
there is a distinction to be made
between
gender dysphoria which is really
kids feeling very confused and upset
during an age period where they're
trying to settle
sexual identity anyway and they can
become very confused and that leads to
being upset and i think a therapist
who then tries to help them with a
feeling of upset
not the gender issues that
may have some played some role in
fostering it comes along but the thing
that disturbs me and i heard reports of
this both from national organizations
and from people that i'd seen
i talked with a couple of kids who had
collision therapy
and the
procedures that they went through with
barbaric to say the least in many
situations and it was very very damaging
to them
and
i i don't have any identity of any
particular people that did it
often at times but
some of them may not have even occurred
around here because i really wasn't
interested in looking for the exact
villains that did this but it really is
a very coercive treatment but i think we
need to make a distinction that
we need to do away with these forced
coercive methods
to change someone's sexual identity
often it's someone else's request
either a parent or a school or somebody
says i don't want you to be a gay person
i want you to come back to being a
regular
bisexual person but those are
wrong and there's absolutely no evidence
anywhere there's any treatment method
that's going to accomplish that sure but
i know of
but the distinction really is and i
think you've already said that if a kid
is very confused about where he's at at
any given point that is something that
you can quite successfully work at and
try to help him deal with
would you say let me just make a blanket
statement that any
therapy that is coercive
is unethical
thank you
any other questions for the doctor
representative soloway
thank you mr chairman
dr jameson if you could put yourself in
the mind of
um an honor student at harvard medical
school in the mid 70s
perhaps someone working with the like of
arthur kleinman even
would you say that we have made
remarkable progress
in our treatment of adolescents
in areas of gender
and maybe we should just let the
legislation stand and walk away from it
and stay loose
i i can't find my way to that sir
i really cannot see
that there is tremendous progress
in dealing with adolescent gender issues
which are
epidemiologically
rampant now in comparison with the 70s
one could ask why are there four times
as many
adolescents confused about their gender
and
how does one help them
um
representative weber
thank you and i'm wondering how your
uh position squares with what appears to
me to be the position of the american
psychiatric association
which says among other things that the
apa encourages legislation which would
prohibit the practice of reparative or
conversion therapies
that are based on the a priori
assumption that diverse sexual
orientations and general gender
identities are mentally ill
well that a priori assumption if in fact
they're
basing their position on that
i disagree with that a priori assumption
but i also disagree with the apa's
conclusion there
and i certainly don't
agree with the apa in lockstep i think
that they are quite wrong about that
yes
seeing no further hands up thank you so
much dr jamison we appreciate your
coming i appreciate it
the chair recognizes the honorable ed
butler an alumnus of the house of
representatives
good to see you back representative
from hart's location which i think is
north of my
district a little bit
it is uh it is good to be back here and
thank you uh as you said i'm from hart's
location at butler
and um i'm going to take this down a
little different road
uh
when my now husband les and i were
beginning our life together about 44 ish
years ago
it was time when gay and lesbian couples
didn't often have children
unless they had kids from a previous
marriage we talked about whether we
wanted to bring a son or daughter into
our lives
but it was not a time when acceptance of
same-sex families was as prevalent as it
is today i think we would have been
great parents
but the lack of societal support
deterred us
these days many gay and lesbian couples
do have kids
when
we have friends a young gay couple up in
bretton woods who have built an
impressive hospitality business
they've adopted two kids a few years ago
brother and sister the boy is now eight
and the girl's six
they are a wonderful vibrant and happy
family
gay and lesbian couples with children
understand that their kids need to grow
into their own sexual identity whatever
that is
that is their responsibility as a parent
to nurture and support their child's
growth one aspect of which is a healthy
sexuality and gender identity
whatever that aspect
of which yeah i'm sorry it would be
absurd to consider that children of gay
or lesbian couples should be counseled
against heterosexual yearnings simply
because of the environment they grew up
in was with gay parents
it's the same if you turn the construct
around to the children of heterosexual
couples it would be absurd if their
children who have normal healthy
homosexual yearnings should be sent to a
licensed professional to tell them that
those yearnings are wrong
that they are defective because of those
feelings
all parents want to have their kids to
have safe and secure childhood and to
grow into a happy healthy and successful
life
sending your child into conversion
therapy doesn't support their growth
into a strong and happy adult but rather
reinforces shame and dissonance about
who they are
according to the world psychiatric
association statement denouncing the
harmful and discredited practice of
conversion therapy there is no sound
scientific evidence that innate sexual
orientation can be changed and
the provision of any intervention
support purporting to treat something
that is not a disorder is wholly
unethical
there are already laws preventing other
forms of child endangerment the existing
ban on conversion therapy joins those
laws and makes it clear to parents that
it is dangerous to their child is
discredited by the medical community and
has no legitimate purpose
the ban protects parents from being
taken advantage of by practitioners of
harmful therapy practices
we should not be telling kids who have
same sex attractions or kids who have
questions about their gender expression
that they are wrong to have those
feelings
the damage that conversion therapy can
do has been shown and the professional
counseling therapy communities have
repudiated
the ban on conversion therapy hb 587
which had bipartisan sponsorship
passed in 2018 and was signed by
governor sununu
it says that we value the health and
well-being of the health and well-being
of our children
all of our children
it shouldn't be undone thank you and i'm
happy to take questions
representative um i certainly
stand with i think just about everybody
else who says coercive
counseling is
not good at all
but i do know some people who for
the first 20 years of
their adult life
identified in one way
and
through a process or through
a period of time
then spent the next years of their life
identifying differently
i know those people it wasn't just a
quick thing it wasn't forced nobody had
a gun to his head
but they changed and and this is in both
directions of the subject so
i would
hold out
that
at least as my small apprehension of
truth
that
what do you think of that
we have had this discussion before
and um it is absolutely imperative that
support for people who are exploring
a variety of conflicts in their
growth and development
deserve to have the support
that they need
either through their family through
their churches through their
health care communities however that is
possible
what
conversion therapy does is say
what you are experiencing is wrong
that is bad and i think most everyone
agrees to that that's what this bill is
about it is not about
um
threatening
the therapy community with
helping um
through
the growth and development of teens and
young adults to explore their sexuality
their gender identity and their
conflicts
over
becoming an adult
i was a psychiatric nurse for 15 years
i worked in the health care community
for more years than that
and i was a
struggling young adult for
several years
and
had incredibly positive experiences with
therapy helping me to understand
the ground that i was standing on the
relationships that i was exploring and
the conflicts with family and community
that kind of therapy is incredibly
important which which is which i
understand but it really wasn't my
question i know but it is part of the
process and it is i think the basis of
what we're hearing
remember that time we debated on channel
nine you won and i said
you can outclass me in a debate all
right
thank you thank you
representative gay
thank you mr chairman and thank you very
much for coming and
i have again i have a question
that am i understanding you right that
the most important aspect of counseling
for a kid who either
feels strongly
and and says it's not standard so it's
kind of concerning me or is really
questioning doesn't know where they
stand and are feeling really lost
would you say that the most important
part of counseling is acceptance
and helping them deal with people who
aren't accepting
absolutely um
you know for all of us
trying to find acceptance is always a
challenge um
but when we are entering
an area that is
psychologically fraught
because of
the history of acceptance of say lgbt
experiences it becomes more difficult
and especially when you come from a
family that may not support or
believe that what you are experiencing
is good or healthy and may be damaging
and your family cares
desperately about you and doesn't want
you to go there
the the
best
treatment is acceptance and support and
allowing someone to grow through that
experience
seeing no further questions thank you
thank you
next we call up taylor largman from unh
law
good afternoon
my name is taylor largeman and i'm the
president of lambda at the university of
new hampshire school of law
lambda formerly opposes hb 1077
because conversion therapy is hateful
it's trans and homophobic
and torturous
in response to um the sponsor's
testimony a few minutes ago this body
would create a slippery slope that
people can understand
if people were to understand liberally
um
the concept behind it so locking like
the locking in the closet um
referred to earlier
is by no means um on par with the
need to
ban conversion therapy
so what is conversion therapy because it
seems that we seem to be talking without
really a solid definition um it's the
pseudo-scientific practice of attempting
to force someone
to change their sexuality and gender
identity to heterosexual and cisgender
through psychiatric physical or
spiritual means
it completely lacks any scientific
credibility
according to the human rights campaign
there's no credible evidence that
conversion therapy can change a person's
sexual orientation
or gender identity or expression
to the contrary and this is still from
the same quote
research has clearly shown that these
practices pose devastating health risks
for lgbtq people
such as depression decreased self-esteem
substance abuse homelessness and even
suicidal behavior which many people
before me have brought up
the harmful practice is condemned by
every major medical and mental health
organization including the american
psychiatric association
american psychological association and
the american medical association so
while you may disagree with one of them
i would find it difficult that you agree
with the entire
industry
as you may know new hampshire is one of
20 states that has banned conversion
therapy for lgbtq minors
new hampshire did so
legislatively
and all the new england states have
banned conversion therapy
as well as all of the northeastern
states except for pennsylvania
so i think it would be a major and gross
misstep to
go against what is a clearly
accepted understanding
here today
um
and i since governor sununu signed the
prohibition on conversion therapy i
guess we wonder why sponsors of the bill
um an abusive bill that is seek to roll
back progress made for the lgbtq
community under the same leadership that
created it
i'm now willing to answer any questions
and speak on behalf
of the lgbtq community as a member of it
and not on behalf of lambda because i
don't want to conflate those conflicts
of interest
so i open up the room to questions
if there are any actually
i'll ask a question as chair sure
i listening to some of the prior
testimony i heard that this is having a
chilling effect on counseling is i'm
curious about whether you believe that
the all of these associations believing
it's unethical already prohibits it
through our existing statutes and
licensing laws and if the harm of
denying access to this to therapy in
general to youth
if that's a risk that we need to
consider as well
sure um by no means am i qualified or
i'd have the expertise but i will say
that um
there they should not be conflated um
conversion therapy with just um
somebody's regular course of therapy
as somebody who underwent
not conversion therapy thankfully but as
somebody in my adult life who has sought
professional license uh
psychite that means
mental health services um
those should be um taken into
consideration but i think what's
fundamentally
important to notice too is the absence
of inclusive lgbtq
sex education in the state of new
hampshire
only nine states
actually include lgbtq
curriculum in sex education so i think
that if we're going to try and offer
therapeutic services to children we
should start when they're young and in
school and it shouldn't be from a
heteronormative
perspective it should be inclusive
so i'm not sure if that fully answers
your question but it does based on the
best of my ability and lack of expertise
that's all we can ever ask for so thank
you thank you
sing oh sorry representative cushman
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question do you know of any
therapists in new hampshire prior to the
implementation of this law
that we're performing the therapy that
we're discussing here conversion therapy
um to my knowledge i don't
but i don't think that that obvious the
need to keep it like prohibited
thank you very much
the chair recognizes dr deborah warner
from littleton new hampshire
and you have
very nice testimony at least lots of
different fonts and pages and all kinds
of stuff
you are a licensed clinical psychologist
yes i am thank you mr chairman and
distinguished committee members i
appreciate being here i'm dr deborah
warner i'm from littleton new hampshire
i have four more decades of
family practice in psychology experience
i've also be speaking on my experiences
on two licensing boards the board of
mental health practice and the board of
psychologists i am not speaking for
those boards i'm going to speak based on
my experience and knowledge that i
gained from those experiences and also i
won't be able to just disclose any
confidential information as you're aware
please look for my handout which i
passed around it is the one with the
green
paper clip
you can read it the
the
headings are informative you can
probably catch the outline that way and
also read deeper if you are looking at
the details
i'd like to call your attention
to
page
two
where i'd like to go over the mechanics
of the law that is going on in the books
by the way as an aside i did stop seeing
anyone under
18 when this did happen uh when this was
enacted
and you'll see why
if we look at the analysis of the
wording of the law
what i did was something in seventh
grade they taught us how to diagram
sentences
this is basically that
i brought the same wording that there is
in the statute and moved it into a
format that we could analyze and see
what's happening
so what we have here is in the first
section
in this chapter conversion therapy means
and that means
these therapies are prohibited
practices or treatments that seek to
change an individual's sexual
orientation or gender identity
including efforts to change
behaviors
gender expressions or to eliminate or
reduce sexual or romantic attractions or
feelings toward individuals of the same
chapter as gender
now all of those things are prohibited
and
unfortunately that kind of talk goes on
a lot with kids
whether or not
they're
looking to change their gender identity
they are developing their gender
identity
naturally and normally they will have a
variety of considerations a variety of
attractions of self um
appreciation and and degradation there's
a mixed bag being an adolescent and in
this room we're all grown up we've
passed by that and it lovely it seals
over and we're not as aware of the
torture that that uh
age group goes through it's difficult
and so we look and see these things are
going to be talked about by any kid
and the conversion therapy stories that
we've heard of
um
that over the several years that this
bill has turned to law and and is now on
the books
these therapies are called conversion
therapies the difficulty with them is
that they are
forcing an agenda on the kids and that's
not at all um
what any therapy is supposed to be ever
anyway no matter what the topic is
so then you have the rest of this
paragraph conversion therapy shall not
include
and that is these
treatment exceptions are allowed
counseling that provides assistance to a
person undergoing gender transition
or counseling to prevent or address
unlawful conduct or unsafe sexual
practices
this might be kids who have been
referred by the court having offended
someone or perhaps dcyf
has made a referral in that regard
gender transition obviously we know what
that is um
those are the only two classes of minors
who can basically freely address their
issues but then we do come to the part
um
of what would it be like to do this such
counseling
uh that provides acceptance support
understanding of a person that's good
facilitates a person's coping social
support and identity exploration and
development good that's what we do
including sexual orientation neutral
interventions
which as dr jamison pointed out we don't
quite know what that is but i think we
could basically say let's try not offend
anyone would be your operating
definition
and the last one is as long as such
counseling does not seek to change an
individual's sexual orientation or
gender identity
well here we have this seek to change
problem uh which i go into talking about
in the next section is that you cannot
really define intent
and make that the offense
intent how do you how do you find out
what someone's intent is is you infer it
from a whole bunch of things that they
do
and to know what happens in therapy i
think you probably can imagine you've
seen bob newhart
when you're in therapy you talk about
things and the therapist gives you
reflections back oh i i can't stand how
it is at home it sounds like you're
having difficulties at home you know
it's it's all re-characterizing and and
and giving the
the
the minor or the adult the opportunity
to hear their words back at them so they
can reflect at them now what if the
child says i can't stand my lesbian
feelings or i really am
disgusted by some whatever they might
say if the therapist according to this
law
says it sounds like you're not
comfortable with those feelings toward
the same sex you're breaking the law
you cannot reflect on that portion of
the uh
students
the youth's
feelings they need to be able to express
all of their feelings they need all of
those aspects to be elaborated on and
and
looked at and
evaluated themselves it is against the
the um ethics of codes of all of these
professions to push your own agenda on
the kids of any age adults either it's
not allowed
but let's see we'll go to page three and
you can see in the beginning at the
middle of the page there's a little grid
but therapy conversion is limited
conversation is limited due to rsa 332l
and you can see in this the way it's
been defined
same-sex attraction cross-gender
attraction and then at the top there's
two columns positive aspects negative
aspects well according to this law
when you're talking with youth
they can talk
positively about same-sex attraction
and you can too and they can talk
positively about cross-gender attraction
and so can you as the therapist
but when you get over to the negative
aspects and goodness knows in therapy
there's a lot of negatives and teenagers
are very good at bringing them out
if they say anything about same-sex
attraction that's negative
the therapist by this law is prohibited
from saying anything about it
and you can't help them
with
their torment about this or that portion
of their
uh conflicts
you could talk about
negative aspects of cross-gender
attraction
but not the same gender attraction
unless you can have a free an open
discussion in pursuit of their truth
they won't get anywhere and you'll just
get in trouble
having served on several boards i do
know how it goes and what what would
happen if we look over to page
four in the middle how the current reg
law in practice would be handled in the
regulatory system this is my opinion
from having served on these boards
as written it provides very narrow gates
for discussing sexual issues in therapy
boards have no choice but to find guilty
those who walk into the confusion of
this minefield because it's law
if it were repealed and the practices
revert to using professional standards
which would outlaw coercion and
nasty stuff that we've heard about
if it were repealed
the boards could weigh the circumstances
and make
sure that the doctors honor the
self-determination
of the children in their care
that's what we're there for i have
included in the last several pages uh in
the appendix of my testimony
uh quotes from the standards of care
these are the portions that the each of
these boards would use
to measure
the the complaint that would come before
them if somebody felt that their
therapist
was being pushy
argumentative
judgmental um
coercive
punitive
all that stuff unaffirming
all of those things
this is these are the measures they
would use and having seen many cases of
all sorts go through i think the boards
do a pretty good job of this action and
this analysis and applying these things
and you can look through and see the
different wording the different uh
professions have it differently there's
about five professions listed there
i do want to say also
that it is a dangerous statute being so
vague
and
i'm sorry that it went through that way
i i was verbal at the onset of this but
um
it wasn't as bad as it could have been
they were going to make a misdemeanor
out of it long ago and at least that's
not in there so that's good
but this needs to be in the hand of the
professionals who do this good judgment
in their work
in regulating the licenses in new
hampshire
if apa wants to change their coding
their ethics codes to reflect certain
things stronger in this they can
i think that these cover it very
adequately i would never have done any
of the things in conversion therapy as
described at all
and i've certainly talked with a lot of
people of all ages about their gender
issues their development issues it's a
very fluid process
and dr warner we're going to have to
wrap it up because we've got a number of
people will you take some questions
doc
representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman
in your experience as a member of
various mental health boards or the
board of psychology and the board of
mental health
have you um
had the experience of people being um
receiving consequences for having
conversations with
youth about their sexual
you know their gender or sexual
orientation questioning
have you experienced people being
punished for that
it goes out
huh okay i will only be able to speak
about the things that have come into the
public domain i can't reveal
confidentiality things
but there are no cases that i'm aware of
in the public
arena
that involved this
okay
follow-up please
so
while i
while my reading of
convert what conversion therapy is not
or what is allowed is not the same as
what your reading is of it
i do agree that it's not written very
artfully
and
if the
if the ban on conversion therapy
remained in statute as is
but the wording
the wording in the previous
under the definition
if all the information was just taken
out about what
conversion therapy is not
or what is allowed
wouldn't what is allowed revert to
people's
code of ethics and to the
if we took out the definition of what
conversion therapy is not
but left in the ban on conversion
therapy or coercive therapy
would that be a solution to the problem
that you seem to you said you stopped
seeing adolescence
i i think that if you have a law that
says you you you're targeting something
and you don't define it this was their
attempt
to to define it
and if it doesn't get defined
then it's a mess also i i think that the
point is is that
all of these codes will cover all of the
problems of conversion therapy that
people have imagined
and and were afraid of
and
we do have a lot of information that
there it was not going on in new
hampshire at the time of this
legislation we're going to be moving
along quickly dr shapiro representative
shapiro follow up i'll just make one
more attempt um if if we
change the definition so that it defined
conversion therapy or coercive therapy
but didn't define the alternative
would that
have made you feel safer as a therapist
working with adolescents
i would have to see the wording for that
thank you thank you representative
weber
thank you uh so as a follow-up to that
if we left the first sentence
which you said was all right
which said the conversion therapy means
practices or treatment that seeks to
change an individual's sexual
orientation or gender
identity including efforts to change
behaviors or general or expressions or
eliminate or reduce sexual or romantic
attractions or feeling towards
individuals of the same gender
if we left that
and then we simply included
in place of the language that you're
finding troublesome
the words
conversion share therapy shall not
include counseling that honors the self
determination of minors in their care
would that not solve the problem
that could help a little bit but we do
have the problem in the first paragraph
where it says seeks to change which is
very vague um one could say that if
if a child says i don't like these these
feelings
and and the therapist says it sounds
like you don't like these feelings right
now they've just done it
i
well follow up follow up um
whether i not agree with your parsing of
the words
would it
be helpful if we made it clearer
that it is the therapist who should not
seek to change that the therapist should
follow
the questioning
or
the feelings or the concerns of the
individual being counseled that sounds
like an improvement i'd be very happy to
go over any such language thank you
representative kenner
yes actually i want to pick up it was a
good timing because in the comments you
just repeated i'm still confused because
you talk about intent and you have used
now twice that example of a person says
i'm just troubled by my
feelings uh my i think used my lesbian
feelings and you said if you reflected
well sounds like you're troubled
wouldn't you agree that the intent of
that statement is not to change a person
but to actually ask them to be more
introspective and continue talking
you're trying to encourage them to
continue to talk whereas wouldn't that
be very different than if you said well
you're absolutely right it's horrible
and disgusting that would be attempting
to change the other is attempting them
to continue to talk so i'm not quite
sure how that example says you violated
the law when you said it sounds like
you're troubled can you clarify that for
me yes i can um
what the problem is is
we're looking at this through a legal
point of view and and with
it's not your problem you know it's
you're not the one in therapy
but a child in therapy is going to
remember and
reiterate the their conversations
over and over again with various people
in their life
and we don't know what they're going to
make of it when you say it sounds like
you're troubled by those lesbian
feelings
um that they then go on to their next
person they say my therapist says i'm
troubled
and and that my lesbian feelings are are
trouble
and you know the the game of telephone
where you you're
it's going to come back because it's not
very specific and it does not allow
uh therapists to fully explore and if
you happen to say these things that are
reflections of negatives for the kids
i i think it's a very dangerous area
it gets repeated it'll get into a
complaint and then the boy is going to
say well we don't know we weren't there
we don't know what said
what's known is
the
professions have a non-coercion
angle already
in the codes in the ethical codes you're
not just to coerce your patients ever
and that's an important thing to
remember is that the boards do know how
to enforce that
representative merchant
thank you madam chair
and thank you donald trump for taking my
question
i'm reading through your testimony and
what basically comes down to when i'm
hearing
through your testimony as well
is the
concern is around this statute no way
the statute is written
where are you
i'm looking at your very first paragraph
on line one i saw page one okay
because of the faulty design and wording
of the statute that seems to be the
underlying concern
that i'm hearing through your testimony
most of today
what i'm trying to do not to parse it
but i think i'm trying to understand is
the word seek is ambiguous which is what
you pointed out
and
what we're trying to avoid or i think
you're trying to avoid we're all trying
to avoid is that someone's directing the
child to do something against the
child's wishes or against the child
and trying to find a way to understand
this because if the therapist is
directing the
child
um that seems to be
cohesion so therefore
how do we come up with this if we found
a way in a statute to address this
and the wording and so forth would we
have to repeal the statute that's what
i'm trying to get to
yes i think it needs to be repealed
because these things are already in
those ethics codes that you can see at
the end of my testimony
they all say
that you are to respect the
self-determination of your client
thanks very much thank you so much i
appreciate it
next
hi my name is dave mcpherson i'm from
hooksett i'm here to support my son
andrew over here in the corner um i'm
against this bill i'm gonna try to keep
a kind of simple uh representative
said that it was a simple bill so the
way i look at this we're a society that
wants to move forward we're here to
provide as much support as we can for
our children and our families that are
going through this
decision this uh
whatever word you want to use um we want
to move forward
i feel like repealing this bill is going
to take a step backwards in their
support that these children need
representative testerman mentioned he
was a pilot i use this analogy in a
different scenario i'm going to use it
today to kind of give you help you
in 1903 the wright brothers flew 120
feet
63 years later we walked on the moon
that's technology that's advancement
that's moving forward if we think of
where the lgbt community was 63 years
ago and where we are today we are
literally walking on the moon in the
lgbtq community today
we've put
citizens in space in the last two years
we are talking about flying and manned
missions to mars that's technology
that's moving forward where will we be
in another 50 years in the lgbtq btq
community
we need to repeal this so that we have
the ability to continue to move forward
in that progression
thank you
thank you very much
next let's see i don't know if i see him
next uh the chair will call
representative kurt wilper or is he out
in the hall
okay
um then let's call dr jillian um
sorry
okay if you don't mind i'll take this
off so you can hear me hopefully a
little bit clearer
good afternoon everybody thank you for
your time i appreciate what we've been
kind of doing here for the past little
bit
um
my name is dr jillian schilleber i'm a
licensed clinical psychologist here in
the state of new hampshire and i
appreciate a couple of questions we're
asked what are psychologists doing now
as a result of this bill that was passed
into law and so now we're trying to
repeal it so i'm happy to speak to that
but i just want to say for the record i
don't practice conversion therapy i
think you've heard that most of us say
we don't do that
um and there's a reason why
which i'll get to in a minute but what i
want to acknowledge is that this bill
isn't just about conversion therapy if
it was nobody would be testifying to
repeal
the law
what this bill does it actually seeks to
reinstate client autonomy
and dignity that was stripped away
from the law when gender and sexuality
was over regulated by the law that's
currently on the books
as you've heard we have various every
you know american counseling association
american psychological association all
the outfits right we all have ethical
codes that that guide our decision
making in the therapy environment
so
we don't push an agenda as mental health
professionals that's not why we got our
degrees that's not why we're helping
people
but the current law actually pushes an
agenda of limiting mental health
professionals such as professionals such
as myself to only talk about one
possibility for an individual seeking
help okay but this bill allows mental
health providers to meet the needs of
the clients who are seeking who are
questioning who are deciding who they
are
in a safe space devoid of judgment
it's my opinion that individuals can be
more harmed when they don't have that
opportunity when they can't talk through
deeply personal decisions with a neutral
party who is not their family who is not
their friends
somebody who can say kind of actually
what somebody had said like it sounds
like you're feeling conflicted like
would you want to explore that with me
and sometimes they will
and sometimes they won't because they
don't trust you yet it's a lot of hard
work working with youngsters
um it's easier for me because people
don't believe how old i am
you're probably like oh she's just 20.
i'm not but i'm not going to say because
i'm a lady
i would just like to say that counselors
cannot force anybody
minor
major
right
those of us over the age of 18 they
can't counselors don't force us into
doing something
however if a mental health provider is
not adhering to our ethical guidelines
that's a different story there's a
complaint process in place we already
heard about the board of psychology
which i'm thankfully not acquainted with
but i'm perplexed as to why the law was
necessary when i know we have this
system of checks and balances in place
for
if someone were to perhaps do something
they shouldn't
but i feel like this bill eliminates
unnecessary and harmful regulations
that's why i support it
i'm happy to talk about this further i
know legislators aren't necessarily
psychologists so if you have any
questions about therapy if i could kind
of talk through some of that
i would be willing to answer questions
any questions
representative gay
thank you mr chairman
what part of the current law
is
the the poison pen
that prohibits you
from
allowing people and reflecting
any other thought besides
besides what seems to be
the only the only acceptable
outcome
yeah so i echo the concern is it still
on about seeks to change um in the sense
of
counseling is about changing it's about
growing it's about becoming who you are
and as
you know now as adults that change
process is much narrower in the sense of
you know maybe i want to change how i
respond and anger to my kids when they
do something they shouldn't
whereas now in adolescence it might be
like
you know i want to change who my friend
group is like how do i break out of this
situation
and so it's kind of like
what does that mean like what does it
mean to to for
the law makes it feel like to me
that if i were to say to somebody like
okay you're wrestling with whatever this
is sexuality sexuality gender stuff
anything with in the realm of gender
sexuality
if they were to go back to their friends
and say i'm talking with a therapist
about
becoming let's say straight
right and i would say well but that's
not what we're doing like that's not my
my goal my goal is to support you where
you are in your gender and sexuality as
it evolves and changes
but that
this kind of limitation it feels it's
kind of like if somebody were to come
into your bedroom it's like that i'm a
psychologist and i'm here and i'm
counseling with people and we're working
together and but now i'm worried about
like
who else is in the room with me
it's not just about me and the client
anymore it's like am i adhering to this
law am i saying too much am i saying too
little it feels intrusive
it kind of it's i don't know if i'm
being clear about how i'm feeling but
to the point i haven't seen adolescents
since this bill passed
thank you we're going to be moving along
appreciate that answer i see no other
hands up so thank you doctor so much for
coming before us and now we're at that
magic time in a hearing where the clock
is ticking and the pink cards are many
and i looked through them and most
people asked for either two or three
minutes and in the grand tradition of
this place of trying to square circles
everybody now coming up will be given
two minutes 30 seconds we have a device
here
it makes a very pleasant noise at 2
minutes 30 and at which point i'm going
to sort of wave at you and you've got 15
minutes 50 whoa
seconds
go with what as i tell my wife go with
what i think not what i say
and
the first one to come on up is
emma savigny from concord and new
futures
and the clock starts
once she's seated
perfect
i'll be brief
do you remember hello members of the
committee chairperson pearson thank you
for having me
my name is emma savini i am a children's
behavioral health policy coordinator at
new futures new futures is a
non-partisan nonprofit organization that
advocates educates and collaborates
collaborates to improve the health and
wellness of all granite staters
new future strongly opposes house bill
1077 because it would remove a key
protection for youth identifying as lgbt
plus from harmful treatment that has
been shown to negatively impact
participants
conversion therapy is widely discredited
often cruel treatment and i use that
term loosely that is banned
internationally
in fact the
united nations has put put forth a
um recommendation for a universal
ban on conversion therapy across all
nations not just in america
and i've cited that in my testimony
identifying as being lesbian gay or
bisexual has not been considered a
mental illness by mental health
practitioners in over 45 years
according to
the apa the american psychiatric
association there's no data to
support that this conversion therapy
treats or cures
sexual preferences
however even the least
invasive forms of conversion therapy can
be extremely detrimental to participants
the american
psychological association
american psychiatric association academy
of child and adolescent psychiatry all
support the ban on conversion therapy
for youth conversion therapy poses a
risk
of family rejection and as holly from
nami mentioned
this
can create a whole host of long-term
psychological damages for children
they are a
higher risk of suicide
depression
use of illicit drugs and more likely to
report having engaged in unprotected sex
when compared to lgbt plus peers
who reported no or low levels of family
rejection
as such removing the ban on conversion
therapy not only goes against sound
psychologi scientific evidence but will
increase the chances that lgbt
plus children and youth
15 seconds to wrap up yes we'll
experience negative health outcomes
therefore new futures urges this
committee to
put this bill as itl and i'm happy to
take questions
seeing none thank you and next time you
come we owe you eight more seconds
appreciate
chair recognizes aaron
penkasic
did i get that right
wow
i'll be giving you back a minute and a
half because most of what i wanted to
say has already been said
but
you know i view the conversion therapy
as
a treatment that is
should be part of the spectrum of
offerings we have for people who are
inclined to enter the lgbtq community or
to do uh
sex change i don't have strong feelings
about these people one way or another
they can do what they want it's fine
with me right but i think that uh the
kids need to have all the options
presented to them they are at a point in
their life where they're confused
vulnerable uh to suggestions and very
impressionable right so for us to not
offer all available options including
instances where someone may have
unwanted confusion
about conversion or about lgbtq
society
they ought to be offered the option to
to work with a counselor
to be able to be
prevented from entering those things if
that's what they want and by the law
that we currently have in place we're
removing that option from the table for
those kids
right so i think we need to we need to
pass this bill um you know the the
decisions that are being made here
remember these are kids right our life
threat are life-altering and in most
cases irreversible
right so the decisions that are made
here these kids are not going to be able
to back out of them later in life if
they want to and i've seen videos of
of of kids who
have been 95 through the conversion
process and then change their mind when
they're an adult and they're trying to
deconvert
and they're a mess
and talk about suicide rates you know
that's that's there we need
comprehensive therapy therapy for these
kids that includes all options not
ideology and i'll give back the rest of
my time thank you very much sir
the chair recognizes dr jennifer smith
from pembroke
chair recognizes
frank
connect
mr chairman members of the committee
thank you so much for the opportunity to
testify my name is frank knack policy
director with the aclu of south carolina
new hampshire
and uh we are here in opposition to this
bill
um
we've already talked about most of the
reasons why we have concerns with this
legislation um i'll focus on one thing i
feel like this conversation we've really
conflated two things we've completed
therapy with junk science
conversion therapy is junk science
this is not me the aclu saying this
a number of the organizations national
medical association has already been
mentioned
but conversion therapy is based on
understanding of sexual orientation that
has been rejected by major health and
mental health
major health and mental health
professions
including as i've already been mentioned
the american medical association medical
american psychological association
american psychiatric association in
addition to those the american academy
of pediatrics the american counseling
association the national association of
school psychologists the national
association of social workers the
american school
school of council the american school of
counselor associations
again this is not aclu these are the
major medical associations of our
country have come out and said again
that this is not therapy we're talking
about this is junk science we're talking
about
it's important that we don't allow junk
science into medical profession and the
replicable harm is nami mentioned that
this can have
on kids in our community so thank you
and we hope that you oppose this bill
thank you thank you very much
thank you
chair recognizes david
schweineveld
how'd i do
david was okay i got that david
okay just ignore the spelling dutch name
yeah yeah
very nice uh
sorry
good afternoon my name is david
swanebelt i'm also a law student here at
unh franklin pierce i've read hp 1077 as
well as rsa 332 l and i hope you'll
consider my words in support of hb-1077
in my opinion house bill 1077 should
pass for three primary reasons one new
hampshire's conversion ban prevents
willing participants from exercising
their constitutionally recognized right
to conscience
two new hampshire's conversion therapy
bans is currently defined can negatively
impact children particularly children
diagnosed with gender dysphoria
and three when the state takes away
choices from doctors and professionals
parents lose as well
first conversion bands restrict willing
participants from exercising their
unalienable constitutionally recognized
rights of conscience
advocates describe so-called conversion
therapy as a discredited practice linked
to physical abuse drug use and suicide
and they point to politicized statements
from medical associations and activist
groups to support these claims
although it is possible to find
instances of physical abuse and
otherwise clearly harmful practices
which can and should be prosecuted under
existing law conversion therapy bans as
they are currently advocated for are not
targeted at particular practices but
instead of particular values
advocates for so-called conversion
therapy bans impose legal restrictions
because they disagree with particular
views about human sexuality and biology
held by certain professionals
new hampshire's constitution recognizes
a person's inalienable light inalienable
right to one's conscience conversion
therapy bans prohibit those who wish to
seek treatment aligning with their
beliefs and desires concerning sexuality
no one is in favor of allowing any kind
of abuse to masquerade as therapy
but counseling bans are the wrong tool
for addressing actual cases of abuse
silencing speech only limits the options
of people who wish to live consistent
with what they believe about sexuality
depending on the extent to which new
hampshire's current conversion therapy
ban is enforced a paid counselor would
be banned from helping a young woman
experiencing unwanted attraction to a
close female friend
or from helping a youth experiencing
gender confusion but who has expressed
the desire to eventually marry and have
a traditional family
and a bookstore
may not be able to advertise or sell
certain books helping young people who
wish to live consistently with their
biological sex
we should take into account the
legitimate legitimate needs of those who
wish to pursue therapy that supports
their lifestyle choices even if they
don't conform to the latest cultural
trends
only then will our public policy
simultaneously protect and respect the
freedom of everyone
second conversion therapy bands have a
negative impact on children you've got
15 seconds to wrap it up okay
experiencing gender dysphoria
there's strong evidence for the
effectiveness of a watchful waiting
approach to treating gender dysphoria in
minors allowing children time and space
to come to terms with their biological
sex than pursuing aggressive permanent
interventions
and these types of therapy
types of therapies are largely precluded
by the bill as it currently stands thank
you very much do you anybody have any
questions for him uh representative
folsom
uh thank you chairman and thank you for
taking this question i'm sorry i did not
write fast enough what was your third
point just the title of your third point
of course lastly when the state takes
away choices from doctors parents lose
as well including confidence in the
system
the chair has a question i'm going back
to a phrase i think i heard
that you said that the i if i heard you
correctly the
conversion therapy ban is not directed
against practices but against values is
that what i heard you say yes that's
what i said okay thank you that's that i
had not thought of it that way before
yeah
okay thank you
oh yeah if you'd like i can submit my
please yeah okay yeah we do that yeah
the chair recognizes john d
dejoy
is it
start now
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is john
dejoy i rise today representing the new
hampshire chapter of the national
association of social workers
and the new hampshire psychological
association both of which are member
organizations representing social
workers and psychologists as you've
heard our both of our national
organizations
oppose conversion therapy and have
supported nation bands across the
country including the one here in new
hampshire
this bill
really is being mispresented
and misunderstood
this bill
seeks to ban
an intervention referred to as quote
conversion therapy
that it has since 2018 banned that
this was a it was and is a coercive
intervention
which starts from the premise that
homosexuality
or gender non-conformity is wrong
or bad or evil or whatever the term
would be that people would put on it
it seeks to protect children
from unscrupulous
purveyors
of this type of intervention that's what
it does
it does not stop
adults
from seeking out conversion therapy it
see it prevents therapists from engaging
this practice with children does not
affect what children can or cannot talk
about
it only affects the intent of the
therapist to confirm for a child that
their feelings of
gender non-conformity
or homosexuality
are bad or wrong and should be changed
as far as legislation goes this is
fairly well written
now legislation as you all know is
inherently difficult to understand i
think of conversations around rsa 126u
169b
and many other statutes
that in some cases there is many
opinions as there are people in the room
an opinion doesn't
equate to fact
it doesn't mean that's what the law says
and i guess if you if you folks truly
want to get to the bottom of whether
there are issues with this i would
encourage you to reach out to all the
mental health boards
ask the mental health boards how many
cases have been brought forward how many
clinicians have complained about i'm
going to ask you to wrap it up clarity
in
understanding this statute that is the
answer to the testimony that says this
is a problem it's not a problem
and the boards can confirm that and with
that i will end my testimony thank you
and would you take questions of course
i'm looking at the law
that my
assistant chair has up on her computer
and under item 3
it says nothing in this chapter shall be
construed to infringe on any
constitutional right including the
exercise of religion in two the people
who cannot do conversion therapy include
doctors psychologists and so on what if
there's a christian organization with a
physician does three trump two or two
trump three
it's a great question in in the
interpretation of statute um it would go
to the supreme court to determine that
and if the court is unable to determine
it would go to legislative intent which
would require us to pull up the minutes
of this
four year ago event
so
i can't answer that i can give an
opinion but my opinion is as good as
anybody else's i think i was the clerk
that year so i hope it doesn't go that
far okay thank you very much anybody
else with a question uh representative
leon thank you mr chairman and thank you
for taking this question
i'm curious if you believe that the
licensing boards are capable of
protecting children and other patients
from unscrupulous doc practitioners
thank you for the question the licensing
boards primarily are not
charged with protecting children
that's what dcyf does the licensing
boards are charged with enforcing
statute
and and board rules
in the practice of mental health
so
i don't i wouldn't suggest that the
boards are incapable of protecting kids
i would suggest that that is not their
primary charge their primary charge is
to enforce rule and law
follow-up
thank you
are you trying to say that the licensing
rules and regulations don't apply to
practitioners who are working with
children great question and thank you
very much no i it's a matter of focus
you know it's
we don't send abuse and neglect
petitions to the licensing boards we
send those to dcyf
what the licensing boards are charged
with is overseeing the the practice of
professionals
so to the extent that a complaint
of a professional practicing with
children in an unscrupulous or unethical
manner they of course would address that
but they're addressing the behavior of
the professional that is their focus and
they do that quite well
um
i i'd like to raise something i raised
one of the last times this came up
and that is as i look at
the people who are not allowed to do
conversion therapy
they're all medical and counseling
professionals
not basketball coaches
not
the nice guy who loves all the kids in
the neighborhood that's what i mean
genuinely truly so not the pastor
and as i look at this i know just enough
about counseling to know how far i
shouldn't go beyond
and if there's a child who is
really troubled and again we go back to
the confusion in the minds of a lot of
people as to what conversion therapy is
banning and what it isn't in spite of
what it says there's a lot of confusion
if somebody cannot find a
licensed trained psychotherapist
and has to go to the basketball coach or
me
i'd worry because i think a trained
therapist knows more about counseling
than i do
and so
any questions i can respond to uh well
i'm getting towards the question thank
you for reminding us of that
um
would you understand my concern should
this happen
i would understand your concerns should
it happen i would allay your concerns
that that is not what's happening it is
in fact true as as speakers have
testified that it's difficult to find a
mental health professional
it's not difficult to find a mental
health professional because they're
afraid of the statute it's difficult to
find a mental health professional
because of parity because of clawback
because of acts the ability to be
reimbursed at a fair rate for their
services that's why it's difficult to
find a mental health professional i can
in fact tell you of a survey from the
new hampshire psychological association
that a significant number of their
members and i'm not going to say a
number because i don't remember a
significant number of their members
are contemplating dis and paneling
from insurance providers and only
accepting cash because the providers are
so difficult to work with that's why
it's so difficult to find mental health
professionals
it wasn't my question but i think
representative webber did you have your
hand up
i did but i think that you've probably
answered it my question was
isn't it true that the licensing boards
are
reactive in that they react to
complaints they
don't
so
what they do depends on what somebody's
told them
yes that's accurate
thank you for your testimony thank you
chair recognizes ann marie banfield from
northampton
good evening
my name is ann marie banfield and i'm a
parental rights advocate in new
hampshire with a focus on academic
excellence in education which is why i
tend to be in the
room down the hallway
but today i do come here in support of
hb1077
let me first start out by saying that
we've all seen what i think is
considered conversion therapy on tv and
it was a shocking and abusive treatment
so i want to make it clear that in no
way do i want there to be any confusion
that this kind of behavior is acceptable
however as a parental rights advocate i
want to be very careful that we never
limit good therapy options for children
who need it and i have parents who do
come to me and i've had parents come to
me on occasion i'm going to bring that
up in my testimony
so i hear from parents who have come
into conflict with their school
counselors on how best to help their
children these are loving and caring
parents who have
seen deep-rooted issues that they want
to address through therapy these are not
parents who would agree to
what has been reported in the news not
in new hampshire
i will only support parents who are
loving and supportive of their children
no matter where that leads them
i was going to read a one-page testimony
from a parent
that came to me because of what was
happening to her daughter in their
school district because this is a
current and because the mother is a
teacher in another school district we
agreed that her testimony should be read
by me
so that it can remain anonymous but in
the interest of time i'll just turn that
into you
in addition to the situation i will
present another parent reached out to me
a few years ago based on what was
happening with her daughter and how the
school counselors were were addressing
the situation
in this case the parents had adopted a
brother and sister at a young age
the new hampshire mother knew that the
adopted children were traumatized by
sexual abuse at a very young age
when her daughter began puberty she
began also dressing as a boy
there was speculation that the girl
believed that dressing as a boy she
would appear less attractive to males
it because it was the males in her life
who had sexually abused and traumatized
her so it wasn't surprising to them that
she was acting out this way
school counselors wanted to labor label
her and treat her treat this girl
according to their will but the mother
wanted intensive therapy that would
address her sexual abuse and trauma
i tell you these stories because in both
cases in addition to what you will read
there was underlying causes for their
children their daughters to act out in a
certain way
they had underlying issues that only a
good therapist could uncover and with
the help from their therapist they had
hoped that they would be able to help
their daughters these are parents that
would love accept and value their
daughters if they were part of the lgbt
community but they were also parents who
knew that if they ignored the underlying
conditions things can get a lot worse
they knew that in order to help
for their daughters that they needed to
seek the best available therapists
so that brings me to this conversion
therapy ban
you have about 30 seconds left my
concern has always been are we going to
handcuff good therapists with this law
are we going to limit the choices for
these parents these are parents who want
no part of an abusive approach they want
to make sure that whoever they use had
the ability to practice what they can to
help these children i think we've heard
today that they're that some of them
have had their hands cuffed
tied behind their backs and that's not
helping these children and it's not
helping these families
so thank you so much
for your testimony yes thank you
chair recognizes stephen and beth scare
from nashua
and you're going to get a total of four
minutes tag team thank you
thank you for giving me a moment to
speak about this i'm concerned that laws
such as ours prevent youth with gender
dysphoria from getting the help that
they need already
there's a lot of wounded souls out there
there's there's a reddit page that has
almost 26 000 d transitioners people
regret what happened to their bodies
and they they frequently complained that
there was no one there to put the brakes
on their decisions and they they might
be mistaken
um i read the following post and i'll
just read bits about why have trans
activists pushed so hard for immediate
medicalization of anyone who is
experiencing even minor forms of gender
discomfort dysphoria encouraging a
lifestyle of doctors blood tests scans
injections surgery even more surgery
instead of just trying to talk for
therapy first
and he she goes on to say transition
should be 100 the last resort not the
first especially in the case of minors
the law that we have and i think it came
across means that we've got a
one-size-fit-all approach which is
affirmative therapy you can affirm the
identity but people are afraid to say
the opposite
so several of the transitioners on the
same site responded that their therapist
hadn't helped them explore the mental
health issues that were underlying the
dysphoria before the medicalization and
others noted in some states it's illegal
to offer help than other than
affirmative care
one detransitioner suggested if you go
to a therapist who has experience with
lgbtq people but is not gender affirming
they can help also if you're in the u.s
some states require all therapists to
obey the affirmative care model so hop
on psychology today find a therapy
therapist who's not from one of those
states and go on online sessions right
now for our youth we are one of those
states
as you've heard the other thing that
that i want to point out regarding the
uh the the experts that are against any
sort of conversion therapy if you go
back to the 2007 report of the american
psychological association task force a
pro an appropriate therapeutic response
it didn't demonstrate
that sexual orientation change efforts
were ineffective or harmful
it didn't indicate that it caused
suicide it said they couldn't determine
whether it could or couldn't and it even
went on to say that other individuals
reported that so see that sex therapy
was helpful for example it helped them
to live in a matter consistent with
their faith and to give them a chance to
be in a community of others
the fact that the recommendations of the
american psychological association and
these other groups
point the other way just show how
politicized this issues are these are
ideological conclusions they aren't
conclusion based on science and to
answer your question representative
pearson
an expert who did a study on it
said that people with the same mental
disorders
and
comorbid mental disorders young people
have the same suicide rate as those with
gender dysphoria if you controlled for
those other mental disorders a lot of
these people have ptsd
and depression and anxiety
so i encourage you not to be one of
those states that blocks people from
getting help de-politicize this process
and let our therapists make decisions so
we don't have another
25 000 people
saying what happened to my body and why
didn't anyone help me so thank you team
scare has
38 seconds
left just for me
no either one of you okay
um
so um in 2018
governor sununu signed the
unconstitutional conversion therapy ban
into law
and it bans therapists from helping
confuse
kids and teens to explore whether their
same-sex
attraction or opposite sex gender
eternity is something they want to keep
or change
this law puts kids and teens on a
one-way street with no turning back
my niece who grew up in a dysfunctional
family situation went on testosterone as
a 17 year old she thought it would solve
her problems but it only made them worse
15 seconds to go died at 21 from a drug
overdose
and um kerry stella a young woman a d
transitioner said they don't tell you
it's okay to be butch to be gender
non-conforming to not like men to not
like the way men treat you they tell you
about testosterone
and she asks how many other medical
conditions are there where you can walk
into the doctor's office tell them you
have a certain condition which has no
objective tests which can be caused by
trauma or mental health i'm going to cut
you off now because you've exceeded your
time thank you so much for coming
the chair recognizes andrew macpherson
hi um i would just like to start off
with
so far i've noticed that a lot of these
people aren't
testifying aren't children and i'm still
technically a my technically a minor 17
years old and i'm part of the lgbtq plus
community i
is that better
um i am both transgender and bisexual
and
to
consider conversion therapy to make it
legal is absolutely absurd in my eyes
um
i currently attend i currently see two
different therapists
i saw one prior to the ban on conversion
therapy in new hampshire
since that went into effect the way she
talked to me and the way she discussed
my sexuality um and when i brought it up
to her did not change at all
she let me talk she let me lead the
conversation she
just followed what i wanted to talk to
her about she did not
push me to do anything that i did not
want to do
um
i would also like to point out that
conversion therapy is also known as
it's known as something else but
reputation therapy something like that
anyway that means to repair which
infers that
homosexuality and being transgender is
something to be fixed
it is not 100 something to be fixed you
can go back thousands of years and it's
always been something that's been around
in the world
it's also been recognized in 450
different animal species and i would
also like to point out that there's only
one species that
has hate against these these kinds of
people and that is the human species
and to
make conversion therapy which
yes
there are instances where there it isn't
physical or emotional or verbal abuse
but i've heard read and seen stories of
people being sexually assaulted getting
sexually assaulted verbally assaulted
emotionally assaulted i've even heard
cases of people being raped just to fix
them
and that is absolutely
insane to me you cannot change it's not
something we choose it's something we
were born as
and
to imply that certain people have that
certain people can be fixed
is absolutely insane thank you
thank you so much for coming
chris erchol
and pardon me if i mispronounced your
name
and once you seated you got
two minutes and 10 seconds
thank you chairman thank you members of
the committee um my name is chris
urchill i'm a
civil rights attorney at glad in boston
new hampshire licensed attorney i'm
going to withhold my written testimony
because i'm going to write something
that's more responsive to the discussion
that we heard in this room and i'll
email it to you at a later date um
a little over 20 years ago when i was a
teenager um a different century but not
that long ago really
my mom found a note
from me to my boyfriend at the time
and um that's how she found out that i
was gay the next day i was in my dad's
pickup truck on the way to tombstone
arizona that's where i grew up in
southern arizona
um he took me to see a priest um
as soon as i was alone with that priest
he said
to me you're gonna be okay and thank god
he did that could have gone a different
way um
i was supported in the moment when i
needed to be my parents loved me very
much but they did not know uh they did
not know that the that conversion
therapy was the wrong choice for me and
and that and that it was and it was
wrong it was only 20 years ago but this
was widely understood at the time to be
the way you treat people who are lgbtq
conservative religious but also other
people who weren't conservative or
religious thought that the way you
treated um people who are who are who
are same-sex attracted or transgender
was to provide them with conversion
therapy to change the way that they felt
i've been hearing so many people in this
room today saying that this it's wild to
think that anyone would want to like
coerce someone so people who are really
in support of this bill are saying no no
nobody wants to coerce anybody to change
their sexual orientation or gender
identity but that's absolutely false
because up until very recently it was
ubiquitous treatment for lgbtq people
across the country to go through
electroshock therapy to go through uh
forced viewing of pornography to go
through uh lobotomies even it's not that
much far in our in our past that this
was happening ubiquitously so to hear
people today saying like oh nobody
believes that or supports that that's
great it's great that we've gotten to
this overwhelming consensus that that is
a debunked um way of treating people but
it is not a uniform universal way of
thinking and it's not that far in our
past okay so when the bill was passed in
2018 to ban conversion therapy it was
necessary and the circumstances today
have not changed there are still people
all over the country including in new
hampshire who are sending their kids to
places where they can get conversion
therapy treatment and um and and we need
to make sure that it's not possible in
as many places as we can and here in new
hampshire it's been banned you do not
want to be one of the one state to go
back no state has so far repealed its
ban you don't want to be the one state
to do that
thank you counselor will you take
questions i would love to take questions
if anyone has any
none thank you for driving you drove up
from boston yeah
say hi to the red sox tell him to stop
the strike all right i'll see you next
week yes sir
chair recognizes matthew rice uh it
looks like there's something else there
or is there some yeah
okay
we'll say hi mom anyway
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee for giving me the opportunity
to speak here today um originally i came
straight from school so forgive me if my
words are a little less prepared than
other testimonies here today we came
straight from work so oh yeah
but
i come here to speak today as a
concerned peer of lgbt
teenagers a teenager myself and most
importantly a concerned elder brother of
a sibling who is questioning their
gender identity
looking at the writing of this bill or
the law that we're seeking to repeal
essentially what i see is that
the only therapy allowed in regards to
gender identity within the state of new
hampshire is now affirmation therapy
which
when it comes down to it is constantly
saying yes and agreeing with a
self-diagnosis from a child
now at the end of the day i just want to
ask the question why it's a question
that children ask their parents every
day and that now
we should open up the opportunity for
parents and the children's therapist to
ask them why they feel that way with
affirmation therapy being the only legal
therapy allowed for
gender
gender non-conforming kids within the
state
essentially
they're no longer allowed to ask why
they feel that way and it's something
that allows for not as deep a level of
care
and
therapy is some place where people learn
to self-reflect and have someone help
them through that process of growing and
in the wording of the bill or the law it
says that
therapists are not allowed to attempt to
change
a person's gender identity or sexual
attractions but the whole point of
therapy
is to change as a person it's to get
over fears it's to gain a better
understanding of yourself
and so i support the repealing of that
law and this bill because as someone
that has gone through therapy therapists
should be able to have the ability to go
into a deeper level of self-reflection
over the issues that
lgbt youth
um
would you take some questions from the
group here yeah i would be fine with
that uh representative delemus
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question it's going to be
really simple how old are you and did
you have you come out of high school
where are you um
i'm 18 years old and i just drove up
from nashua high south i'm a senior
there
so you are impressive thank you for your
you know what you qualify for
running for the house
18. i've considered it but the award
will be pay money
i've considered it
any other
questions representative not around them
thank you what ward do you live in
um being a representative from nashua
i'm not quite sure um ward five
okay
down on the hollis border so all right
thank you yeah don't run against her but
you can run yeah did you have a question
well i'm moving up to durham in a little
bit so maybe i'll run oh
yeah college
don't run
do you have a question anybody else have
a question
okay cignan thank you so much and thanks
mom
thank you
i went to leominster high when i was
growing up our first game was nashua
they all when you had one high school
and a bazillion football players you
always beat us it was unfair
chair recognizes shannon mcginley
good afternoon i'm well aware that it is
five o'clock so i have scribbled out my
testimony to try to
to shorten it here good afternoon mr
chairman and members of the committee i
am shannon mcginley i'm the volunteer
executive director of cornerstone action
a christian
based organization based here in new
hampshire i'm asking you to vote ought
to pass on hp 1077. it's been three
years now since chapter 3
32-l officially became law the bill
where this law first arrived was first
introduced in 2017
and i was in this seat before many of
you
pleading to not pass this law the law
violates the constitutional rights of
minors and their right to set their
therapeutic goals and violates the
constitutional rights of licensed
therapists i want to address the harmful
effects of this law on both sides of the
clearance the client therapist
relationship
i come before you with a heavy heart
knowing the pain that this law has
caused innumerable families and children
families have reached out to us at
cornerstone asking for help a referral
to a therapist who can help their child
yet there are no therapists in new
hampshire allowed to assist because our
law won't allow for it
for example if a christian teen is
experiencing feelings that are contrary
to their religious beliefs and life
goals they might want to talk to a
professional to help them work through
those issues but under this law they are
not allowed to
i spoke with some individuals who have
been helped through same-sex attraction
or gender dysphoria but the challenges
they face are deeply private because of
this they do not want to come to a
public committee hearing to tell of
their personal stories and so i'm here
in on behalf of them the law is in
violation of our state constitution
freedom of speech and freedom of
religion why don't we challenge the
court the law in court we shouldn't have
to sue in a state known for valuing
liberty how it is is it that we have a
law we know violates the first amendment
this law disregards the rights of young
people to set their therapeutic goals
and undermining the ability of
therapists to do their job there are
multiple examples of these kinds of
bands being overtuned turned on grounds
that violate the free speech of
therapists and the religious freedom of
both therapists and minors tampa florida
palm beach county bands have all been
overturned as well as new york city the
rulings in some of these cases
referenced a case out of california the
national institute of family and life
abacus versus becerra it's also known as
nifla a u.s supreme court decision
handed down in june of 2018 the court
said that crisis pregnancy centers which
aim to persuade women to continue their
pregnancies cannot be required to tell
their patients about the availability of
state offered services including
abortion
a washington post article from february
the 1st
2019 said that the crisis pregnancy
centers had argued that a california law
violates their first amendment free
speech and in a 5-4 decision the supreme
court agreed justice clarence thomas
wrote that in in that speech quote it is
not unprotected merely because it is
uttered by professionals end quote in a
concurring opinion justice anthony
kennedy wrote the law wrote that the law
was quote paradogmatic
paragmatic example of the serious threat
presented when government seeks to
impose its own message in the place of
individual speech thought and expression
in closing no government has has no bus
the government has no business in
eavesdropping inside of the counseling
session between a counselor and a client
thank you for your service and i ask you
to please vote to pass hb 1077. any
questions for ms mcginley
all right thank you seeing none thank
you and i closed the hearing on house
bill
1077 and please committee attend to the
announcement that the clerk has a
message from your clerk several people
have said they handed me their testimony
what i've asked them to do is um to
email it to you so
since it will be an electronic format so
i don't have to spend my life in the
copy room next door
thank you in the next meeting of this
committee there is a work group at 8 30
next tuesday morning the next time we
meet is 9 30 tuesday monday is a holiday
drive safely
you